SENATE BUDGET, SUB-COMMITTEE TWO
ON RESOURCES, ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AND ENERGY WILL COME
TO ORDER. WE ARE HOLDING THESE
HEARINGS IN THE Ó STREET
BUILDING. UH, ASK ALL MEMBERS
SUB COMMITTEE PRESENT SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A CO AND BEGIN OUR
HEARING. FIRST OF ALL. THANK YOU
, UH, GREAT INTEREST IN, UH,
THIS COMMITTEE THIS YEAR
REPRESENTED BY ALL THE FOLKS
HERE TODAY. THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HERE. I'D LIKE TO START
OUT WITH A FEW, UH, INTRODUCTORY
REMARKS. IN THE PAST FEW YEARS,
UH, CALIFORNIA HAS MADE, UM
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS. BY SETTING
NEW GOALS TO FIGHT AND PREPARE
FOR CLIMATE CHANGE. AND WE ALSO
PROVIDED UNPRECEDENTED SPENDING
TO ACHIEVE THAT PROGRESS. AND
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCY.
FOR EXAMPLE, WE HAVE AMBITIOUS
GOALS TO IMPROVE. RESILIENCY AND
AIMING TO SCALE UP FOREST
MANAGEMENT TO MEET THE STATE AND
FEDERAL 1 MILLION ACRE ANNUAL
RESTORATION TARGET BY 2025. TO
GET THERE. WE'VE COMMITTED OVER
2.8. BILLION DOLLARS IN FOREST
HEALTH AND WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
IN RECENT CLIMATE BUDGETS. AND
CLEAN ENERGY. WE'VE HIGH
STANDARDS AS WELL. S¼ B 100,
REQUIRING ALL RETAIL ELECTRICITY
SOLD. IN CALIFORNIA WE POWERED
WITH RENEWABLE AND ZERO CARBON
RESOURCES BY 2045. AND TO MEET
THAT GOAL. WE'VE INVESTED NEARLY
$8 BILLION FOR CLEAN ENERGY,
ENERGY RELIABILITY, ENERGY
AFFORDABILITY PROGRAMS. AND
FINALLY REGARDING EMISSIONS. WE
HAVE ONE OF THE WORLD'S MOST
AMBITIOUS EMISSION REDUCTION
GOALS. AIMING AT 48% BELOW 1990
LEVELS BY 2030 85% BY 2045. THAT
IS A GOAL THAT IS GOING TO BE A
STRETCH GOAL. AND, UM IN LINE
WITH THAT OUR RECENT CLIMATE
BUDGETS HAVE INCLUDED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO DECARBONIZE CROSS
TRANSPORTATION, BUILDINGS,
ENERGY, AGRICULTURE AND OTHER
VARIOUS SECTORS, AS WELL AS
INVESTING IN KEY TECHNOLOGIES
AND STRATEGIES THAT WE NEED TO
GET THERE. BUT IN ORDER TO MEET
THOSE GOALS WE NEED URGENT
POLICY AND BUDGET ACTION TO
CONTINUE AGGRESSIVELY REDUCING
EMISSIONS AND PROTECTING OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES. HOWEVER, WE
ALL KNOW THAT THIS CAN BE A
TOUGH BUDGET YEAR AHEAD. THEY
RECENTLY CAME OUT WITH ESTIMATED
DEFICIT OF 70 THREE BILLION
DOLLARS UNDER THEIR UPDATED
REVENUE FORECAST. ALL OF THE
PROPOSED CUTS SHIFT AND DELAYS.
IN THESE AREAS IN OUR AREAS AND
OTHER AREAS ARE GOING TO BE
PAINFUL DECISIONS. MY PRIORITY.
IS THAT THIS SUB COMMITTEE? UH
WORKING WITH MY COLLEAGUES, SO
WE MAKE DECISIONS CAREFULLY AND
THOUGHTFULLY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE SMART AND
IMPACTFUL CLIMATE INVESTMENTS.
IN A TIME OF BUDGET DIFFICULTY,
WE WILL NEED TO PRIORITIZE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE. PROGRAMS TO
MAXIMIZE THE IMPACT OF OUR STATE
DOLLARS IN REACHING OUR
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS. WITH
THAT. I'D LIKE TO WELCOME TWO
NEW MEMBERS TO OUR
SUB-COMMITTEE. SENATOR
BLAKESPEAR AND SENATOR ALLEN.
WELCOME TO SUB TWO AND WE
WELCOME BACK. UH, SENATOR DOLLY,
WHO WILL BE WITH US SHORTLY. UM,
WHAT OTHER PEOPLE LIKE TO SAY
ANY OPEN REMARKS BEFORE WE GET
STARTED? OK? RIGHT? UM WITH
THAT, LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
BECKER. HERE BECKER HERE, ALAN
ALAN HERE, BLAKESPEAR.
BLAKESPEAR HERE, DOLLY!
REQUIREMENTS ESTABLISHED. A
CHAIR HERE WILL FOCUS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SOLUTIONS AND
CLIMATE, NATURAL RESOURCES,
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AND ENERGY
, THE HISTORICAL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT WE APPROVED IN 2021
AND 2022 BUDGET ACTS SPANS
ACROSS MANY AREAS, INCLUDING
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES, ENERGY,
WATER AND DROUGHT, WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCE, NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS, EXTREME HEAT,
CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND MANY MORE.
UH, WE ARE. UH, TODAY WE ARE
FIRST HERE FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE, FOLLOWED BY THE L A
Ó AND THEN MEMBERS WILL HAVE
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS,
AND WE ALSO HAVE SEVERAL DO. UH,
SEVERAL DEPARTMENTS ARE HERE AND
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AGAIN. WE THANK ALL OF YOU, UH,
FOR BEING HERE, UM, OUR FIRST
PRESENTER WILL BE, UH, SERGIO
AGUILAR REPRESENT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE, AND HE'LL PROVIDE US AN
OVERVIEW OF THE GOVERNOR'S
CLIMATE BUDGET SOLUTIONS.
WELCOME. STRAGGLER CAN START
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
UH, GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBER,
SIR AGUILAR DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. NOW JORDAN HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE STEVEN BENSON, ALSO
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, SO
WE'RE GOING TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE CLIMATE BUDGET
AND ASSOCIATED GENERAL FUND
SOLUTIONS. AND AS YOU MENTIONED,
WE DO HAVE COLLEAGUES FROM THE
VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS HERE WITH US
TODAY, UM, WHO WILL BE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE ON A SPECIFIC
PROGRAM THAT ARE IMPACTED AND
ASSOCIATED POLICIES. SO THE
STATE FACES UH UH, BUDGET THAT
MUST SOLVE BOTH FOR LAST YEAR'S
DEFICIT, WILL ALSO ADJUSTING
SAFE SPENDING TO SUPPORT
CONTINUED FISCAL STABILITY. AND
EVEN AS THE STATE FACES A $37.9
SHORTFALL, CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO FULFILL MANY PROMISES MADE
WHILE RESPONSIBLY MANAGING
FINANCES. UH AND WHILE CLOSING A
SHORTFALL OF 37.9 BILLION POSES
A SUBSTANTIAL CHALLENGE, IT IS
MORE MANUAL BECAUSE OF THE
STATE'S OVERSIGHT AND BUILDING
SOME HISTORIC RESERVES,
HISTORICAL OR OTHER LEVELS IN
2023. SO THE 2021 AND 2022
BUDGET ACTS TOGETHER, UH,
ALLOCATED APPROXIMATELY $54
BILLION OVER FIVE YEARS ACROSS
MANY DIFFERENT, UH, CLIMATE, UH,
PRIORITIES TO ADVANCE STATE
CLIMATE AGENDA. AND THE BUDGET
MAINTAINED APPROXIMATELY 48
POINT THREE BILLION OF THAT 54
BILLION INVESTMENT, WHICH IS
ALMOST 90% OVER A SEVEN YEAR
PERIOD. AND OF THE $48 BILLION.
APPROXIMATELY 36 HAS ALREADY
BEEN ALLOCATED TO PROGRAMS AND
THE REMAINING 12.4 IS SET TO BE
ALLOCATED OVER THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS. UH, NOW THIS BUDGET
PRIORITIZES EQUITY AND
INVESTMENTS IN, UH, POPULATIONS
FACING DISPROPORTIONATE HARM
FROM POLLUTION, AND ALSO THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. UH, AND THE
BUDGET DOES INCLUDE, UH, IN SOME
CASES, SOME ADDITIONAL SPENDING.
THERE'S ABOUT 100 AND 60 MILLION
IN ADDITIONAL NEW CLIMATE
SPENDING PRIMARILY IN FLOOD AND
SALT AND SEA. UH AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ALSO CONTINUES TO
LEVERAGE AND PURSUE AVAILABLE
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA,
INCLUDING FUNDING FROM THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND JOBS ACT.
AND AS OF THE BEGINNING OF THE
YEAR, UH, THE STATES PREDICTED
TO RECEIVE, UH, AT LEAST $15.5
BILLION, AND THAT INCLUDES BOTH
FORMULA AND ALSO COMPETITIVE
FUNDING THAT HAVE BEEN AWARDED.
UH FROM BOTH OF THESE, UH LARGE
FEDERAL PIZZAS, LEGISLATION
ACROSS MANY DIFFERENT CLIMATE
AND ENVIRONMENTAL, UH,
PROTECTION PROGRAMS, AND THIS
NUMBER IS EXPECTED TO CONTINUE
INCREASING HAS MORE FEDERAL
WORDS ARE ANNOUNCED, AND MORE
OPPORTUNITIES ARE MADE AVAILABLE
FOR CALIFORNIA AND ENTITIES IN
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE TO APPLY.
SO TO ADDRESS THE PROJECTED
BUDGET SHORTFALL. THE BUDGET
PROPOSES A BALANCED COMBINATION
OF SOLUTIONS THAT INCLUDES $6.7
BILLION IN GENERAL FUND
SOLUTIONS, UH, RELATED TO
CLIMATE PROGRAMS AND OF THE SIX
POINT 7,000,000,002 0.9 BILLION
ARE REDUCTIONS. UH, 1.9 BILLION
ARE DELAYS TO FUTURE YEARS AND
1.8 BILLION ARE FUN SHIFTS, AND
THOSE FUN SHIFTS ARE PRIMARILY
TO THE GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUND. THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
APPROXIMATELY 565 MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL NON CLIMATE RELATED
GENERAL FUND SOLUTIONS IN
NATURAL RESOURCES, ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION RELATED PROGRAMS. AND
OF THAT THREE 150 MILLION IS A
REVENUE BORROWING. 100 AND 75
MILLION OR DELAYS AND THEN
APPROXIMATE, UH, 40 MILLION ARE
REDUCTIONS. SO WHEN LOOKING AT
YOU KNOW HOW THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERED THE VARIOUS GENERAL
SOLUTIONS. UH, THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD A GENERAL
FRAMEWORK AS WE WERE LOOKING AT
THE VARIOUS CLIMATE AND
RESOURCES PROGRAMS AND THINKING
THROUGH. UH YOU KNOW HOW HOW TO
SOLVE THE BUDGET DEFICIT. SO
FIRST WE IDENTIFIED, UH, WHAT
PROGRAMS HAD AVAILABLE FUNDING
THAT HAD NOT BEEN COMMITTED YET.
SO AS I MENTIONED EARLIER, ABOUT
$36 BILLION HAS ACTUALLY ALREADY
BEEN APPROPRIATED THE
DEPARTMENTS, UH, WHICH A LOT OF
THE FUNDING HAS ACTUALLY ALREADY
BEEN COMMITTED. AND HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED OUT IN AWARDS AND
GRANTS AND ARE NÓ LONGER
AVAILABLE. UH SO WE LOOK AT THE
STATUS OF ALL THOSE PREVIOUSLY
APPROPRIATED PROGRAMS TO SEE HOW
MUCH FUNDING IS AVAILABLE BY
FISCAL YEAR. UM AND YOU KNOW
WHAT HAS BEEN COMMITTED. WHAT
AWARDS HAVE BEEN ANNOUNCED. WHAT
UH, YOU KNOW, UPCOMING WORDS ARE
, UM, GONNA BE ANNOUNCED SOON,
UH, TO DETERMINE YOU KNOW WHERE
THERE IS STILL FUNDING AVAILABLE
WE LOOKED AT. WHERE ARE THOSE
POTENTIAL TO SHIFT TO OTHER
FUNDS AND ALSO POTENTIAL TO
LEVERAGE? UH, ADDITIONAL, UH,
FEDERAL UM AND ALSO LOOKING AT
DELAYS. UH, SO, UH, YOU KNOW,
OVER HALF OF THE CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS ARE ARE EITHER DELAYED
OR FUN SHIFTS, WHICH THAT
ENABLES US TO PROTECT THOSE
COMMITMENTS BY THEIR DELAYING
THEM TO FUTURE YEAR OR MOVING
THEM TO THE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND SO THEY COULD
CONTINUE BEING SUPPORTED. UH, WE
ALSO CONSIDERED, UH, PREVIOUS
REDUCTIONS AND THE OVERALL LEVEL
THAT HAS BEEN MAINTAINED FOR
SOME OF THESE PROGRAMS. UH, SO
LAST YEAR, THERE WAS ALSO A
BUDGET DEFICIT. AND THERE WERE
ALSO SOME, UH, TOUGH REDUCTIONS
THAT THAT WE HAD TO MAKE TO
CERTAIN PROGRAMS. UH, SO WE TOOK
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION AS WE
WERE LOOKING AT WHAT ADDITIONAL
REDUCTIONS COULD BE MADE THIS
YEAR? UH, AND SOLUTIONS COULD BE
MADE THIS YEAR IN ORDER TO SOLVE
THE BUDGET DEFICIT. UH, OF
COURSE, LOOKING AT, UH, TRYING
TO PRIORITIZE PROGRAMS THAT
EQUITY AND SUPPORT POPULATIONS
THAT ARE MORE DISPROPORTIONATELY
HARMED FROM POLLUTION AND THE
CLIMATE CRISIS. AND ALSO LOOKING
AT PROTECTING, UH, FUNDING THAT
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE MORE
IMMEDIATE CLIMATE RISKS SUCH AS
WILDFIRE AND SUCH AS WATER, UH,
WHICH WHICH ALIGN WITH SOME OF
THE MOST HIGHEST PRIORITIES AND
THEN AGAIN, YOU KNOW, LOOKING AT
FEDERAL INVESTMENTS, AND THERE'S
SOME AREAS WHERE THERE IS, YOU
KNOW, MORE DIRECT, UH,
CONNECTION TO A FEDERAL FUNDING
THAT COULD DIRECTLY, UH, SUPPORT
THAT, UM, YOU KNOW, RELATED
FUNDING AND OTHER AREAS WHERE
THERE ARE JUST BROAD INVESTMENTS
FROM THE FEDS COMING IN IN
CERTAIN POLICY AREAS TO AWARDEES
THROUGHOUT. THAT COULD ALSO
ADVANCE THOSE SAME GOALS AND
POLICIES EVEN THOUGH IT'S NOT
COMING THROUGH THE STATE.
ULTIMATELY UH, THERE WERE SOME
TOUGH DECISIONS THE
ADMINISTRATION HAD TO MAKE IN
ORDER TO HAVE A
CONSTITUTIONALLY, YOU KNOW,
MANDATED BALANCED BUDGET. AND I
WILL NOW PASS IT ON TO MY
COLLEAGUE STEVEN BENSON, WHO
WILL AT A HIGH LEVEL COVER BY,
YOU KNOW, A CLIMATE PROGRAMMATIC
AREA. UH, SOME OF THE GENERAL
FUND SOLUTION. DETAILS GOOD
MORNING, STEVE METZ DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. UM, I WILL LIKE HE
SEES IT. AS SERGIO SAID, DO SOME
SUMMARY OF THE PRIMARY CLIMATE
INVESTMENT CATEGORIES AND HOW
THE GENERAL FUND SOLUTIONS
IMPACT THOSE SO STARTING WITH
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES RESERVES.
THE 2122 BUDGET ACTS COMMITTED
$10 BILLION OVER FIVE YEARS FOR
INVESTMENTS IN THE STATES E
AGENDA RANGING FROM CLEANING UP
SHORT HAUL TRUCKS TO SCHOOL
BUSES TO ACCELERATING EQUITABLE
ELECTRIFICATION OF PASSENGER
VEHICLES. UH, COUPLED WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE AND INCENTIVES
FOR IN MANUFACTURING. THE BUDGET
MAINTAINS ALL 10 BILLION, BUT
OVER A SEVEN YEAR PERIOD, SO
ESSENTIALLY STRETCHING IT OUT
OVER A COUPLE OF YEARS. UH AND
UM, WHICH INCLUDES TARGETED
INVESTMENTS AND DISADVANTAGED
AND LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES BY
INCREASING ACCESS TO THE
BENEFITS OF CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
, UM AND CONTINUING TO
DECARBONIZE, CALIFORNIA'S
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR TO IMPROVE
PUBLIC HEALTH. THE BUDGET
INCLUDES 38.1 MILLION OF GENERAL
FUND REDUCTIONS. 475 POINT THREE
MILLION IN FUND SHIFTS TO THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
AND 600 MILLION IN DELAYS ACROSS
VARIOUS PROGRAMS. UM IN THE
TRANSPORTATION AREA. THE 2022
BUDGET ACT INCLUDED 13.8 BILLION
FOR TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS THAT ALIGN WITH THE
STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS. THE
BUDGET MAINTAINS 13 POINT
6,000,000,099% OF THESE
INVESTMENTS. THE BUDGET INCLUDES
$200 MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
REDUCTIONS. 791 MILLION IN FUN
SHIFTS AND 3.1 BILLION IN DELAYS
ACROSS VARIOUS PROGRAMS. FOR
ENERGY. THE 2022 BUDGET ACT
PROVIDED A TOTAL OF 7.9 BILLION
ENERGY INVESTMENTS TO EXPEDITE
THE STATE'S TRANSITION TO CLEAN
ENERGY FUND CRITICAL GRID,
RELIABILITY PROGRAMS AND ADDRESS
ENERGY AFFORDABILITY CHALLENGES.
IN ADDITION, CHAPTER 239
STATUTES OF 2022, WHICH WAS S¼ B
846 PROPOSED $1 BILLION OVER
THREE YEARS, BEGINNING IN 2324
TO FUND INITIATIVES UNDER THE
CLEAN ENERGY RELIABILITY
INVESTMENT PLAN. WHICH IS
SUBJECT TO FUTURE APPROPRIATION.
THE BUDGET MAINTAINS
APPROXIMATELY SIX POINT
6,000,000,080 3% OF THESE
INVESTMENTS, UH, FOR OF THE PLAN
2022 ENERGY INVESTMENTS. IN
ADDITION TO THE $944 MILLION
REDUCED IN THE 2020 THREE BUDGET
ACT, THE BUDGET INCLUDES 419
MILLION IN GENO FUND REDUCTIONS.
100 AND 44 MILLION IN FUN SHIFTS
AND 505 MILLION IN DELAYS ACROSS
VARIOUS ENERGY RELATED PROGRAMS.
THE BUDGET ALSO MAINTAINS THE
PROPOSED $1 BILLION FOR CLEAN
ENERGY RELIABILITY INVESTMENT
PLAN WITH THE REMAINING AMOUNT
BEING PROPOSED OVER THREE YEARS,
BEGINNING IN 2025 26. FOR
WILDFIRE AND FOR RESILIENCE. THE
2021 AND 2002 22 BUDGET ACTS
COMMITTED 2.8 BILLION OVER FOUR
YEARS TO CONTINUE STRENGTHENING
FOREST AND WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
STATEWIDE. THE BUDGET MAINTAINS
2.7 BILLION, OR 95% OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS OVER FIVE YEARS, UM,
TO ADVANCE CRITICAL INVESTMENTS
IN RESTORING FORESTS AND WILD
WILDLAND HEALTH AND TO CONTINUE
TO REDUCE THE RISK OF CATAS
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN THE
FACE OF EXTREME CLIMATE
CONDITIONS. THE BUDGET INCLUDES
100.7 MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
REDUCTIONS. AND 162.5 MILLION IN
FUN SHIFTS ACROSS VARIOUS
PROGRAMS. IT ALSO CONTINUES THE
$200 MILLION FROM THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND THAT WAS SET
UP THROUGH, UH, INITIALLY
THROUGH S¼ B 901. AND THEN, UH,
SORT OF CONTINUED, UM IN A
CONTINUOUS APPROPRIATION. S¼ B
155. FOR DROUGHT RESPONSE AND
WATER RESILIENCE. THE 2021 AND
2022 BUDGET ACTS COMMITTED 8.7
BILLION OVER MULTIPLE YEARS TO
SUPPORT DROUGHT, RESILIENCE AND
RESPONSE PROGRAMS TO HELP
COMMUNITIES AND FISH AND
WILDLIFE AVOID IMMEDIATE IMPACTS
OF EXTREME DROUGHT WHILE
ADVANCING PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS
THAT WILL IMPROVE THE STATE'S
RESILIENCE TO FUTURE DROUGHTS
AND FLOODS. THE BUDGET MAINTAINS
SEVEN POINT THREE BILLION OR 84%
OF THESE INVESTMENTS OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS, UM, TO BOLSTER
CAPACITY OF COMMUNITIES AND
ECOSYSTEMS TO ENDURE DROUGHTS
AND FLOODS. THE BUDGET INCLUDES
796.8 MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
REDUCTIONS. 100 MILLION IN
DELAYS ACROSS VARIOUS PROGRAMS.
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES 100 AND
59.1 MILLION IN NEW INVESTMENTS
TO SUPPORT FLOOD PROTECTION,
LEVY REPAIR AND THE RESTORATION
OF THE SALTON SEA. FOR EXTREME
HEAT, THE 2021 AND 2022 BUDGET
ACTS COMMITTED 649 MILLION. THE
BUDGET MAINTAINS 364 MILLION, OR
56% OF THESE INVESTMENTS OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS. UM FOR VARIOUS
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS TO SUPPORT
EXTREME HEAT. THE BUDGET
INCLUDES $40 MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND REDUCTIONS AND 100 AND 9
MILLION IN FUN SHIFTS ACROSS
VARIOUS PROGRAMS. FOR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE. THE 2021 AND 22
BUDGET ACTS COMMITTED 101.9
SORRY BILLION OF COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE INVESTMENTS OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS TO ADVANCE
CLIMATE, RESILIENCE AND LOW
INCOME AND UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES. THE BUDGET
MAINTAINS 1.2 BILLION, OR 67% OF
THOSE INVESTMENTS OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS, UM, TO HELP CONTINUE TO
PROMOTE COMMUNITY RESILIENCE.
UH, THE BUDGET REFLECTS 89.8
MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
REDUCTIONS ACROSS THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS. FOR NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS. THE 2021 AND 22
BUDGET ACTS COMMITTED 1.6
BILLION. THE BUDGET MAINTAINS
1.4 BILLION, OR 89% OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS OVER MULTIPLE YEARS
IN A IN A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS. UH, THE BUDGET
INCLUDES 15 MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND REDUCTIONS ACROSS TWO
PROGRAMS. FOR COASTAL RESILIENCE
, THE 22,021 AND 22 BUDGET ACTS
COMMITTED ONE POINT THREE
BILLION UM, OVER MULTIPLE YEARS.
THE BUDGET MAINTAINS 660 MILLION
, OR 51% OF THOSE INVESTMENTS.
UM ALSO AGAIN OVER MULTIPLE
YEARS AND ACROSS VARIOUS
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS. THE
BUDGET REFLECTS 452 MILLION IN
GENO, FUND REDUCTIONS AND 36.8
MILLION IN GENERAL ARE IN FUN
SHIFTS, UM FOR VARIOUS COASTAL
PROTECTION ADAPTION PROGRAMS.
FOR CLIMATE, SMART AGRICULTURE,
THE 2021 AND 22 BUDGET ACTS
COMMITTED 1.1 BILLION OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS FOR CLIMATE,
SMART AGRICULTURAL INVESTMENTS
AND TO HELP FOSTER A HEALTHY,
RESILIENT AND EQUITABLE FOOD
SYSTEM. THE BUDGET MAINTAINS 1
BILLION, OR 89% OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS. THE BUDGET INCLUDES
79.1 MILLION IN GENERAL FUND
REDUCTIONS AND 24 MILLION IN FUN
SHIFTS ACROSS VARIOUS PROGRAMS.
UM, SO THAT'S IT FOR THE CLIMATE
CATEGORIES, BUT THE BUDGET ALSO
DOES INCLUDE A HANDFUL OF
GENERAL FUND SOLUTIONS THAT ARE,
UM IN THE NATURAL RESOURCES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION POLICY
AREA, BUT NOT STRICTLY THE KIND
OF CLIMATE PACKAGES AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THEM, SO I'LL TOUCH
ON THOSE JUST QUICKLY HERE, TOO.
UM THOSE INCLUDE INCLUDE, UM AND
A DELAY OF 100 AND 75 MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR THE DEPARTMENT
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES AND CONTROLS
CLEAN UP IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES INITIATIVE PROGRAM.
THE BUDGET INCLUDES 85 MILLION
IN FUNDING FOR THESE PROGRAMS IN
2526. AND 9 90 MILLION IN 2026
27. UH, FOR UNDERGROUND STORAGE
TANK CLEANUP FUND. UH, THERE.
THERE'S A LOAN A BUDGETARY LOAN
IN HERE. THAT WOULD BE 100 AND
$50 MILLION. IT ALSO INCLUDES A
ONE YEAR DELAY IN THE REPAYMENT
OF A PRIOR BUDGETARY LOAN OF
$50.7 MILLION. THAT IS FROM THE
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANK CLEANUP
FUND TO THE GENERAL FUND. UM AND
THESE FUNDS WOULD BE FROM, UH,
BALANCES WITHIN THAT FUND THAT
ARE NOT NEEDED IMMEDIATELY FOR
OPERATIONAL PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS
IN THE SHORT TERM. UM SIMILARLY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING FUND. THE
BUDGET INCLUDES A PROPOSAL OF A
BUDGETARY LOAN OF $125 MILLION,
ALONG WITH THE DEFERRAL OF A $25
MILLION BUDGETARY LOAN THAT
ALREADY EXISTS AND AGAIN, THAT
WOULD BE A LOAN FROM THE
CALIFORNIA BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING FUND TO THE GENERAL
FUND, AND IT'S FROM BALANCES IN
THAT FUND THAT ARE NOT
IMMEDIATELY NECESSARY FOR
OPERATIONAL AND PROGRAMMATIC
PURPOSES. UM IN TERMS OF OUTDOOR
EQUITY GRANT PROGRAM. THE BUDGET
INCLUDES A REDUCTION OF $25
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR OUTDOOR
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION AND
ACCESS PROGRAMS THAT ARE
SUPPORTED THROUGH THE OUTDOOR
EQUITY GRANTS PROGRAM THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED. UNDER CHAPTER 675.
THE STATUTE CHOSEN 19, WHICH IS
A B 209. THE BUDGET MAINTAINS
$90 MILLION OF GENERAL FUND
PREVIOUSLY ALLOCATED FOR THAT
PROGRAM. UM URBAN WATERFRONT
FUNDING. THE BUDGET INCLUDES A
REVERSION OF $12.3 MILLION OF
GENERAL FUNDS FROM VARIOUS
PROJECTS IN URBAN AREAS THAT ARE
ADJACENT TO RIVERS AND WATERWAYS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. UH, THE
BUDGET MAINTAINS 100 AND $42
MILLION GENERAL FUND THAT WAS
PREVIOUSLY ALLOCATED FOR THAT
PROGRAM. UM AND THEN, FINALLY,
THE FOR PESTICIDE NOTIFICATION.
THERE'S A REVERSION OF $2.6
MILLION GENERAL FUND RELATED TO,
UM, PESTICIDE NOTIFICATION
NETWORK THAT WAS PREVIOUSLY
APPROPRIATED IN THE 21 BUDGET
ACT, AND THE BUDGET MAINTAINS
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION OF THE
PREVIOUSLY ALLOCATED FUNDING FOR
THAT PURPOSE. SO THAT COMPLETES
OUR OVERVIEW. UH, PRESENTATION
AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED BY
SERGIO. UM, WE HAVE A LOT OF
STAFF HERE FROM VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS TO HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS. UM, SO ON THE ONE
HAND THAT'LL BE VERY HELPFUL FOR
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT PEOPLE HERE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS. UM, BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND, IT ALSO MEANS THAT
THERE'LL BE A LOT OF PEOPLE SORT
OF COMING UP AND DOWN. SO JUST
APOLOGIES IN ADVANCE FOR THE
MUSICAL CHAIRS THAT WILL LIKELY
ENSUE AS WE GO THROUGH THE REST
OF THE HEARING. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AGAIN, AND WE DO APPRECIATE,
UH, THE MINISTER, THE STAFF AND
THE TEAM BEING HERE. UM NOW
WE'LL GO TO, UM, M ERS OF THE L
A Ó FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING, RACHEL
E WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. I'LL BE SPEAKING FROM
THIS HANDOUT, WHICH HOPEFULLY
YOU ALL HAVE, UM, WHICH IS KIND
OF TALKING POINTS FROM THIS
LARGER REPORT. UM WHICH, UH,
HOPEFULLY YOU ALSO HAVE IN BOTH
ARE AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE FOR
OTHERS. UH, SO FIRST BEFORE
DIVING IN JUST TO GIVE A LITTLE
BIT OF CONTEXT. AS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED, WE ARE AND MY
COLLEAGUES FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. WE ARE FACING A
BUDGET SITUATION. UH, IN JANUARY
, OUR OFFICE ESTIMATED THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ADDRESSED A $58
BILLION BUDGET PROBLEM. UM THE
TECHNICAL DEFINITIONS OF WHAT'S
INCLUDED IN THAT PROBLEM. UH
KIND OF RELATE TO PROPOSITION 98
AND SCORING AND BASELINE, BUT IN
JANUARY, WE THOUGHT THERE WAS A
$58 BILLION PROBLEM AS THE CHAIR
MENTIONED BASED ON UPDATED
REVENUE INFORMATION FROM WHAT
THE STATE HAS COLLECTED AS WELL
AS ECONOMIC FACTORS. WE'VE
REVISED THAT RECENTLY, UH
ESTIMATING THAT THE STATE NOW
FACES A $73 BILLION PROBLEM TO
ADDRESS ACROSS THE THREE YEAR
PERIOD THAT THIS BUDGET WILL, UM
BE COVERING THE PRIOR YEAR.
CURRENT YEAR AND FORTHCOMING
2425 FISCAL YEAR. SO IN ADDITION
TO THAT BUDGET PROBLEM ACROSS
THIS THIS BUDGET WINDOW EVEN
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S REVENUE
ESTIMATES, AND EVEN IF YOU WERE
TO KIND OF ADOPT EVERYTHING THAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED, THE
ADMINISTRATION IS ESTIMATING
THAT WE'RE FACING 30 TO $40
BILLION ANNUAL OPERATING
DEFICITS IN EACH OF THE THREE
SUBSEQUENT FISCAL YEARS AFTER
2425, SO IT'S A IT'S A PRETTY
SUBSTANTIAL BUDGET PROBLEM AHEAD
OF US, UH AS PART OF THE TOOLS
TO ADDRESS THAT WE THINK LOOKING
AT ONE TIME FUNDING THAT WAS
APPROVED AND PLANNED AS PART OF
THE RECENT BUDGET PACKAGE MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE FOR SEVERAL
REASONS. ONE IS TO THE DEGREE
YOU REDUCE ONE TIME FUNDING. YOU
CAN PRESERVE SOME OF YOUR OTHER
TOOLS LIKE YOUR RESERVES, WHICH
LIKELY WILL BE NEEDED IN FUTURE
DEFICITS. UM IT ALSO IS, UH,
KIND OF WHEN THESE PACKAGES WERE
PUT TOGETHER. THEY WERE IN IN
THE WISDOM OF THE LEGISLATURE,
USING ONE TIME SURPLUS TO FOR
ONE. PROGRAMS RATHER THAN
BUILDING UP BASE PROGRAMS WITH
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS WAS
TEMPORARY WELL, THAT TEMPORARY
REVENUE ENDED UP BEING LESS THAN
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE, SO WE
THINK ADJUSTING THAT TEMPORARY
SPENDING IS BOTH APPROPRIATE AND
NECESSARY. BUT THESE ARE TOOLS
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO YOU KIND
OF ON A, UH, A LIMITED TERM
BASIS. IF YOU DON'T REDUCE SOME
OF THIS ONE TIME SPENDING, YOU
CAN'T GET OUT THREE YEARS FROM
NOW AND SAY, OH, I WISH WE
HADN'T SPENT THAT WE DON'T WANT
TO CUT INTO ONGOING PROGRAMS. SO
THERE IS SOME TIME URGENCY TO
CONSIDER THAT SO. CLEARLY THESE
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT PROGRAMS
AND EFFORTS ADDRESSING THE
CAUSES AND IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE A HUGE PRIORITY FOR
THE STATE, BUT SO IS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL OBLIGATION TO
PASS A BALANCED BUDGET. SO
THAT'S REALLY THE CONTEXT FOR
THE COMMENTS. I'M GOING TO GO
THROUGH AS YOUR FISCAL ADVISORS.
WE FEEL THAT IT'S OUR OBLIGATION
TO GIVE YOU OPTIONS TO TRY AND
ADDRESS THESE COMPETING GOALS.
SO THAT THAT'S WHAT UM THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO, UH, WITH MY COMMENTS TODAY,
BUT ALSO OVER THE COMING MONTHS
TO GIVE YOU OPTIONS. ADDRESS
THESE CHALLENGES. SO WITH THAT
BACKGROUND, TURNING TO PAGE ONE
OF THE HANDOUT UM, I'LL ALSO
NOTE THAT SOME OF THE NUMBERS I
WILL BE GIVING. YOU WILL DIFFER
SOME FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE BECAUSE WE REALLY HAVE
LIMITED OUR DISCUSSION HERE TO
THE PROGRAMS AND EFFORTS THAT
ARE IN THE PURVIEW OF THIS
COMMITTEE. SOME OF THE CLIMATE
BUDGET NUMBERS THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CITES INCLUDE
TRANSPORTATION SPENDING, HOUSING
SPENDING HIGHER ED SPENDING. UM
THAT REALLY HAVEN'T BEEN PART OF
KIND OF THE LEGISLATURE'S VIEW
OF THE CLIMATE AND RESOURCES
PACKAGE. SO THOSE ARE THE
NUMBERS THAT WE FOCUS ON HERE.
SO THE RECENT BUDGET PACKAGES
AND AGREEMENTS AS NOTED, WERE
REALLY KIND OF UNPRECEDENTED IN
TERMS OF THE AMOUNT OF SPENDING
AND PARTICULARLY THE AMOUNT OF
GENERAL FUND SPENDING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS, THE PICTURE HERE ON
THE BOTTOM OF PAGE ONE SHOWS
THAT VERY LARGE SPIKE IN GENERAL
FUND OVER RECENT YEARS, AND THIS
THIS IMAGE REFLECTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE
COMING YEAR. SO EVEN WITH THE
PROPOSED REDUCTIONS, YOU CAN SEE
HOW NOTABLE THOSE THOSE
INCREASES WHERE THERE WERE SOME
ADJUSTMENTS LAST YEAR TO ADDRESS
THE BUDGET DEFICIT, ROUGHLY
THREE BILLION DOLLARS. REDUCTION
BUT STILL REALLY UNPRECEDENTED
EFFORTS FOR THESE PROGRAMS THAT
HISTORICALLY WERE WERE SUPPORTED
MOSTLY WITH SPECIAL FUNDS AND
BOND FUNDS. SO TURNING TO PAGE
TWO. I WON'T GO INTO GREAT DEAL
TILL HERE SINCE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE HAS ALREADY DISCUSSED
THESE, BUT THEY'RE REALLY THREE
TOOLS IN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
REDUCTIONS OF ROUGHLY $2 BILLION
ACROSS THE BUDGET WINDOW AND
THEN ANOTHER OVER 500 MILLION,
UM, IN 2526 DELAYS, WHICH IS
TAKING GENERAL FUN THAT WAS
PLANNED FOR THE BUDGET WINDOW
AND SHIFTING IT TO A FUTURE YEAR
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS THERE.
UH, AND THEN FUN SHIFTS SHIFTING
FROM GENERAL FUND TO THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND,
OR GGRF. UM BECAUSE SOME OF
THOSE DELAYS COME BACK IN THAT
SPENDING IS RESUMED ACROSS THE
MULTIYEAR, UH, PERIOD. THE
PROPOSAL TO SAVE $4.1 BILLION IN
THE BUDGET WINDOW IS ERODED A
LITTLE BIT ACROSS THE MULTIYEAR
PERIOD. SO WE ESTIMATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD SAVE
$3.6 BILLION IN GENERAL FUND
ACROSS THE FORECAST PERIOD. SO
TURNING TO PAGE THREE. HERE UM,
I APOLOGIZE. THE COLOR DIDN'T
COME THROUGH ON THE GRAY SCALE.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO LOOK IN THE
OTHER REPORT, THIS IS ON PAGE
12. THIS IS A PICTURE OF ALL OF
MISTER BENSON'S TESTIMONY. IT
SHOWS YOU FOR EACH OF THE
THEMATIC PACKAGES. WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL CONTAINS SO
A COUPLE THINGS TO DRAW OUT FROM
THIS PICTURE. FIRST IS HOW MUCH
DARK THERE IS THAT DARK COLOR IS
HOW MUCH IS RETAINED. HOW MUCH
DOESN'T HAVE ANY PROPOSAL?
ADJUSTED. UM THE DOTTED LINES OR
IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT PAGE 12 IN
THE COLOR REPORT, IT'S THE RED
AND YELLOW. THAT'S THE PROPOSED
REDUCTION SO YOU CAN SEE THAT
THAT'S A RELATIVELY SMALL SHARE.
UM OVERALL, THE PACKAGE RETAINS
86% OF THE ORIGINAL, UH,
INTENTIONS. UH SOME OF IT IS FUN
SHIFTS AS I MENTIONED DIFFERENT
SOURCE, SOME OF ITS DIFFERENT
TIMING BY 86% WOULD BE RETAINED.
SO THOSE ARE THAT THAT'S ONE BIG
TAKEAWAY IS THE KIND OF
PROPORTION OF MAINTAINED VERSUS
REDUCED. I THINK ANOTHER TO DRAW
YOUR ATTENTION TO IS THAT DOES
DIFFER BY BY THEMATIC PACKAGE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE TOP LINE FOR
THE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES, IT'S
PRETTY MUCH 100% MAINTAINED,
MAYBE WITH A DIFFERENT TIMING OR
DIFFERENT FUND SOURCE, BUT BUT
REALLY MAINTAIN, WHEREAS YOU IF
YOU GO DOWN TOWARDS THE BOTTOM
TO COASTAL RESILIENCE, THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD CUT
ABOUT HALF OF THAT INTENDED
FUNDING, SO THERE ARE DEFINITELY
SOME POLICY CHOICES HERE. WITHIN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AROUND
WHERE WHERE TO CAPTURE SAVINGS
AND, UM TO PREVIEW WHAT I'M
ABOUT TO SAY. AS WE TURN THE
PAGE, YOU HAVE OTHER OPTIONS. IF
YOU HAVE DIFFERENT POLICY
PRIORITIES, I ALSO JUST NOTE
THIS OTHER LINE IN THE MIDDLE.
UM, THAT SINCE THAT ISN'T WELL
DEFINED IN THIS IMAGE THAT
CONTAINS THE LARGEST PIECE OF
THAT IS THE CLEAN ENERGY
RELIABILITY INVESTMENT PLAN, OR
SUP, WHICH WAS AN INTENTION FOR
A BILLION DOLLARS INCLUDED, UM
AS PART OF THE DIABLO CANYON
REAUTHORIZED. THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WOULD DELAY US IF A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THAT, UM
NOT CUT BUT DELAY. SO THAT'S
THAT'S PART OF THE LARGE GRAY
THERE IN THE MIDDLE. THE BIG
REDUCTION THERE ON THAT OTHER
LINE IS FOR THE CLIMATE
INNOVATION PROGRAM, WHICH WAS
PLANNED FOR THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. THAT'S ROUGHLY $500
MILLION. THAT HASN'T GOTTEN OFF
THE GROUND YET. UM THAT IS A
LARGE REDUCTION THAT'S PROPOSED
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
SO TURNING TO PAGE FOUR FOR A
COMMENTS. UH, OVERALL, WE THINK
THERE ARE MERITS, UH,
SIGNIFICANT MERITS IN IN THE
KIND OF OVERALL FRAMEWORK OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN THAT IT
CONTINUES TO FULFILL MOST OF THE
STATE'S OBJECTIVES BY BY
SUSTAINING A LARGE CHUNK OF THAT
FUNDING. IT'S AGAIN AS I
MENTIONED, FOCUSING ON REDUCING
ONE TIME AUGMENTATIONS RATHER
THAN BASED ONGOING PROGRAMS,
WHICH WE THINK MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE AND IS LESS DISRUPTIVE TO
THE STATE EFFORTS. WE HAVEN'T
IDENTIFIED ANY INSTANCES WHERE
THE GOVERNOR IS GOING IN AND
CUTTING PROGRAMS FOR WHICH
FUNDING HAS ALREADY BEEN
COMMITTED, SO THAT MINIMIZES
DISRUPTION. USING GRF TO KIND OF
HELP SUSTAIN PROGRAMS THAT ARE
PRIORITIES MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
AND REDUCING FUNDING THAT HASN'T
YET BEEN PROVIDED. THAT SAID.
THERE ARE SOME COMPONENTS THAT
WE THINK ARE GOING TO COMPLICATE
THINGS FOR YOU IF YOU ADOPT
THEM, AND PRIMARILY, THIS IS
AROUND THOSE DELAYS, SHIFTING
FUNDING TO A FUTURE YEAR WHEN
YOU'VE ALREADY GOT REALLY
SUBSTANTIAL BUDGET DEFICITS IN
FUTURE YEARS IS GOING TO MAKE
THAT HARDER, UH, KIND OF WORSEN
THOSE OUT YOUR PROGRAM PROBLEMS
AS WELL AS PERHAPS SET UP
EXPECTATIONS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
FOR FUNDING THAT YOU MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO AFFORD. SIMILARLY
THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF A
RELIANCE ON OUT YOUR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND. UM $1.8
BILLION IN THE OUT YEARS OF
FUTURE G GRF REVENUES. THERE'S A
LOT OF UNCERTAINTY AROUND GRF
REVENUES, BUT ALSO UNCERTAINTY
AROUND YOUR FUTURE PRIORITIES.
AND SO WE THINK, TRYING TO KIND
OF MINIMIZE WHAT YOU'RE
COMMITTING TO IN THAT OUT YEARS
TO PRESERVE YOUR FLEXIBILITY
WOULD MAKE A LOT OF SENSE. YOU
DO HAVE OTHER OPTIONS. YOU HAVE
OPTIONS FOR ALTERNATIVES. YOU
HAVE OPTIONS FOR, UH, FINDING
ADDITIONAL SAVINGS TO THE
DEGREE. YOU NEED THEM. SO SOME
OF THAT WOULD BE REDUCING SOME
OF THE GENERAL FUND THAT THE
GOVERNOR LEAVES IN FOR THE
BUDGET YEAR, AS WELL AS THE OUT
YEARS. THAT'S FUNDING THAT
HASN'T YET BEEN COMMITTED,
HASN'T EVEN YET BEEN GIVEN
AUTHORIZATION TO DEPARTMENTS. SO
IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR THE LEAST
DISRUPTIVE REDUCTIONS, THOSE ARE
SOME OF THE CATEGORIES THAT WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT YOU START
TO LOOK AT. WE'VE ALSO
IDENTIFIED QUITE A BIT OF
UNCOMMITTED MONEY THAT HAS BEEN
APPROPRIATED OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS ACROSS MANY PROGRAMS OF
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS NOT YET
KIND OF GOTTEN OUT THE DOOR
COMMITTED TO SPECIFIC PROJECTS,
SO THAT'S ANOTHER AREA. YOU
COULD LOOK AT. YOU CAN ALSO USE
DIFFERENTLY TO PRESERVE YOUR
PRIORITIES. UH UH, AS YOU'RE
MAKING GENERAL FUND REDUCTIONS.
THINK WE WOULD NOTE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL PRESERVES
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITIES
OVER SOME OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. SO AS YOU'RE LOOKING
AT PUTTING YOUR YOUR BUDGET
TOGETHER, THINKING ABOUT, UM
WHAT? WHAT DID YOU ADD IN THESE
BUDGET AGREEMENTS? AND IS THAT
AN AREA YOU MIGHT WANT TO
SUSTAIN AS COMPARED TO, UM SOME
OF THE CHOICES THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MADE. WE WISH
WE COULD SAY TO YOU. THESE ARE
THE PROGRAMS THAT ARE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE. SO WE THINK THESE ARE
THE ONES YOU SHOULD SUSTAIN.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE'S NOT A LOT
OF DATA AND INFORMATION. ROUND
OUTCOMES OF SOME OF THESE
PROGRAMS. SOME OF THAT'S BECAUSE
WE'RE STARTING THEM FOR THE
FIRST TIME, AND SOME OF THAT'S
JUST BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
COLLECTED THAT AS A STATE, SO
THAT'S AN AREA TO FOCUS ON TO,
UM, TO THINK ABOUT KIND OF
INFORMING YOUR INFORMING FUTURE
DECISIONS. UH, WHAT INFORMATION
ARE WE COLLECTING? NEXT UP? THE
FINAL BULLET THERE LEADS TO THE
PIE CHART ON PAGE FIVE, WHICH
ALSO IS IN COLOR IN OUR REPORT
AND MAY BE EASIER TO SEE. UM
THIS HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF THE
FUNDING. WE HAVE SUMMARIZED, UH,
THAT IS COMING TO CALIFORNIA. OR
PROJECTED TO COME TO CALIFORNIA
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. UM
FOR SOME OF THESE SIMILAR TOPICS
AGAIN, THIS NUMBER IS LESS THAN
WHAT YOU JUST HEARD FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE BECAUSE WE
EXCLUDE TRANSPORTATION AND IN
PARTICULAR, HIGH SPEED RAIL FROM
THIS PICTURE, WHICH IS A CHUNK
OF UM OF FUNDING THE STATE IS
EXPECTED TO RECEIVE. SO THIS IS
EITHER FUNDING THAT IS COMMITTED
TO CALIFORNIA THROUGH THE
FORMULA PROGRAMS AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL OR THE ENTITIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE ALREADY BEEN
AWARDED THROUGH COMPETITIVE
PROGRAMS. THEY'RE STILL
COMPETITIVE SOLICITATIONS
HAPPENING SO THIS NUMBER COULD
GROW. UM BUT THIS IS SORT OF
WHAT WE THINK IS CAN IS, CAN BE
WITH SOME AMOUNT OF CONFIDENCE
ASSUMED THAT IT IS COMING TO
CALIFORNIA. SO THE FEDERAL
PROGRAMS ARE NOT A 1 TO 1 MATCH
GENERALLY FOR OUR STATE
PROGRAMS, THEY MAY HAVE
DIFFERENT MATCHING REQUIREMENTS
OR DIFFERENT ALLOWABLE
ACTIVITIES. BUT AT LEAST IN
BROAD CATEGORIES, YOU CAN GET A
SENSE HERE THAT OF THE TYPES OF
OTHER FUNDING WE'RE GETTING FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
MIGHT HELP INFORM YOU AS YOU'RE
MAKING YOUR DECISIONS AS WELL.
AND THEN FINALLY TURNING TO THE
LAST PAGE, UH, FALLING PRETTY
CLOSELY TO THE TO THE COMMENTS
ON WHAT OUR OVERARCHING
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE FOR YOU. WE
REALLY THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO
MAXIMIZE GENERAL FUND SAVINGS
FROM FROM THESE ONE TIME
PROGRAMS, UH, TO PRESERVE YOUR
FLEXIBILITY AND AVOID HAVING TO
CUT INTO ONGOING PROGRAMS,
POTENTIALLY AS THE BUDGET
SITUATION MAY WORSEN. WE THINK
YOU HAVE OPTIONS FOR
ALTERNATIVES OR ADDITIONS. THERE
MAY BE SOME OF THESE AREAS WHERE
TAKING EARLY ACTION MAKES SENSE,
TOO, ESPECIALLY IF YOU WANT TO
LOOK AT AT CAPTURING SAVINGS
FROM PRO FUNDING THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN APPROPRIATED TO HELP PAUSE.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS KIND OF
MOVING AHEAD WITH WITH
ALLOCATING FUNDING THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN GRANTED AUTHORITY.
SO IF YOU WANNA CAPTURE SAVINGS
THAT WE'VE IDENTIFIED FROM SOME
OF THOSE PROGRAMS THAT MAY
REQUIRE TAKING ACTION SOON. WE
THINK USING G GR F TO HELP
PRIORITIZE AND PRESERVE YOUR
YOUR MOST IMPORTANT PROGRAMS
MAKE SENSE. WE UH, ADVISE
CAUTION ON COMMITTING OUT YOUR
FUNDS TO PRESERVE YOUR
FLEXIBILITY AND THEN FINALLY
THINKING ABOUT THIS OVERSIGHT.
IT'S NOT TOO LATE FOR SOME OF
THESE PROGRAMS. WE'VE JUST
GOTTEN STARTED TO START
COLLECTING INFORMATION AND
MAKING SURE YOU ARE, UM, FINDING
OUT WHAT WE'RE GETTING FROM THE
MONEY. WE'RE SPENDING AND ALSO
GETTING INFORMATION TO HELP
INFORM FUTURE DECISIONS WITH
THAT. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS, AND WE'VE GOT OUR
GREAT TEAM FROM THE L A Ó HERE.
WELL TO POP UP IF YOU NEED THEM.
THANK YOU. UH, GOOD. WELL I
THERE'S A LOT IN HERE, SO I HAVE
A LOT OF QUESTIONS, AND WE, UM,
KNOW THERE'S GONNA BE A LOT OF
PUBLIC COMMENT AS WELL. UM I
WILL START OUT WITH A FEW, UH
OVER OVERALL QUESTIONS AND THEN,
UH, TURN OVER TO SENATOR ALLEN,
AND THEN I'LL DIVE INTO THE COME
BACK TO SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS. UM FIRST DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
ABOUT A AO'S MOST RECENT DEFICIT
UPDATE. I SEE THE DEFICIT IS
GROWING SIGNIFICANTLY AS SHE AS
WAS MENTIONED. DO YOU AGREE WITH
THAT ASSESSMENT? SO CANCER JAG
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. UH, SO
ACTUALLY EARLIER THIS MONTH, UH,
FINANCE DID RELEASE A MONTHLY
UH, CASH REPORT, UH, WHICH SHOWS
SOME PRELIMINARY GENERAL FUND
AGENCY. CASH RECEIPTS WERE ABOUT
5 BILLION OR 19.7% BELOW THE
2425 GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FORECAST
FOR JANUARY AND THEN FROM A
FISCAL YEAR TO DATE PERSPECTIVE,
IT WAS ABOUT 5.9 BILLION OR 4.8%
BELOW. FROM THAT FISCAL YEAR TO
THE PERSPECTIVE. UM, HOWEVER,
YOU KNOW, REVENUES ARE DOWN
THROUGH JANUARY. THERE STILL ARE
MANY THINGS THAT, UH, CAN CHANGE
RELATED TO REVENUE THAN THE
ECONOMY BETWEEN NOW AND THE
MAJOR REVISION, WHICH MAY
ULTIMATELY UH, YOU KNOW,
INCREASE OR REDUCE THE SIZE OF
THE PROBLEM. UM SO REALLY, AT
THIS POINT, IT IS, UH A LITTLE
BIT TOO EARLY TO SPECULATE ON
THE TOTAL IMPACT, BUT WE'RE
DEFINITELY ACTIVELY MONITORING
THE ECONOMIC CONDITION AND THE
IMPACT THAT THAT HAS, AND
THERE'LL BE AN UPDATE AT THE
MAJOR VISION. UH, LIKE THE
NEWEST ESTIMATES, AND SO OUR
ESTIMATE IS STILL THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FORECAST ESTIMATE. BUT OF
COURSE WE DO, YOU KNOW, MONITOR
CASH RECEIPTS AND WE DO SEE THAT
THERE ARE CHANGES, BUT MORE TO
COME IN DETAILS TO BE RELEASED
IN THE MAVI. GOT IT. UM. OF THE
TOTAL GENERAL FUND BUDGET
SOLUTIONS. HOW MUCH COMES FROM
CLIMATE PROGRAMS ROUGHLY. SO THE
TOTAL GENERAL FUND SOLUTIONS ARE
37.9 BILLION SO THAT, YOU KNOW,
ALIGNS WITH THE BUDGET DEFICIT.
UM AND WHEN LOOKING AT THE
CLIMATE AREA POLLUTION SO 6.7
BILLION, UH, OF THE 37.9 BILLION
ARE IN THE CLIMATE AREA. UH BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE. UH ONLY
2.9 BILLION ARE REDUCTIONS SO OF
THE 37 BILLION IN STATEWIDE
REDUCTIONS, OR ALMOST
40,000,000,002 0.9 ARE OUR
CLIMATE PROGRAM REDUCTIONS. UH
AND SO WHEN, GENERALLY WHEN KIND
OF LOOKING AT AT THE YOU KNOW,
THE CLIMATE AREA. UM THIS IS AN
AREA WHERE, UH, THERE IS, UH,
AVAILABLE ONE TIME FUNDING AND
ALSO THERE WERE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO
SHIFT TO OTHER FUNDS AND THEN
ALSO, UH, TO PURSUE OTHER
FEDERAL FUNDS AS WELL. SO EVEN
WITH THESE REDUCTIONS THAT WE
HAVE IN THE IN THE CLIMATE AREA,
WHICH AGAIN 2.9 BILLION, UH, ARE
REDUCTIONS OUT OF THE ENTIRE
37.9 STATEWIDE A SOLUTIONS? UH,
YOU KNOW, WE ARE PROTECTING 48.3
BILLION CLOSE TO 90% OF THE
ORIGINAL, YOU KNOW, INVESTMENTS
AND THEN IN ADDITION TO THAT,
YOU KNOW, OVER $15 BILLION OF
FEDERAL FUNDS, UH, THAT YOU
KNOW, AT A MINIMUM BASED OFF OF
THE CURRENT, UH, YOU KNOW,
PROJECTIONS OF A FORMULA AND THE
COMPETITIVE GRANT HAVE ALREADY
COME IN, UH, THAT THAT WE'D GET
SO ULTIMATELY, YOU KNOW, THERE
WERE SOME HARD CHOICES THAT HAD
TO BE MADE, BUT YOU KNOW,
CLIMATE REMAINS A PRIORITY FOR
ADMINISTRATION AND, YOU KNOW, WE
BELIEVE THAT IS REFLECTED IN IN
THE AMOUNT THAT WE'RE PROTECTING
AND ALSO LOOKING AT THE
POTENTIAL, YOU KNOW, FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
COMING INTO THE STATE. GOOD. WE
DO APPRECIATE THAT COMMITMENT.
FEW MORE GENERAL QUESTIONS FOR
THE L Ó. CAN YOU EXPAND ON WHY
YOU BELIEVE DELAYS COMPLICATE
FUTURE? A BUDGET SITUATION AND
WHAT ARE YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS
AND IN PLACE OF IT. YEAH I MEAN,
THE ADVANTAGE OF A DELAY IS
YOU'RE NOT MAKING A CUT. YOU'RE
INDICATING THAT THIS IS STILL A
PRIORITY AND YOU HOPE TO FUND IT
. AT SOME POINT. I THINK OUR
CONCERN IS JUST GIVEN THE BUDGET
DEFICITS THAT YOU'RE FACING EVEN
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S, UH,
ESTIMATES THAT THOSE THOSE
EXPECTATIONS THOSE INDICATIONS
THOSE COMMITMENTS MAY BE REALLY
HARD TO, UH FULFILL AND YOU WILL
JUST KIND OF BE BACK HERE AGAIN
NEXT YEAR, HAVING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM ALL OVER AGAIN. SO IF
YOU'RE IF YOU ALTERNATIVELY WERE
TO SET YOURSELF UP, SAYING, OK,
WE DON'T THINK WE CAN AFFORD
THAT IN THE FUTURE, SO WE'RE
JUST GONNA GO AHEAD AND SAY WE
CAN'T AFFORD THAT, UH, IN IN THE
COMING YEARS, AND THEN IF
REVENUES DO ALLOW YOU TO THEN
THEN YOU CAN ADD THAT IN IN YOUR
BUDGET, UM AS AS THE YEARS COME
FORWARD, BUT BUT SETTING
YOURSELF UP FOR SPENDING IN A
SITUATION WHEN YOU ALREADY HAVE
A 30 TO $40 BILLION DEFICIT. UM
WE THINK JUST ISN'T THE WISEST
COURSE SETTING FORWARD THAT THAT
KIND OF WRITING YOUR FISCAL SHIP
NOW AND THEN, UH, AS YOU COME
INTO THAT YEAR, WHAT YOUR
PRIORITIES ARE WHAT YOUR
RESOURCES ARE, YOU CAN REVISIT
THE ISSUE. OK, UM, ON FEDERAL
FUNDING. YOU MENTIONED IT.
DISPARITY SOUND LIKE THAT WAS A
LOT OF THAT WAS HIGH SPEED,
RAILWAYS OR OTHER PIECES TO THE
FEDERAL FUNDING. YEAH THE
BIGGEST TWO PIECES ARE
TRANSPORTATION RELATED. HIGH
SPEED RAIL IS THREE BILLION OF
IT, AND THEN THERE'S ANOTHER
KIND OF LARGE TRANSPORTATION
PIECE. I THINK THOSE AS AS WE'VE
RECONCILED, WE WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE SAME SAME DATA THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS, BUT I
THINK PART OF IT IS JUST THE
UNIVERSE OF WHAT WE'RE WE'RE,
UH, CONSIDERING BEFORE YOU OK?
UM CERTAINLY FINANCE. UM YOU
MENTIONED THE FEDERAL FUNDS AND
UM. SO I'M WONDERING HOW HOW WAS
THE ADMINISTRATION PARTICULARLY
THOUGHT ABOUT THAT. AND BUT A
LOT OF FEDERAL PROGRAMS ARE
SIMILAR TO STATE. PROGRAMS
THEY'RE NOT DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR
REPLACEMENTS. SO HOW
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING TO KIND
OF BRAID FEDERAL AND STATE AH,
PROGRAMS TO STILL REACH OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. YEAH. SO THIS
REGION HAS BEEN ENGAGED IN SOME
PRETTY EXTENSIVE EFFORTS OVER
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS TO TRY
TO LEVERAGE AS MUCH AS THE
FEDERAL FUNDING WE CAN TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE
YOU KNOW, COLLECTIVELY WORKING
BOTH INTERNALLY, YOU KNOW, WITH
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION TO
HAVE DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES, YOU KNOW, APPLY AS
ALSO WORKING WITH OUR YOU KNOW,
LOCAL PARTNERS, NON PROFITS, UH,
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS AND OTHERS TO
TRY TO AVAIL THEM OF THE
OPPORTUNITIES. AS YOU KNOW.
SUBST STATE, UH, GRANT
RECIPIENTS AND, UH, YOU KNOW,
OVER 15.5 BILLION DAY IS WHAT WE
ARE EXPECTING. COMING TO
CALIFORNIA. THIS WAS DEFINITELY
ONE OF THE FACTORS THAT THAT WE
DID CONSIDER, UH WHEN LOOKING AT
GENERAL FUND SOLUTIONS AND YOU
KNOW HAS BEEN MENTIONED, UH, NOT
IN ALL CASES THERE, YOU KNOW,
ONE FOR ONE OR THE SAME PROGRAM.
IN SOME CASES IT IS. IT IS VERY,
YOU KNOW, SIMILAR uWHAT
STATE WOULD HAVE PROVIDED JUST
AS AN EXAMPLE, UM, YOU KNOW WHEN
THINKING ABOUT SOME OF THE
FEDERAL WATER INVESTMENTS, UH,
THERE'S OVER 400 MILLION THAT'LL
PROVIDE IT TO THE WATER BOARD
FOR CLEAN UP OF EMERGING
CONTAMINANTS. UH, WHICH INCLUDE
PFOS AND ONE OF THE REDUCTIONS
THAT WE HAVE IN THIS BUDGET. UH,
THE GENERAL FUND SOLUTION IS
REDUCING 100 MILLION OF GENERAL
FUND FOR PF ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
THERE IS 400 MILLION THAT'S
GONNA BE COMING IN FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OVER OVER A
COUPLE OF YEARS, UH, TO SUPPORT
THAT SAME EFFORT, SO THAT'S KIND
OF ONE EXAMPLE WHERE THERE IS A
MORE DIRECT PROGRAM ALSO COMING,
UH, FUNDING, UH, TO THE STATE,
UH, CALIFORNIA, UH, TO SUPPORT
THAT IN OTHER CASES, IT'S NOT A
ONE FOR ONE, BUT WE'RE ALWAYS
LOOKING AT WE COULD BEST, YOU
KNOW, LEVERAGE SOME OF THE
FUNDING. UH, ONE YOU KNOW,
EXAMPLE. PROVIDE OF HOW WE'VE,
YOU KNOW, TRIED TO BRAID SOME.
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS, UM UNDER
THE, UH, THE AIR BOARD THE HÌ VÆ
PROGRAM. UH, THEY RECENTLY MADE
SOME SOME MODIFICATIONS TO THE
PROGRAM TO BE ABLE TO BETTER
HELP THE, UH LOCAL TRANSIT
AGENCIES BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
SOME OF THE FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION UH, KNOX PROGRAMS
AND SO WE'RE ALSO TRYING TO
ADJUST. YOU KNOW WHERE POSSIBLE
OUR PROGRAMS TO BE ABLE TO HELP
OTHERS WHO ARE GONNA POTENTIALLY
, YOU KNOW, USE OUR FUNDING AS A
MATCH FOR SOME OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDS. AND SO WE'RE ACTIVELY,
YOU KNOW, MONITORING A LOT OF
THE SOLICITATIONS TO LOOK WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE GUIDELINES
COMING OUT OUT OF THE FEDERAL
PROGRAMS TRYING TO YOU KNOW, AS
AS AS MUCH AS WE CAN, UM, MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE DOING OUR PART
AND ALSO SUPPORTING THE LOCALS
WHO ARE GONNA BE APPLYING, UH,
TO AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE. YOU
KNOW, TO THE EXTENT WE COULD
OFFSET SOME OF THE LAST GENERAL
FUND BY BY, YOU KNOW, SUPPORTING
THE LOCALS IN IN THEIR, UH UH,
PURSUIT OF THE FEDERAL FUNDS AS
POSSIBLE, AND SO THERE
DEFINITELY IS STATEWIDE EFFORT.
AND AS I MENTIONED BEFORE, YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE A LOT MORE, UH,
AWARDS AND SO STATIONS TO COME.
THE 15.5 BILLION IS JUST SO FAR
OF WHAT'S ALREADY BEEN ANNOUNCED
. BUT THERE'S UH, YOU KNOW, ON A
MONTHLY BASIS, UH, FEDERAL, UH,
YOU KNOW AWARD IS ANNOUNCED, AND
ALSO A FEDERAL OPPORTUNITIES
THAT ARE ANNOUNCED. AND, UH, WE,
UM, YOU KNOW, PROVIDE A LOT OF
LIGHT TO THE SUPPORT, UH, TO
DIFFERENT ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE APPLYING TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, SO THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO LEVERAGE AND MAXIMIZE AS MUCH
AS THAT FEDERAL FUNDING AS
POSSIBLE, YOU KNOW, EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THERE'S UH,
IN SOME CASES REDUCED GENERAL
FUND THAT IS AVAILABLE. OK,
THANK YOU FOR THAT, UM, YOU KNOW
ONE MORE SET OF QUESTIONS, AND
THEN I'LL TURN OVER TO SENATOR
ALLEN SO WE CAN ADD SOME OF THE
HIGH LEVEL QUESTIONS BEFORE WE
START MOVING PEOPLE AROUND. AS
YOU MENTIONED, UM IN TERMS OF
PROGRAM. EFFECTIVENESS. UM SAY
YOU, YOU YOU REFERRED TO THIS?
UH WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
IN REACHING THEIR GOALS AND DO
ANY PROGRAM STAND OUT? TO YOU.
YEAH AS I MENTIONED. THIS HAS
NOT BEEN AN AREA WHERE THE STATE
HAS COLLECTED A TON OF
INFORMATION. UH ONE AREA OF
EXCEPTION WITH A DISCLAIMER, I
GUESS IS AROUND THE, UM
EXPENDITURES FROM G GR F. THAT
IS AN AREA WHERE THIS THE CARB
THE AIR BOARD. UM, DOES KIND OF
MONITOR OR ESTIMATE THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS AT REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FOR THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED THROUGH
THAT FUND SOURCE. UM WE'VE
RAISED SOME ISSUES WITH OUR
METHODOLOGY AND KIND OF THE
RELIABILITY OF THAT, BUT THERE
IS AT LEAST THERE IS THAT EFFORT
HAPPENING. SO UM, SOME OF WHAT
THEY FOUND. VEHICLES HAVE KIND
OF HIGH COST EFFECTIVENESS
RATINGS FOR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS, SO THAT'S ONE
CATEGORY. I THINK YOU KNOW THIS
SOMETIMES WITH BONDS. ALSO,
THERE'S LANGUAGE THAT'S WRITTEN
IN FOR SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS TO
REPORT ON PROGRAM OUTCOMES. UM
BUT IT REALLY HASN'T BEEN AN
AREA THAT THE STATE HAS REQUIRED
MUCH OF FOR THESE RECENT
INVESTMENTS. SO IN TERMS OF
AREAS WE WOULD THANK YOU MIGHT
WANT TO CONSIDER ADDING SOME
LANGUAGE OR POTENTIALLY EVEN
SETTING ASIDE MONEY FOR A FORMAL
EVALUATION. IN PARTICULAR AROUND
EFFORTS WERE TRYING FOR THE
FIRST TIME, SO ONE AREA WE'D
HIGHLIGHT IT AROUND EXTREME
HEAT. THAT IS A NEW CLIMATE
CHALLENGE THE STATUS FACING WE
HAVEN'T REALLY SPENT A LOT OF
MONEY OR DONE A LOT OF ACTIVITY
ON THAT. AND WE DON'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT WE'RE EXT WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF THE FUNDING IN THIS
PACKAGE, BUT WE DON'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT WORKS. WE DON'T KNOW
WHETHER IT'S YOU KNOW, PLANTING
TREES OR BUYING AIR CONDITIONING
UNITS FOR FAMILIES OR SETTING UP
COOLING CENTERS FOR FOLKS TO GO
TO. YOU KNOW WHAT IS REALLY THE
MOST, UM, IMPACTFUL ACTIVITY WE
CAN DO ON PUBLIC HEALTH AND THAT
IS RESEARCH HAS FOUND THAT'S
GOING TO BE ONE OF THE MOST, UM,
DANGEROUS CLIMATE IMPACTS ON
PUBLIC HEALTH. SO BECAUSE THAT'S
A NEW AREA THAT COULD BE IN AN
AREA THAT WE REALLY WOULD WANT
TO LEARN FROM SO THAT WE KNOW IN
FUTURE YEARS WHERE STATE
INVESTMENTS MAKE THE MOST SENSE,
SO I THINK OUR GUIDANCE TO YOU
WOULD BE OF COURSE, OF COURSE,
WE'RE DATA NERDS. WE WANT TO
KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT EVERY
PROGRAM, BUT REALLY FOCUSING ON
WHERE DO WE NOT? AND WHERE DO WE
NOT KNOW WHAT THE MOST EFFECTIVE
ACTIVITIES ARE? AND IT MIGHT BE
WORTH EVEN IN THIS BUDGET
CONTEXT. SETTING ASIDE SOME
FUNDING FROM FROM THE PROGRAM
BUDGET TO DO SOME SOME LEARNING
AND SOME RESEARCH. THANK YOU AND
. RETURNING FINANCE. AND HOW
WOULD YOU RESPOND TO THAT? HOW
DOES ADMINISTRATION ASSESS WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE MOST? AFFECTIVE OR
ARE THEY BEING EFFECTIVE AND
DIFFERENT FACETS? CLIMATE
CHANGE, WHETHER BE EXTREME HEAT
IS MENTIONED OR PROVING COASTAL
RESILIENCE OR WE'LL TALK ABOUT
GREEN GR FIND ANOTHER TIME. YEAH
AND ADMINISTRATION. DEFINITELY
YOU KNOW, LOOKED AT AT
EFFECTIVENESS AND MONITOR SOME
OF THE OUTCOMES OF THE VARIOUS
PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE MAKING INVESTMENTS IN THOSE
AREAS THAT ARE MAKING A
DIFFERENCE THAN AN IMPACT. AND
THERE'S OF COURSE, DOESN'T THE
PROGRAM THAT HELPS SUPPORT
DIFFERENT CHEMICALS WAS PRODUCED
IN EMISSIONS, EQUESTRIAN, CARBON
REDUCING DIFFERENT CLIMATE
RISKS, AND SO THERE'S VARIOUS
WAYS THAT WE TRY TO TARGET THE
EFFECTIVENESS. WE KNOW ONE WAY
IS AS WE'RE DEVELOPING THE
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA FOR MANY OF
THE PROGRAMS WITHIN YOU KNOW
WHAT WE'RE REQUIRING OF THE
APPLICANTS AND OTHER PROJECTS,
FOLDING SOME OF THAT, YOU KNOW,
EFFECTIVENESS, MEASURES AND
METRICS WITHIN THAT, AND SO YOU
KNOW, WHEN THINKING ABOUT, YOU
KNOW PROGRAMS, FUNDING FOR CAP
AND TRADE BUILDING IN THE GHD
BENEFITS AS PART OF THAT, WHEN
THINKING ABOUT LIKE THE URBAN
GREENING PROGRAM AS AN EXAMPLE.
REALLY KIND OF LOOKING AT WHAT
PROGRAMS HAVE THE MOST BENEFIT
FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT THREATS TO
EXTREME HEAT AND THE APPLICANT
THERAPY REQUIRED IN THE
APPLICATIONS. IDENTIFY THE RISKS
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA EXTREME
HEAT ASSESSMENT TOOL. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE FOR LIKE THE DELTA
LEVIES PROGRAM UNDER DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES, YOU KNOW,
THE APPLICANTS ARE REQUIRED TO
DO A DETAILED ASSESSMENT OF THE
LIFETIME CLIMATE, VULNERABILITY
AND ADAPTATION KIND OF MEASURES
OF THEIR SPECIFIC PROJECT. SO WE
HAVE KIND OF A LOT OF MEASURES
BUILT IN WITHIN FIRST STEP WITH
APPLICATION PROJECT OR
APPLICATION PROCESS, THEN WHEN
THE PROJECTS ARE ACTUALLY GOING
THROUGH MANY CASES, THERE'S ALSO
REGULAR REPORTING THAT WE
REQUIRE OF THE APPLICANTS OR THE
GRANTEE THAT THAT POINT IN TIME
WHERE SOME WERE REQUIRED TO DO,
YOU KNOW, QUARTERLY OR
SEMIANNUALLY OR ANNUALLY
REPORTING ON HOW THEY'RE
ACTUALLY MEETING THOSE METRICS.
AND THEN IN MANY CASES IT ALSO,
YOU KNOW, POST ASSESSMENT OF
EFFECTIVENESS ONCE THE PROJECT
IS COMPLETED, YOU KNOW, WE
LOOKED AT WHAT HAS BEEN THE
TOTAL IMPACT OF THESE PROJECTS
AND SOME ACTUALLY ALSO HAVE TO,
YOU KNOW, REPORT AFTER THE FACT
AND HE HAS MENTIONED BEFORE YOU
KNOW, THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
DOES HAVE AN ANNUAL REPORT FOR
ALL THE CAP AND TRADE
INVESTMENTS, AND THERE'S A LOT
OF, YOU KNOW PUBLIC INFORMATION
ON THOSE PROGRAMS. BUT WE
DEFINITELY HAVE INFORMATION.
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT THERE'S ANY
SPECIFIC, YOU KNOW, PROGRAM OF
INTEREST. WE COULD DEFINITELY
KIND OF WORK WITH RESPECTIVE
DEPARTMENT THAT IMPLEMENTS YOU
KNOW THOSE PROGRAMS TO SEE WHAT
DATA IS AVAILABLE OF, YOU KNOW,
REFLECTING SOME OF THE OUTCOMES
OF THE GRANT THAT HAVE BEEN
PROVIDED, OKAY? WELL I'M A FAN
OF URBAN GREENING, SO I'M SURE
WE'LL GET TO THAT LATER. LET ME
TURN IT OVER NOW TO SENATOR
ALLEN TO, UM, UM, STARTED A LINE
OF QUESTIONING. YEAH I MEAN,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS
AND OBVIOUSLY REALLY TOUGH YEAR
AND I TOTALLY APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW WE DON'T HAVE
GREAT DATA. OF COURSE, THE
CHALLENGE I THINK IS, YOU KNOW,
WE ALL KNOW THAT, UM THE
DECISIONS WE'RE MAKING. WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BOTH. DO OUR PART, GIVEN THE
BROADER BUDGETARY CHALLENGES,
AND THE FLIP SIDE IS WE REALLY
DO KNOW THERE'S GOING TO BE
IMPACT. I MEAN, THESE ARE ALL
VALUABLE PROGRAMS THAT ARE BEING
FUNDED AND A LOT OF THESE ARE
REALLY COST EFFECTIVE. SOLUTIONS
TO ADDRESSING ALL SORTS OF KEY
GOALS THAT WE HAVE, AND YOU JUST
LOOK AT THE LIST OF THINGS THAT
ARE POTENTIALLY IMPLICATED. I
MEAN OUR PROTECTION OF COASTAL
COMMUNITIES AGAINST THE
INTENSIFYING IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. OUR CLIMATE GOALS OR
OUTDOOR ACCESS CALLS 30 BY 30, I
, YOU KNOW, I KNOW IF I ASK YOU
HOW DO WE KNOW HOW IT'S GOING TO
IMPACT? YOUR WE'RE NOT GONNA
HAVE ENOUGH DATA. WHICH YOU KNOW
IS, I'M SURE, UM TRUE, BUT BUT
NEVERTHELESS, UM WE KNOW THERE
WILL BE AN IMPACT. UM SO LET ME
JUST LET ME TALK. LET ME ASK YOU
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT, UM THE
POSSIBILITY OF A BOND. YOU KNOW,
OBVIOUSLY SOMETHING THAT SOME OF
US HAVE BEEN WORKING ON. THE
GOVERNOR HAS MENTIONED IT
REPEATEDLY THROUGH THE COURSE OF
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS AS A
OUTLET FOR SOME OF THESE
EXPENDITURES, YOU KNOW, THERE'S
NO WAY AND NOW, OF COURSE,
THEY'RE ALL TRYING TO DOWNPLAY
THE SIZE OF A POSSIBLE BOUND,
WHICH MEANS THE SMALLER IT IS
THE LESS IT WOULD BE ABLE TO
HANDLE A LOT OF THESE. UM COSTS
THAT MIGHT SOME FOLKS MAY TRY TO
ATTEMPT TO SHIFT ONTO IT. UM BUT
AH! TELL ME GIVEN THE ME ASK THE
L A. OH, SO UM YOU KNOW? THE L A
. I CAME OUT WITH THIS OVERVIEW
OF STATE BOND DEBT SERVICE, AND
THERE WERE A COUPLE OF FACTORS
THAT THEY CAME THAT THAT I NOTED
ONE WAS IT OUR TOTAL BOND. IT IS
RELATIVELY LOW. UM, AND IT
DOESN'T SERVICE RATIO IS THE
LOWEST IT'S BEEN IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF DECADES. I THINK
SOMETHING. THE TOTAL ANNUAL DEBT
SERVICE AND 2223 WAS ABOUT 3.2%
OF GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES
AND, UM SO OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A
LOT OF CONCERN OVER THE BROADER
ECONOMIC OUTLOOK AND CERTAINLY
THE EDGE OF THE BUDGETARY
OUTLOOK. BUT YOU WHAT DO YOU
HAVE THOUGHTS ON? GIVEN THE
STATE'S CURRENT OUT LEVELS. HOW
MUCH YOU KNOW? SOME OF THE
VARIOUS IDEAS ABOUT CLIMATE BOND
MIGHT IMPACT OUR ANNUAL DEBT
SERVICE PAYMENTS. UH HUH. YEAH
SO A COUPLE OF POINTS FIRST.
THERE'S NO MAGIC NUMBER THAT WE
CAN GIVE YOU OF WHAT THE RIGHT
AMOUNT OF DEBT AND BOND IS SOME
GUIDANCE AS WELL. AND I GUESS I
WILL ALSO NOTE PART OF WHY ARE
DEBT SERVICE RATIO IS SO LOW
RIGHT NOW IS BECAUSE OUR GENERAL
FUND IS SO MUCH HIGHER THAN IT
WAS HISTORICALLY. SO I THINK
THAT'S THAT THAT THE NUMERATOR
AND DENOMINATOR MATTER ON THAT
ON THAT RATIO. AH ARE ROUGH KIND
OF RULE OF THEM IS THAT FOR
EVERY ADDITIONAL BILLION DOLLARS
OF BOND YOU AUTHORIZE. IT WILL
KIND OF EQUATE TO ABOUT $85
MILLION IN ANNUAL PAYMENTS FOR
15 TO 20 YEARS. SO IN TERMS OF
WHAT THE IMPACT WOULD BE ON THE
FUTURE, THAT'S THAT'S A ROUGH
RULE OF THEM TO USE. THINK SOME
OF OUR GENERAL GUIDANCE AROUND
AROUND BONDS ARE AND WHAT TO PUT
IN THEM IS TO THINK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT THEY WILL BE BEING
PAID OFF FOR DECADES, SO THAT
SHOULD BE PROJECTS OR EFFORTS
THAT WILL BENEFIT FOLKS. 30
YEARS FROM NOW, SO THINKING
ABOUT BIG CAPITAL PROJECTS AS
OPPOSED TO, YOU KNOW, REBATES
FOR TVS OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT,
UM, THINKING ABOUT PUBLIC
BENEFIT BROAD PUBLIC BENEFIT FOR
THE BROAD PUBLIC TAXPAYER, GIVEN
THAT THEY WILL BE THE ONES
PAYING PAYING THAT OFF, THINKING
ABOUT WHERE THERE MIGHT NOT BE
OTHER FUNDING AVAILABLE, SO IT'S
REALLY FILLING A HOLE. UM
THINKING ABOUT IF THERE ARE
AREAS THAT CAN LEVERAGE OTHER
FUNDING. FOR EXAMPLE, IN THE
AREA OF FLOOD, THERE'S A LOT OF
FEDERAL MONEY THAT TYPICALLY
REQUIRES A STATE MATCH FOR ARMY
CORVIN ENGINEERS PROJECTS, FOR
EXAMPLE, SO IF THE STATE DOESN'T
HAVE MONEY TO PENNY UP, WE MAY
NOT BENEFIT FROM THE FEDERAL
PROGRAMS. SO THOSE ARE KIND OF
OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD. SOME OF
THE GUIDING PRINCIPLES WE'VE
WE'VE HISTORICALLY GIVEN AROUND
BONDS, BUT AGAIN I'M SORRY, I
CAN'T TELL YOU WHAT THE RIGHT
MAGIC NUMBER IS. I DON'T THINK
THERE IS ONE, BUT IT'S GOOD NEWS
IS, OF COURSE, UM UM YOU KNOW, I
IT THERE'S ALSO FLEXIBILITY ONCE
UPON THIS PAST THE GOVERNOR
LEGISLATURE. YOU KNOW, EVERY
YEAR WE'RE DETERMINING HOW MANY
BOND FUNDS TO AUTHORIZE AGENCIES
TO SPEND IN A GIVEN YEAR AND, OF
COURSE, THE DEBTS NOT INCURRED
UNTIL THE AGENCY ACTUALLY SPENDS
THE MONEY. SO YOU KNOW, EVEN IF
VOTERS APPROVE A LOT OF BONDS.
YOU KNOW, WE ULTIMATELY DECIDED
TOGETHER THROUGH THIS PROCESS,
IN FACT, UM HOW MUCH DEBTS
ACTUALLY INCURRED THROUGH THE
BUDGET ACTIONS THAT WE TAKE THAT
THAT'S ABSOLUTELY TRUE. WHAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY FLEXIBILITY
AROUND IS PAYING THE DEBT
SERVICE ONCE THE BOND HAS BEEN
SAID THAT IS LOCKED IN THAT HAS
FIRST CALL ON THE GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS AND SO WHEN YOU DO FACE
TOUGH FISCAL TIMES YOU KNOW,
THAT IS NOT AN AREA OF
FLEXIBILITY. ONCE YOU HAVE
LOCKED THAT INSIDE, THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION, BUT WE
COULD IF WE WANTED TO KEEP THE
DEBT SERVICE. LOWER. UM FOR A
LOT OF VARIETY OF GOOD REASONS,
WILLING TO THESE MACROECONOMIC
TRENDS. I MEAN, THE LEGISLATURE
COULD APPROPRIATE FOR YOUR BOND
FUNDS IN PARTICULAR BUDGET YEAR.
WITH THE KEY CAVEAT THAT WE
STILL HAVE. THE LOCKED IN
RESPONSIBILITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
PREVIOUS EXPENDITURES ON THE
BOND, RIGHT AND SOMETIMES
BECAUSE THE DEBT SERVICE DOESN'T
COME DUE FOR SEVERAL YEARS, HE
MAY AUTHORIZE IT IN A GOOD
FISCAL TIME. AND THEN ONCE THE
DEBT SERVICE COMES. THE FISCAL
CONDITION HAS WORSENED. BUT
THAT'S WHEN THE OBLIGATION COMES
TO YEAH, WELL, LOOK, YOU'RE I
THINK YOU'RE SPOT ON ON WHAT WE
NEED TO BE THINKING ABOUT. YOU
KNOW, AS WE THINK ABOUT A
POSSIBLE BLONDE. THAT'S THE
RIGHT ANALYSIS RIGHT? IT'S ALL
ITS LONG TERM EXPENDITURES THAT
WOULD BENEFIT PEOPLE WHO WOULD
BE SPENT HERE WHO CONTINUED TO
BE PAYING FOR THEM A LONG TIME
DOWN THE LINE. UM, YOU KNOW, I
THINK WE LOOK AT THESE WE?
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW, THERE'S A
REASON WHY WE WERE SO RELATIVELY
EXPANSIVE. ARGUABLY EVERYTHING
WE'RE DOING IS INADEQUATE,
RIGHT? BUT WE WERE VERY
EXPENSIVE OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS IN THIS SPACE, AND
WE'RE CLAWING IT BACK SO
DRAMATICALLY, AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT IN SOME RESPECTS, BUT YOU
KNOW I REALLY DO WORRY ABOUT ALL
THE IMPACT THIS IS GOING TO HAVE
GIVEN ALL THAT WE KNOW ABOUT.
YOU KNOW THE MONEY THAT'S SPENT
NOW ON CLIMATE MITIGATION. HOW
WHAT? WHAT? WHAT AN INCREDIBLE
MULTIPLIER EFFECT IT HAS ON ON
THE FUTURE, INCLUDING ON FUTURE
LOSSES, RIGHT? I MEAN, MANY
RESPECTS OUR OUR LONG TERM
ECONOMIC VIABILITY AND HEALTH
AND VIBRANCY WILL DEPEND ON SOME
OF THE UPFRONT INVESTMENTS THAT
WE DO NOW WITH REGARDS TO
MITIGATION AND RESILIENCE. SO
YEAH, WE ALL KNOW HOW TOUGH THE
BUDGET IS. WE GOT WE SPENT LAST
COUPLE OF DAYS IN RETREAT AND
YOU KNOW, IN BOTH. BUT PHYSICAL
AND METAPHORICAL RETREAT WHEN IT
COMES TO, UH AH, THESE TOUGH
NUMBERS. SO, UM, YOU KNOW, I
APPRECIATE OF COURSE, YOU KNOW,
I HMM. YOU KEEP GIVING THE
SHORTFALL NUMBERS THAT YOU'RE
GIVEN THAT WE ALL KNOW THAT
THERE'S A VERY DIFFERENT
ARGUMENT OUT THERE ABOUT HOW
MUCH BIGGER THE SHORTFALL IS
THAN WHAT THE U F IS SAYING
THESE DAYS, OR AT LEAST WAS
RELYING ON SO, UM, WITH THAT,
YOU KNOW? SO HAPPY THAT THE PRO
TEM PUT ME ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. UM, IN THIS REALLY
EASY BUDGET YEAR. YEAH AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THE REST OF
DISCUSSIONS. WHAT WAS THAT?
WE'RE GLAD TO HAVE YOU SOLVED.
HELP US SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. UM
WE'RE GONNA GET DOWN SOME
SPECIFICS. WE UNDERSTAND THERE
MIGHT BE SOME SHUFFLING AROUND.
UM I WANTED TO START OFF WITH
ENERGY AND, UM UM. BUT BOTH THE
ACTUALLY MAY HAVE SOME COMMENT
ON THIS. WE DISCUSSED THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROCESS. DELAY
SYRUP FUNDING AS FOLLOWS 400
MILLION IN 24 2500 MILLION 2526
TO 100 MILLION AND 25 26 300
MILLION IN 2627 AND 500 MILLION
IN 2728. SO UM, AS WE'RE
GATHERING THE APPROPRIATE,
FOLKS, UM LOVE TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IS THE RATIONALE FOR
COMPLETELY DELAYING THE SYRUP
FUNDING ALTOGETHER WHEN THE
DIABLO CANYON PLANT EXTENSION
GENERAL FUND LOANS HAVE GONE AS
PLANNED?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. STEVE WELLS
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I
JUST WANT TO SAY, YOU KNOW, IN
REGARDS TO THE SYRUP FUNDING,
AND THEN THE DABBLE KENYAN THE
SYRUP FUNDING. YOU KNOW, WE
WE'VE ALREADY WE HAVE $100
MILLION IN CURRENT
APPROPRIATIONS, AND I THINK WE
TALKED EARLIER ABOUT UM SOME OF
THE CRITERIA THAT WE USE TO
DETERMINE WHERE WE WOULD MOVE
THINGS AROUND HAVE TO DO WITH,
YOU KNOW, IS THERE AN ACTIVE
APPROPRIATION AVAILABLE SO THAT
THESE THESE PROGRAMS CAN
CONTINUE SO $100 MILLION THAT
WAS APPROPRIATED IN THE 2324
BUDGET IS STILL ACTIVE, AND MOST
OF THAT FUNDING IS STILL
AVAILABLE, SO WE FELT IT WAS AN
APPROPRIATE UH, IT WAS
APPROPRIATE SOLUTION TO THEN
MOVE THE FUNDING OUT. UM THAT
YOU KNOW THE ADDITIONAL YEAR, UM
, OVER WHAT WE HAD PLANNED
BEFORE. AS FAR AS THE DEVIL
CANYON. SOME OF THOSE FUNDS
WOULD NEEDED TO BE SPENT IN
ORDER TO THE ONGOING EFFORTS TO
RE CERTIFY AND KEEP THE
APPLICATION OPEN. SO IT'S MORE
OF A TIMING ISSUE OF WHEN THE
FUNDS WERE NEEDED. JUST TRY AND
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND THAT
BECAUSE I THINK WHEN WE VOTED ON
IT WAS TIED TO THE EXTENSION. SO
JUST SORT OF TELL ME ONE MORE
TIME AGAIN SO WELL. THOSE FUNDS
ARE AVAILABLE UPON
APPROPRIATION. SO WE YOU KNOW
AGAIN. WE ARE STILL PART OF THE
PLAN IS STILL HAVE THOSE FUNDS
BE AVAILABLE JUST WE WOULD HAVE
THE APPROPRIATION BE. YOU KNOW,
WE'RE MOVING APPROPRIATION OUT
TO 2025 AND 26. UM OKAY, UH, IN
MID JANUARY, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FINALIZED APPROVAL OF
$1.1 BILLION DOLLARS TO HELP PG
KNEE KEEP OPERATING JABLEH
CANYON. HOWEVER, IN FEBRUARY,
THE MINISTRATIONS REQUEST
ADDITIONAL 400 MILLION THROUGH
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET.
COMMITTEE NOTIFICATION PROCESS,
SO GIVEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AWARD, WHY ARE THE ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDS NEEDED AT THIS TIME?
GOOD MORNING, SHERIFF. MORNING,
SENATOR. MY NAME IS DELPHINE
HOME, THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
STATEWIDE WATER AND ENERGY AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES. SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION. UM SO I WANTED TO KIND
OF SEPARATE THE TWO THINGS. SO
FIRST OF ALL, ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY FROM WHAT
DO WE UNDERSTAND? UNDERSTANDS
AND OF COURSE, I JUST WANT TO
CAVEAT THAT BY SAYING THAT DWR
IS NOT PARTY TO THE AGREEMENT
BETWEEN ME AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY, BUT FROM WHAT WE
UNDERSTAND, BASED ON PUBLIC
INFORMATION THAT THOSE FUNDS, UH
, BASED ON THAT CREDIT AWARD
WOULD NOT COME ABOUT UNTIL I
THINK THE EARLIEST 2025 SO
THAT'S BASED ON THE DEAL. WE
TIMING OF LOOKING AT PG AND E
SUBMITTED COST, SO THERE IS A
LONG PROCESS THERE THAT YOU
WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY.
THEREFORE RIGHT NOW, P GENIE IS
IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT LICENSE
RENEWAL. THEY HAVE SUBMITTED
THEIR APPLICATION TO THE NUCLEAR
REGULATORY COMMISSION BACK IN
NOVEMBER. IT WAS DEEMED
SUFFICIENT, WHICH MEANS THAT THE
PLANT CAN CONTINUE TO OPERATE
BEYOND ITS CURRENT LICENSE
EXPIRATION DATE. SO BECAUSE OF
THAT, PGD IS ACTIVELY DOING
EVERYTHING IT NEEDS TO DO IN
ORDER TO MAKE THAT, UM, LICENSE
EXTENSION BUT ALSO DO
INSPECTIONS AND OTHER WORK
THAT'S NECESSARY TO REPORT BACK
TO THE NUCLEAR REGULATORY
COMMISSION TO SUPPORT THAT
LICENSE EXTENSION. WHAT IS THE.
FUND REPAYMENT SCHEDULE FOR THE
MONEY THAT UM, THE COMPANY'S
ALREADY RECEIVED. AND POSSIBLY
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS REQUESTED. SO
AGAIN THAT'S DEPENDENT ON, FOR
EXAMPLE, WHERE THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY AND PD NI HAVE NEGOTIATED
, AND IN THE MOST RECENT PUBLIC
INFORMATION THAT DWR HAS SEEN
THE TIMELINE FOR THAT IS 2025
THAT WE UNDERSTAND. OKAY? AND.
OF THE DOLLARS. UM, HOW MUCH OF
THE GENERAL FUND LOANS WERE
DISCUSSING IS GOING TO RUNNING
THE DEVIL CANYON DIRECTLY AND
HOW MUCH OF IT IS GOING TO AH TO
PG NHIÀU. AND JUST STAKEHOLDERS.
I'M SORRY. CAN CAN YOU TO? OH,
I'M SORRY DIRECTLY TO RUNNING
THE PLANT PLANT OPERATIONS. SO
PER SP 846 AND ALSO MEMORIALIZED
IN THE LOAN AGREEMENT. THESE
FUNDS FOR PG ME IS TO BE USED
FOR DIABLO CANYON. UM AND ALSO,
YOU KNOW ALL PAROLE THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THERE. THAT FOR
THE COST TO BE KIND OF ELIGIBLE,
UM AND REASONABLE THEY ARE NOT
TO BE USED FOR SHAREHOLDER
PAYOUTS. SO THAT'S DIRECTLY IN
SP 846 AND THEN MEMORIALIZED IN
THE LOAN AGREEMENT BETWEEN DWR
NPG NHIÀU. GOT IT. IT JUST AS A
NECESSARY IS FOCUSSED ON BUT SO
DO YOU. HAVE YOU HAVE A LOAN
REPAYMENT SCHEDULE FOR THE MONEY
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN LOAN FROM
THE STATE. DO WE HAVE A
REPAYMENT SCHEDULE? THE SCHEDULE
IS DEPENDENT ON, FOR EXAMPLE,
THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY
AGREEMENT THAT PG AND E HAS A,
UM, NEGOTIATED DIRECTLY WITH
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY AND SO
AGAIN, THE MOST PUBLIC
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE SEEN
RECENTLY IS 2025 DATE. OKAY, I'M
SURE WE'LL BE FOLLOWING UP ON ON
THIS. UM WHILE YOU'RE HERE. WHAT
IS THE CURRENT STATUS OF THE
CENTRAL PROCUREMENT? FUNCTION.
AND WHEN DOES ADMINISTRATION
EXPECT TO NEED DID YOU HAVE TO
DEPLOY THIS OPTION? SURE THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. I WILL
HAVE TO SAY THAT I'M PROBABLY
ONLY HALF THE ANSWER. SO THIS
ALSO DEPENDS ON MY COLLEAGUES,
PERHAPS AT THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION CAN OPINE,
BUT RIGHT NOW WE ARE STARTING TO
FOLLOW THE INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PROCEEDING THAT WE EXPECT TO
HAVE THAT CENTRAL PROCUREMENT
DISCUSSION. BUT AS SPECIFIED IN
AN ABBEY 1373. THE CPUC HAS
UNTIL SEPTEMBER 1ST 2024 TO
DETERMINE IF THERE IS A NEED AT
THAT POINT IN TIME FOR CENTRAL
PROCUREMENT OF RESOURCES. SO DWR
HAS WE'VE STARTED PREPARING TO
ENGAGE IN THAT DISCUSSION, BUT
ULTIMATELY IT WILL DEPEND ON THE
CPUC PROCESS AND, YOU KNOW,
PUBLIC, UH, PUBLIC PROCESS AND
PROCEEDING. OKAY? UM. GOOD WELL
UP ON THAT AS WELL. I'M SURE AND
THE STRATEGIC RESERVE. HOW UM,
HOW WAS THAT UTILIZED LAST
SUMMER AND HOUSE DEPARTMENT
PLANNING FOR THE UPCOMING
SUMMER? YES THANK YOU FOR THAT
QUESTION. SO FOR THE RESERVE
ITSELF, I DO WANT TO KNOW IT'S A
LITTLE CONFUSING BECAUSE THERE'S
SEVERAL ASSETS AND THEY'VE COME
INTO THE RESERVE AT DIFFERENT
POINTS IN TIME. BUT IN TERMS OF
JUST LAST SUMMER, WE HAD OUR
CORE STATE POWER AUGMENTATION
PROGRAM UNITS, AND THOSE WERE
AVAILABLE FOR DISPATCH DURING
THE EXTREME EVENTS IN JULY, SO
THERE WERE THREE OF THEM. THERE
WAS THE FIRST ONE WAS THE ENERGY
EMERGENCY ALERT ON JULY 20TH.
AND THEN THERE WAS TO LATER ONES
OF A KIND OF, I GUESS THE
CAISSON TURN WOULD BE A WATCH
DECLARATION. JULY 25TH AND 26
AND EACH OF THOSE WERE EVENTS
WERE VERY DIFFERENT FROM EACH
OTHER SO THAT THE UNITS WERE
PREPARED FOR THAT, UM, AS WELL
AS THE ADDITIONAL IMPORTS. UH
THAT DWR SUPPORTED THAT WERE
ABOVE THE MARKET COSTS THAT WE
WORKED WITH WITH THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES. SO THOSE WERE
THE TWO CORE ASPECTS OF WHAT WAS
AVAILABLE IN THE RESERVE LAST
SUMMER. MOVING INTO THIS COMING
SUMMER, WE HAVE AGAIN THE SAME
STATE POWER AUGMENTATION PROGRAM
UNITS, SO IT'S ABOUT 120
MEGAWATTS OF THAT WE NO LONGER
HAVE AUTHORIZATION FOR IMPORTS
FOR THIS COMING SUMMER. BUT
INSTEAD WE DO HAVE OVER 3000
MEGAWATTS OF THE I'M SORRY OVER
2000 MEGAWATTS OF THE ONCE
THROUGH COOLING RESOURCES. THOSE
ENTERED INTO THE RESERVE JANUARY
1ST 2024. WE ALSO HAVE THREE
ADDITIONAL UNITS THAT ARE, UM
THE DWR HAD BEEN CONSTRUCTING,
TWO OF WHICH ARE READY. ANOTHER
ONE IS NEARING CONSTRUCTION
COMPLETION, SO COMING UP FOR THE
SUMMER. WE SHOULD HAVE A TOTAL
OF 3150 MEGAWATTS OR SO OF
GENERATION AVAILABLE. AND UM OR
THEIR PROGRAMMING IMPACTS OF
THERE'S I THINK $55 MILLION
DELAY. WELL THAT HAVE IMPACTS AT
THIS POINT IN TIME FROM WHAT WE
SEE IT'S UNLIKELY TO IMPACT DWR
S ABILITY TO OVERSEE THE PROGRAM
AND OUR ASSETS OR TO EXECUTE
ADDITIONAL CONTRACTS. SO, UM,
YOU KNOW, WE'VE PLANNED THIS OUT
FAIRLY CAREFULLY. ACROSS THE
MULTIPLE YEARS OF THE RESERVE.
KIND OF. WELL AS YOU DISCUSSED
IN PREVIOUS HEARINGS, LOOK
FORWARD TO MAKING SURE THAT IN
THE FUTURE WE CAN, UM WORK
TOGETHER, PROCURE MORE CLEAN
ENERGY IN THAT IF WE HAVE A
FUTURE RESERVE UM LIKE TO MOVE
ON TO OUR THANK YOU. YOUR
MISSION VEHICLE. PROGRAM. AND
MAY REQUIRE SOME DIFFERENT FOLKS
UP HERE. UM. JUST WAIT A MOMENT.
SUPPOSE AND GET SETTLED. LET'S
JUST START TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT
OF A COMMENT HERE. UM THE EFFORT
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL THE BUDGET
PROPOSED TO LAY 45 MILLION FOR
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL FROM 2425 TO
2728. LAST YEAR, WE DID TAKE
STRONG ACTION TO ADDRESS PRICE
GOUGING BY ORAL FINE ARIES THAT
ARE UM THAT MANY FELT WERE
ARTIFICIALLY RAISING PRICE. BUT
LET'S NOT FORGET THE BIGGER
PICTURE THE BEST WAY TO INSULATE
PEOPLE FROM HIGHER GAS PRICES IS
TO GET THEM OFF OF GASOLINE AND
MOVE THEM. 20 EMISSION
TRANSPORTATION SOLUTIONS. YEAH
AND I'M CONCERNED THAT SOME OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT WERE DELAYING
HERE UM, ARE THE ONES THAT HAVE
BEEN TAILORED TO HELP THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE MOST SENSITIVE TO
FUEL? PRICES WHETHER BE LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS UNDER CARDS FOR
ALL OR A SMALL FLEET TRUCK
DRIVERS UNDER H V I P. THESE ARE
PEOPLE WE KNOW ARE MOST
SENSITIVE TO FUEL PRICES AND
AFFECTED BY THEM. SO. MY FIRST
QUESTION IS, CAN WE PROVIDE AN
UPDATE ON STATEWIDE AND LOCAL
AIR DISTRICT RUN PROGRAMS AND.
WHAT IS THE TIMELINE FOR
IMPLICATION FOR THE STATEWIDE?
PROGRAM. YES THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION. MICHELLE BUFFINGTON,
THE CHIEF BUDGET POLICY OFFICER
AT THE CALIFORNIA RESOURCES
BOARD. UM TO YOUR FOR AN UPDATE
REGARDING WHERE WE ARE WITH THE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAMS, I
WOULD SAY THAT WE HAVE SPENT. WE
HAVE DELIVERED 13,000 VEHICLES.
TO DATE WHICH HAVE RESULTED IN
ABOUT 100,000 TONS OF GHG
EMISSIONS. 104 TONS OF NITROUS
OXIDE EMISSION REDUCTIONS AND
17.4 TONS OF ROCK EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS. THE NEW JOINT
STATEWIDE, CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
AND FINANCING ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
IS CURRENTLY UNDER DEVELOPMENT
AND IS EXPECTED TO OPEN IN MID
2024. WE ANTICIPATE HIGH DEMAND
FOR THE PROGRAM, AND IN ADDITION
, THE MAJORITY OF THE DISTRICT
RUN PROGRAMS ARE CURRENTLY OPEN
AND RUNNING. UM OKAY? UM.
ADMINISTRATION OF A PLAN FOR HOW
WE ENSURE THAT THAT THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE DELIVERING INCENTIVES
TO LONGTIME CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY TO SUPPORT
OPERATIONS. AS WE KIND OF
NAVIGATE THROUGH THESE NEXT
COUPLE OF YEARS. THANK YOU.
CHAIR CHRISTIAN BUILT IN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE, SO
THAT'S REALLY THE BASIS OF WHY
WE'RE PROPOSING TO SHIFT A
NUMBER OF THE DIFFERENT FUNDS TO
THE OUT YEARS, SO WE REALLY WANT
TO STAY COMMITTED TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE APPROPRIATING RESOURCES
FOR THE CLEAN CARS FOR ALL
PROGRAMS, BUT ALSO OTHER
EQUITABLE FOCUS PROGRAMS SUCH AS
THE EQUITABLE AT HOME CHARGING.
WE'RE STILL PLANNING ON
APPROPRIATING $60 MILLION OF G R
F IN 2526 FOR THAT PROGRAM. 40
MILLION IN 2627 AND THEN
80,000,027 28, SO WE STILL ARE
DEFINITELY PRIORITIZING SOME OF
THOSE PROGRAMS AND HAVE PLANS TO
CONTINUE TO TRY TO FUND THOSE TO
THE EXTENT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE. OKAY. UH, THE. WELL I
GUESS I'LL MOVE ONTO THE CLEAN
VEHICLE ASSISTANCE PROGRAM, BUT,
UM YOU KNOW, WE'LL WE'LL DIVE IN
HAVE THE CHANCE TO DIVE INTO
OBVIOUS THAT FUTURE HEARINGS.
BUT I ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO
MAKING SURE THAT WE TALK ABOUT,
UH AND CONTINUE OUR CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW TO TARGET THESE
INCENTIVES AT SUPER USERS.
PEOPLE THAT WE KNOW NOW ARE THE
ONES WHO ARE DRIVING THE MOST,
AND THAT MAY ALSO FALL INTO
THESE OTHER CATEGORIES THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT THAT DISCUSSION.
IN TERMS OF THE CLEAN VEHICLE
SYSTEMS PROGRAM, LEGISLATURA
ALLOCATE MORE THAN 100 AND
33,000,002 FINANCING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR LOW INCOME.
CONSUMERS OFTEN SURE TO RECEIVE
APP. IT'S INTERESTING. THIS
PROGRAM HASN'T BEEN OPERATIONAL
FOR SEVERAL YEARS. CAN YOU
EXPLAIN WHAT IS DELAYING
IMPLEMENTATION AND HOW MUCH
FUNDING STILL AVAILABLE PROGRAM?
SURE THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
QUESTION. SO YOU ARE CORRECT
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS HAD
APPROPRIATED 101 $133.5 MILLION
FOR THESE PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON
PROVIDING FINANCING ASSISTANCE
TO LOW INCOME CONSUMERS THAT WE
ACTUALLY AT CARVER SPLIT THAT
INTO TWO PROGRAMS. ONE THAT WAS
THE STATEWIDE WHICH IS THE C VAP
PROGRAM THAT YOU'RE SPEAKING OF.
AND ONE THAT WENT TO A LOCAL
PILOT PROJECT AND BOTH OF THOSE
WERE OPERATING AS PILOT PROJECTS
THROUGHOUT FROM 26 TO 2016 TILL
TODAY. UM I THINK WHEN YOU'RE
REFERRING TO THAT, IT HASN'T
BEEN AVAILABLE. THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME STARTS AND STOPS BASED ON
THE APPROPRIATIONS AS THEY HAD
COME IN FOR THE STATEWIDE
PROGRAM. BUT BOTH PROGRAMS WERE
OPERATIONAL AS OF SUMMER OF 2023
WHEN THIS WHICH WHICH IS WHEN
THEY EXHAUSTED THEIR LAST ROUNDS
OF FUNDING. WE ARE CURRENTLY IN
A PAUSE AND LET ME STEP BACK FOR
JUST A SECOND THAT THAT HAS
COVERED 53 MILLION OF THE 133.5
MILLION THAT HAS BEEN
APPROPRIATED TO US. THE
REMAINING FUNDING WAS COMBINED
INTO A JOINT SOLICITATION THAT
INCLUDED. BOTH ARE CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL PROGRAM AND OUR
STATEWIDE FINANCING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM, AND WE WERE TAKING A
LOT OF LESSONS LEARNED FROM
THOSE TWO PILOTS AND
INCORPORATING THEM INTO THIS NEW
STATEWIDE PROGRAM, WHICH WE
INTEND TO LAUNCH IN MID 2024. IS
THERE ANYTHING PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE ABOUT THE LESSONS
LEARNED THAT YOU REFERRED TO?
YES YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO FIND
EXAMPLES OF THOSE LESSONS
LEARNED IN OUR FUNDING PLAN THAT
THEY WERE DISCUSSED DURING OUR
PUBLIC PROCESS THIS PREVIOUS
YEAR WHEN THE BOARD IS THAT, UM
MOVED. IT DIDN'T DROP THAT ARE
FUNDING PLAN, BUT I WILL POINT
OUT THAT THE TWO MAIN AREAS
WHERE THAT, UM WHAT WE HAD
DETERMINED FROM THOSE PILOTS IS
THAT IT NEEDS BASED APPROACH WE
NEEDED TO EVALUATE A MUCH MORE
RIGOROUS NEEDS BASED APPROACH
THAN WHAT WAS THE FIRST COME
FIRST SERVE OF THE ORIGINAL
STATEWIDE FINANCING ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM, AND SO BOTH DETERMINING
THAT MODEL ON HOW TO SERVE LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS. UM AND IT IN
PRIORITIZE THOSE MOST IN NEED,
ALONG WITH MAKING SURE THAT WE
COULD PACE THE FUNDING AND HAVE
IT AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT THE
WHOLE PROGRAM. FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WERE THE TWO MAIN
THINGS THAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON
FROM THE COMMENTS THAT WE
LEARNED IN THE PILOTS. YEAH I'D
SAY THOSE ARE CRITICAL. HOW MANY
LAUNCHERS LOANS HAS THIS FUNDING
RESULTED IN THE LOCAL AND
STATEWIDE PILOTS. UM RESULTED IN
OVER 500 CLEAN VEHICLE GRANTS
AND ABOUT IN ABOUT 100 LOANS.
DIRECT LOANS. THERE WERE
MULTIPLE FINANCING MECHANISMS
THAT WERE AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS
WHEN THEY CAME IN AND HAD THEIR
PROGRAM. WE'RE BOTH VERY HIGH
TOUCH, MEANING THAT WHEN LOW
INCOME CONSUMERS CAME IN, THEY
HAD A FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO HELP
THEM TALK THROUGH ALL THEIR
FINANCES TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
WORKED BEST FOR THEM. SO ABOUT
100 OF THOSE APPLICANTS DID GO
DOWN THE LONE PATH. A SMALL
NUMBER GIVEN THE FUNDING, THOUGH
THE 100 LOAN FROM DIRECTLY FROM
THE PROGRAM, BUT THERE WERE
STILL 5000 GRANTS THAT WENT TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO CAME IN THROUGH
THE FINANCING ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
, AND WE ALSO IF YOU'RE
INTERESTED IN MORE DETAILS AND
FACTS ABOUT THE KIND OF THE
OUTCOMES FROM THAT PROGRAM, WE
DO POST THOSE ONLINE IN THEIR
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO SHARE THEM WITH THE
OFFICE. YEAH I JUST DIED AND
AGAIN, ALL THESE THINGS WILL
HAVE A CHANCE TO DIVE INTO MORE.
BUT, UM IT'S AMONG THE MOST
CRITICAL. TOP PRIORITIES WE HAVE
. WE'RE GONNA MAKE THE
TRANSITION TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE PRAYING INCENTIVES IN THE
RIGHT PLACES THAT WE CAN MAKE
HELP. LOW INCOME CONSUMERS.
LOWER INCOME CONSUMERS GET INTO
THESE ELECTIONS, VEHICLES AND
BENEFIT FROM THIS TECHNOLOGY AND
THEN HAVE THE APPROPRIATE
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE, AS WAS
ALSO ALLUDED TO SO I'M SURE
WE'LL COME BACK. THANK YOU. THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES USE GROFT
BACKFIELD IS OF PACKAGE. AND
WHAT'S THE RATIONALE THERE? AND
DO WE KNOW ABOUT THESE PROGRAMS
COST EFFECTIVENESS IN TERMS OF
REDUCING EMISSIONS AND WHICH
ONES HAVE BEEN THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
THE Z PACKAGE? OVERALL. BRANDON
MERIT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ONE
OF THE MAIN CONSIDERATIONS FOR
THE ADMINISTRATION IS AT THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
ISN'T APPROPRIATE FUND SOURCE TO
BACKFILL GENERAL FUND SOLUTIONS
IN THE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
PACKAGE, GIVEN THAT THE
STATUTORY FOCUS OF THE GIRAFFE
IS ON THE REDUCTION OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. AND
FURTHER GIVEN THAT THE
INVESTMENTS IN THE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE PACKAGE ARE PRIMARILY
GEARED TOWARDS ACHIEVING THOSE
SAME GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS.
THIS MAKES GROF INAPPROPRIATE.
PHONE SOURCE WITH AN APPROPRIATE
NEXUS FOR GENERAL FUND SOLUTIONS
WITHIN THIS PACKAGE. AND CHAIR
BECKER CHRISTIAN BELL TOWER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IF I
COULD ALSO ADD SOME MORE CONTEXT
IN TERMS OF THE RATIONALE IT
THESE APPROPRIATIONS ALSO HELP
IN TERMS OF ADDRESSING KIND OF
THE ONGOING MARKET CONDITIONS
THAT WE'RE SEEING AS WELL IN
TERMS OF THE VEHICLE PRICES, THE
ONGOING HIGHER INTEREST
BORROWING COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
PURCHASING A NEW VEHICLE. IT
ALSO HELPS IN ADDRESSING A LOT
OF THE EMISSION GOALS FOCUSED ON
BUSY CORRIDORS THAT REALLY DO
IMPACT OR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE STATE.
AND THEN LASTLY, IT ALSO HELPS
CONTINUE TO THESE PROGRAMS
CONTINUE TO SEE VERY HIGH DEMAND
ACROSS THE BOARD. SO THAT'S KIND
OF THE RATIONALE AS TO WHY WE
REALLY WANTED TO FOCUS YOUR
GIRAFFE INTO THIS SPACE. AND
THEN, UM, LAST, BUT NOT LEAST
HERE. OTHER QUESTION IN TERMS OF
THE COST EFFECTIVENESS. I THINK
THIS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER IN
THE TESTIMONY FROM MY COLLEAGUE
AT THE YELLOW. THERE IS THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE INVESTMENTS
FOR ANNUAL REPORT THAT DOES
TRACK SOME OF THE COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE PROGRAMS
SO HAPPY TO PROVIDE THAT TO YOU
AND YOUR STAFF. THERE'S A
SPECIFIC APPENDIX TOWARD IS THE
FACT THAT WE CAN PROVIDE THAT.
THAT TRACKS FOR EXISTING GROF
PROGRAMS. CORRECT YES, AND WE DO
HAVE SOME DATA ON THAT CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL, AND SOME OF THE
OTHERS HAVE PROGRAMS AS PART OF
THAT REPORT. UM GOOD AND ON TOP
OF YOUR HEAD AND WHICH ONE IS
THE MOST EFFECTIVE? ANY IN THE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE REALM. UH
NOT ON. NOT ON. NOT ON IN FRONT
OF ME RIGHT NOW. YEAH. OKAY?
WELL, THANK YOU ALL LIKE TO MOVE
ON TO COASTAL RESILIENCY.
THANK YOU. AND THE GOVERNOR'S
SOLUTION REDUCES COASTAL
RESILIENCE. FUNNY WAY 452
MILLION AND ALSO SHIFTS
37,000,002 G R F UM THIS TOPIC
IS OF GREAT. INTEREST IN MY
DISTRICT AND MANY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. HOW MUCH OF THE ORIGINAL
FUNDING TO THE CONSERVANCY FOR
COASTAL RESILIENCE HAS BEEN
APPROPRIATED? SO THE GENERAL
FUND SOLUTIONS FOR THE
CONSERVANCY. UM OUR TOTAL OF 392
MILLION, WHICH MAINTAINS 489
MILLION FOR THESE PROGRAMS AT
THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY, AND OF
THAT 489 MILLION. BASICALLY ALL
OF IT HAS BEEN COMMITTED OR
AUTHORIZED FOR PROJECTS. AND
WHAT ARE YOU EXAMPLES OF SOME OF
THE PROJECTS? THAT CONSERVANCY
IS FUNDED Tð. HELP BOLSTER
COASTERS. SCIENCE YEAH, I COULD
DO THAT FOR HOURS AND BUT I
WON'T. THAT'S IT. YEAH, I WON'T.
BUT THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
SOME OF THE ONES TO HIGHLIGHT
INCLUDE, UM TORREY PINES STATE
BEACH IN SAN DIEGO. A GRANT TO
DEVELOP NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS
TO BUILD RESILIENCY TO SEA LEVEL
RISE. AND COASTAL HAZARDS FOR
THAT STATE BEACH, THE PALAMAR
SEWER AND WATER RELOCATION
PROJECT IN SAN MATEO COUNTY. SO
A GRANT TO THE RCD TO PLAN AND
DO ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
PERMITTING TO RELOCATE PUBLIC
SEWER INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
LOCATED ON AN ERODING CLIFF
SIDE. WE JUST GAVE A LARGE GRANT
TO THE LOS CERRITOS WETLANDS
AUTHORITY AND LONG BEACH FOR THE
SOUTHERN LOS CERRITOS WETLANDS
RESTORATION PROJECT. UM, WE HAVE
GRANTS FOR THE TIJUANA ESTUARY
RESTORATION, UM, CITY OF SAN
DIEGO. COASTAL RESILIENCE,
MASTER PLANNING. ORMOND BEACH
RESTORATION IN OXNARD SURFERS
POINT MANAGED RETREAT IN VENTURA
, THE SOUTH SAN FRANCISCO BAY
SHORELINE PROJECT, UM IN SAN
MATEO, SANTA CLARA AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY'S, UM BOLINAS LAGOON UP
PROJECT TO MOVE BACK A SECTION
OF ROAD AND RESTORE WETLANDS TO
ADAPT TO SEA LEVEL RISE AND
COASTAL RESILIENCE, PLANNING FOR
FRONTLINE COMMUNITIES AND HUMBLE
BAY SO THAT THOSE ARE SOME
EXAMPLES THERE, UM, WELL OVER
250 PROJECTS. THANK YOU, MR
LIZARD. THOSE ARE GOOD EXAMPLES.
WILL THE CONSERVANCY BE ABLE TO
TAKE ON NEW COASTAL RESILIENCE
AND ADAPTATION PROJECTS WITH THE
PROPOSED CUTS? NO UM, WE HAVE
ALLOCATED ALL OF THE GENERAL
FUND MONEY FOR COASTAL
RESILIENCE AND SEA LEVEL RISE
AND THE G R F FUNDING THAT WE
WERE APPROPRIATED. SO, UM, WE
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE ON
ADDITIONAL PROJECTS AT THIS
POINT. AND THEY'RE FUN, FEDERAL
FUNDING OR WHAT ARE THE WHAT ARE
THE OTHER OTHER SOURCES
AVAILABLE FOR THESE KINDS OF
PROJECTS? YES OUR STAFF ARE
WORKING VERY HARD TO APPLY FOR
AND SECURE FEDERAL FUNDS. WE
HAVE APPLIED FOR 11 DIFFERENT
GRANTS. JUST THIS FISCAL YEAR,
INCLUDING Tð. UM GRANT SITTER
EACH $75 MILLION THROUGH NOAH
ONE FOR SAN FRANCISCO BAY
WETLANDS RESTORATION AND SEA
LEVEL RISE RESILIENCE AND ONE
FOR WETLANDS RESTORATION. UM
ALONG THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
COAST, UM, THAT THE TOTAL, UM
AMOUNT FOR THAT GRANT PROGRAM IS
ABOUT 600 MILLION. THIS WAS THE
PROGRAM PRESIDENT BIDEN CAME OUT
TO PALO ALTO AND ANNOUNCED THIS
PROGRAM SO I DON'T KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO RECEIVE
150 MILLION OF THE TOTAL 600
MILLION, BUT WE ARE WORKING VERY
HARD ON ON THOSE TWO GRANTS AS
WELL AS, UM NINE OTHER GRANT
APPLICATIONS I WAS THERE. YEAH
THERE WAS THERE WITH HIM
PALLIATIVE SO GRATEFUL TO THE
BIDEN HARRIS ADMINISTRATION FOR
ALL OF US FUNDING. LET'S MAKE
SURE WE GET OUR SHARE. JUST CAN
I ASK YOU, LASTLY TO KIND OF
PINE ON? THE SCALE OF THE NEED
FOR COASTAL ADAPTATION PROJECTS.
YEAH AND I KNOW LAST YEAR I
MENTIONED $110 BILLION FIGURE
JUST FOR SAN FRANCISCO BAY IF WE
WANTED TO, UM, SECURE. UM
EVERYTHING IN PLACE, AND I THINK
THAT ASSUMED JUST OVER A 4 FT.
SEA LEVEL RISE, SO I KNOW 100
AND 10 BILLION IS NOT THE MOST
HELPFUL NUMBER. UM, AND THAT'S
JUST SAN FRANCISCO BAY. UM, I
THINK FOR THE ENTIRE CALIFORNIA
COAST YOU'RE LOOKING AT UM, MORE
THAN DOUBLING THAT NUMBER. UH I
THINK IT'S A MIX OF, YOU KNOW,
WHAT ARE WE TRYING TO, UM,
SECURE IN PLACE? UH AND WHAT ARE
THE METHODS THAT WE'RE USING TO
DO SO FOR THE COASTAL
CONSERVANCY? OUR INTERESTS ARE
REALLY IN NATURE BASED
ADAPTATION TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE AND IN WORKING WITH
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE LESS
CAPACITY. UM TO, UM TO CONDUCT,
SEA LEVEL RISE, ADAPTATION,
PLANNING AND IMPLEMENTATION ON
THEIR OWN. HMM. UM. AND SORT OF
FOOD JUMPING INTO ANYTHING THAT
IN TERMS OF SP ONE
IMPLEMENTATION. UM HOW HOW IS
HOW IS THAT GOING? AND UM, I
GUESS HOW WOULD YOU CHARACTERIZE
THAT? YEAH WELL, HOW HOW IS THAT
GOING? RIGHT THANK YOU. CHAIR
BECKER. UM, SO WE WERE. THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL WAS
ORIGINALLY APPROPRIATED THIS
FUNDING IN RECOGNITION THAT THE
POTENTIAL POTENTIAL LOSS OR
DAMAGE TO PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE,
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND NATURAL
HABITATS DUE TO SEE LEVEL RISE
IS SIGNIFICANT AND URGENT. AS AS
YOU ALL KNOW, SO WE LAUNCHED OUR
SENATE BILL ONE GRANT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE CRITICAL INVESTMENTS TO
LOCAL, REGIONAL AND TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DEVELOP SEA LEVEL
RISE ADAPTATION PLANS AND
PROJECTS. WE'VE HAD SIGNIFICANT
PUBLIC OUTREACH FOR THIS PROGRAM
. IT'S BEEN UNDERWAY AND MANY
STAKEHOLDERS AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE EXPRESSED A
LOT OF INTEREST AND NEED FOR
THIS FUNDING TO SUPPORT SEE
LEVEL RISE, ADAPTATION PLANNING
AND ON THE GROUND PROJECTS. SO
UM, DISBURSEMENT FOR THE
ENTIRETY OF FUNDING FROM OUR
2022 AND 23 AND 2324
APPROPRIATIONS WERE APPROVED BY
OUR COUNCIL AT THEIR AUGUST
MEETING LAST YEAR. THEY INCLUDE
A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE DIRECT APPLICATION
SERVICES, TOO, UNDER RESOURCED
COMMUNITIES TO APPLY FOR THOSE
FUNDS. THE PROPOSED GENERAL FUND
SOLUTION WILL REQUIRE OPC TODAY
TO DELAY AWARDS FOR OUR 2023 24
FUNDING AS THE THAT GENERAL FUND
IS PROPOSED TO BE SHIFTED TO G G
R F SO WE HAVE LAUNCHED THIS
COMPETITIVE SOLICITATION. WE
HAVE A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDER. UM AND WE ARE
BEGINNING QUARTERLY ROLLING
AWARDS, STARTING AS WE SPEAK. UM
AND SO WE'VE GOT A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF FUNDING TO START
MOVING THAT PROGRAM. HMM. AND
THERE ARE SOME REDUCTIONS HERE
AS WELL. I MEAN, WELL, THAT HOW
WOULD THAT AFFECT THESE EFFORTS?
YEAH SO THOSE REDUCTIONS WILL
OBVIOUSLY REDUCED THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT WE CAN PROVIDE TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES TO BUILD
RESILIENCE TO SEA LEVEL RISE. WE
KNOW FROM SOME RESEARCH THAT WE
ARE COUNCIL HAS INVESTED IN AT
LEAST JUST ON THE OPEN COAST.
THE MAJORITY OF COASTAL
JURISDICTIONS UP TO 63. LACK
COMPREHENSIVE, CONSISTENT AND
SCIENTIFICALLY ROBUST, SEA LEVEL
RISE ADAPTATION PLANS THAT ARE
ADEQUATE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PREPARED IN THE FACE OF SEA
LEVEL RISE AND ASSOCIATED
FLOODING AND EROSION AND DAMAGE.
UM WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ESTIMATED COST OF DEVELOPING SEA
LEVEL RISE ADAPTATION PLANS CAN
BE ANYWHERE FROM $250,000 TO UP
TO A MILLION DOLLARS. DEPENDING
ON THE SCOPE AND SCALE OF THE
PLAN, WHETHER WE'RE LOOKING AT A
CITY OR COUNTY OR REGIONAL LEVEL
, UM SO THOSE PROPOSED SOLUTIONS
AND REDUCTIONS WILL RESULT IN
FEWER STATE FUNDS AVAILABLE FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DEVELOP SEA
LEVEL RISE ADAPTATION PLANS AND
PROJECTS, LEAVING THOSE
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT ADEQUATE
RESOURCES TO PLAN AND INFORM
INVESTMENTS AND ADAPTATION
PROJECTS. THANK YOU, MR KUWAIT.
THESE ARE CRITICAL TO SO MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES, SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO AND DRIVING HIM MORE
AS A YOUR GOES ON. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DID WANT TO, UM SO.
BECOME BACK, HAVE SOME WATER.
BORDER SHED AND WATER STORAGE
QUESTIONS, BUT DID WANT TO UM
MAKE SURE COVERED SUSTAINABLE
AGRICULTURE. MAYBE WE COULD HAVE
GOOD JOB, FOLKS COME UP.
DISCUSSED THE PROPOSED CUTS TO
PROGRAMS I KNOW ARE. CERTAINLY
IMPACTFUL MY DISTRICT AND THE
FOLKS WERE VERY MUCH LOOKING
FORWARD TO, UM. THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL REDUCES 23 MILLION
ACROSS COUPLE CDFA PROGRAMS 14
MILLION TO THE FARM TO COMMUNITY
FOOD HUBS PROGRAM. UM, WHICH IS
REALLY A UM UH, IMPORTANT.
EFFORT UH AROUND AGGREGATION
DISTRIBUTION INFRASTRUCTURE. UM
THAT'S NEEDED TO INCREASE
PURCHASES OF LOCAL FROM A
SUSTAINABLE CLIMATE, SMART,
EQUITABLY PRODUCED FOOD. AND
AGAINST MIGHT JUST IT WAS VERY
MUCH LOOKING FORWARD TO, UM, 9
MILLION FOR THE HEALTHY HEALTH
REFRIGERATION GRANT PROGRAM.
THERE WAS SOME SHIFTS AROUND THE
LIVESTOCK METHANE REDUCTION
PROGRAMS, SO HMM. WHAT'S
RATIONAL FOR RATIONALE FOR
LIMITING. THE 14 MILLION, SO
THEY GET FOR FORMAL COMMUNITY
FOOD HUBS. THAT LEAVES ONLY I
THINK ABOUT A MILLION DOLLARS
REMAINING. JULIANNE ROLF
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO UM
THIS PROGRAM IS NEW. AND SO THE
RATIONALE WAS WHEN LOOKING AT
PROGRAMS TO CUT KEEP THE CURRENT
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND SEE WHICH
ONES COULD BE CUT THAT HAVEN'T
STARTED YET. AND SO THE 14
MILLION, UM, ISN'T AFFECTING
ANYONE. THAT BECAUSE NO GRANTS
HAVE BEEN, UM GIVEN IT YET. GET.
YEAH CHAIR BECKER'S CHRISTIAN
BELTRAN WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE JUST TO ADD SOME
ADDITIONAL CONTEXT THERE.
THERE'S NO GRANTS YET HAD BEEN
ADVERTISED AT THAT AT THIS
PARTICULAR POINT WHEN THE
ADMINISTRATION DECIDED TO
PROPOSE THIS AS A REDUCTION,
HOWEVER, WE ARE REQUESTING TO
RETAIN SOME OF THE FUNDING
RELATED TO SOME OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
UNDER WAY AT CDF TO AND
SPECIFICALLY, THOSE FUNDS ARE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO FUND
SETTING UP SOMEWHAT IN THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE PROGRAM AS WE
CONTINUE TO LOOK AND SEE IF WE
CAN FUND THIS PART GRAHAM IN THE
FUTURE, SO THERE'S STILL SOME
GROUNDWORK LEVEL A BASIC WORK
HAPPENING AT CDF, AND I'M HAPPY
TO TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE
TO PROVIDE MORE CONTEXT FOR
THAT. THANK YOU. ARMY CASINO
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE. THANK YOU. SO MUCH
FOR THE QUESTION. SO PRIOR TO
THE PROGRAM AS AS MY COLLEAGUE
AT D O F MENTIONED PRIOR TO THIS
PROGRAM BEING IDENTIFIED AS PART
OF THE GENERAL FUND SOLUTION
ADMINISTRATIVE DOLLARS WERE
BEING SPENT IN THE CURRENT YEAR
TO SET UP THE PROGRAM, INCLUDING
THE FARM TO COMMUNITY FOOD HUBS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. RETAINING
THE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ADMINISTRATIVE FUNDING ALLOWS
FOR THE RECENTLY HIRED STAFF
MEMBER TO CONTINUE BUILDING THAT
GROUNDWORK, INCLUDING
INTERVIEWING STAKEHOLDERS,
DEVELOPING OTHER RESOURCES FOR
FOOD HUBS IN THE ABSENCE OF
GRANT FUNDS, WORKING WITH
APPLICANTS WHO HAD APPLIED TO BE
PART OF THAT ADVISORY COMMITTEE
AND DEVELOPING MATERIALS FOR A
PROGRAM IF IT IS FUNDED,
SOMETIMES IN THE FUTURE. IT
SHOULD ALSO BE NOTED THAT THE
STAFF MEMBER HELPS TO SUPPORT
FOOD HUB EFFORTS AS PART OF THE
FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM. WHICH
WILL HAVE A TRACK FOR FOOD HUBS
AS PART OF THAT PROGRAM. I
APPRECIATE THAT I DO. I WAS JUST
DISPUTE THAT PEOPLE AREN'T
AFFECTED BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE
PLANNING AND ANTICIPATING THIS
THIS PROGRAM UM, WE'RE GOING TO
HEALTHY REFRIGERATION. UH,
PROGRAM. DO YOU PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF AWARD GRANTS AND HOW
THAT PROGRAM IS GOING SO FAR.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU, UM, THE
HEALTHY REFRIGERATION GRANT
PROGRAM ANNOUNCED A WORDS OF
APPROXIMATELY $9 MILLION IN
FUNDING TO 103 GRANTEES IN
DECEMBER OF 2023. THE GRANTS
WILL SUPPORT 43 CORNER STORES IN
SMALL BUSINESSES. THAT'S ABOUT
$2.7 MILLION OF THE FUNDING. $4
MILLION WILL FUND 15 CITIES,
COUNTIES, TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS OR
NONPROFITS THAT SERVE AN
ESTIMATED 168 STORES AND $2
MILLION WILL GO TO 45 FOOD
DONATION PROGRAMS. THE GRANT
ROUND WAS EXTREMELY
OVERSUBSCRIBED, SO CDF RECEIVED
322 APPLICATIONS. TOTALLING OVER
$61 MILLION IN FUNDING REQUESTS
FOR THE $9 MILLION THAT WAS
AVAILABLE. GIVEN THE DEMAND.
MANY OF THE WORDS WERE FOR
PARTIAL FUNDING ONLY. IN
ADDITION, $900,000 WAS AWARDED
IN 2022 FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROVIDERS WHO PROVIDED SUPPORT
FOR APPLICANTS. APPLICANTS
INCLUDING TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
REGARDING EQUIPMENT, ENERGY
EFFICIENCY AND CLIMATE FRIENDLY
REFRIGERANTS. OUTREACH
ASSISTANCE, ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS. URBAN FOOD DESERT, UM,
AND AMONG NON ENGLISH SPEAKING
STORE OWNERS, APPLICATION
ASSISTANCE AND GRANT
IMPLEMENTATION, AND THEN CDFA
HAS CONTRACTING WITH THE
NUTRITION POLICY INSTITUTE AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES. WHICH WILL EVALUATE
THE EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM
AND JUST GIVE CONTINUAL UPDATE
ON HOW THAT PROGRAM'S GOING
MOVING FORWARD. I WANTED TO TURN
TO THE NUTRITIONAL INCENTIVE.
PROGRAM WHICH AGAIN YOU KNOW,
THESE GENERALLY AREN'T HUGE
NUMBERS, AND THIS IS A STUDENT
PROGRAM. I HEAR ABOUT A LOT IN
MY DISTRICT. UM AND, UM THIS
PROGRAM IS, YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT
SENTENCE FOR PURCHASE OF
CALIFORNIA GROWN FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES AT CERTIFIED FARMERS,
MARKETS AND UM IT ALSO INCLUDES
THE MARKET MATCH PROGRAM, SO WE
GET PEOPLE ON CALVARY. ANOTHER.
TWO FOR TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE FOREIGN WORKERS IS A HUGE
KIND OF WIN WIN AND THE THIS
BUDGET REDUCES IT BY 33 MILLION,
RETURNING ONLY A COUPLE OF
MILLION FOR ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
AND. THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
UNDERSTAND PRIZES, WON ONE MATCH
AND FEDERAL FUNDING TO STATE
INVESTMENT THROUGH THIS PROGRAM.
AND SO WE'RE NOT SPENDING WE
CAN'T JOIN IN THE FEDERAL FUNDS
SO WHY WOULD WE BE? REDUCING
THAT, CONSIDERING WE. ARE
LEAVING FEDERAL FUNDS ON THE
TABLE. YEAH, I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION CHAIR, SO, YOU KNOW.
ULTIMATELY THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS HAD PREVIOUS FUNDING
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS PROGRAM
BEFORE IN THE PREVIOUS BUDGET. I
THINK WE HAD 10 MILLION IN 21
AND THEN 10 MILLION IN 2022.
MAYBE 22 AND 23 HAVE TO TRIPLE
CHECK THAT, BUT ULTIMATELY, THIS
WAS ONE OF THOSE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS WHERE THE GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES JUST WERE NOT THERE.
UM THE TIMING OF THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS WERE ALSO IN QUESTION IN
TERMS OF WHEN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WOULD ACTUALLY GET
THE GRANT PROGRAM ROLLING ON IN
TERMS OF THE MATCH THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO, AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE BROADER
SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE PACKAGES
WHERE WE HAVE MANY PROGRAMS THAT
ARE STILL ONGOING AND OPERATING
VERY EFFICIENTLY. THIS WAS ONE
OF THOSE THAT WE JUST HAD TO
MAKE THE DIFFICULT DECISION TO
REDUCE. WELL ANYWAY, COME BACK
TO HIM THAT I CAN TELL YOU
BELIEVE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
PROGRAM AND I THINK THAT THIS
WOULD BE MISTAKES SO WELL. UM
COME COME BACK TO THAT I ALSO
LAST YEAR I SPENT A LOT OF TIME
ON ENTERIC METHANE, WHICH IS THE
LARGEST SOURCE OF METHANE
EMISSIONS IN THE STATE AND ONE
THAT WE'VE UM, MADE ALMOST NO
PROGRESS IN REDUCING SO GIVEN
THAT WHAT'S THE RATIONALE FOR
REDUCING THAT THE INTERIM METHOD
AND SENATE PROGRAM BY 23?
MILLION DOLLARS ONLY RETAINING
ABOUT 9% OF THE ORIGINAL MOUNT.
SO SENATOR BECKER. THIS ONE IN
PARTICULAR IS A CRITICAL
PROGRAM. BUT AS I THINK, UH,
IMPLIED IN THE QUESTION THE 23
MINUTES AT THE FULL AMOUNT THAT
WE'RE RETAINING, TOO, THAT WE
ARE PREVIOUSLY APPROPRIATED FOR
THE PROGRAM. WE STILL ARE TRYING
TO RETAIN SOME DOLLARS ASSOCIATE
WITH THE ADMINISTRATIVE COST TO
AGAIN CONTINUE THE IMPORTANT
WORK ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
PROGRAM. THERE IS SOME STAFFING
HOURS THAT HAVE BEEN ALREADY
FUNDED THROUGH THAT DOLLAR
AMOUNT, AND THERE'S STILL SOME
WORK GOING ON AT CDF RELATED TO
THAT PART. IN THE CASE THAT
THERE ARE RESOURCES IN THE
FUTURE. BUT AGAIN, MY COLLEAGUE
FROM CDF A CAN ALSO PROVIDE SOME
EXTRA CONTEXT AS TO HOW THEY'RE
STILL MAKING THINGS WORK. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION CHAIR.
YEAH, I CAN PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
MORE CONTEXT AROUND HOW THAT
REMAINING 8.7% OR $2 MILLION
WOULD BE SPENT. SO ESSENTIALLY
THAT FUNDING WOULD HELP SUPPORT
TO STAFF WHO ARE DEVELOPING THE
SCIENTIFIC FRAMEWORK FOR ENTERIC
METHANE REDUCTION THROUGH FETA
ADDITIVES. REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
OR NOT THERE'S INCENTIVE PROGRAM
OF FUNDING AVAILABLE SO AS
YOU'RE AWARE, SB 1383 REQUIRES
THAT THE STATE REDUCED METHANE
EMISSIONS 40% BY 2030.
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER WE HAVE AN
INCENTIVE PROGRAM WILL NEED TO
HAVE A METHODOLOGY TO EVALUATE
THE USE OF FEED ADDITIVES AND
STRATEGIES TO MEET THAT GOAL. SO
THE FIRST FDA REVIEWED PRODUCT
IS ANTICIPATED TO COME TO MARKET
THIS YEAR. AND AS SUCH, THERE
WILL BE WORK TO DO TO TRANSLATE
THE EXISTING RESEARCH AND
PRACTICE ADOPTION INTO EXPECTED
REDUCTIONS IN CALIFORNIA. SO
THIS FUNDING WILL SUPPORT OUR
COLLABORATION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND RESEARCHERS TO DEVELOP A
RELIABLE TOOL FOR ACCURATELY
MEASURING THE METHANE EMISSIONS.
UM REDUCED BY THIS PROGRAM, AND
THIS IS LIKELY TO BE A LENGTHY
PROCESS REQUIRING CONSIDERABLE
INPUT FROM EXPERTS TO TDF, A SO
IT WOULD INVOLVE FACILITATING
COLLABORATION ACROSS THE PUBLIC,
PRIVATE ACADEMIC AND GOVERNMENT
SECTORS AND PRESENTING SEMINARS
AND PUBLIC EVENTS ON THE TOPIC,
AND IT WILL ALSO HELP US TO
MODEL EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS FROM
FEED ADDITIVES TO UNDERSTAND HOW
SO IT WILL HELP US TO MODEL
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS. HELP US
UNDERSTAND HOW WILL MEET SB 1383
GOALS? AS MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED
, MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
FRAMEWORK IN THE EVENT OF AN
INCENTIVE DOLLARS ARE AVAILABLE
IN THE FUTURE. AND VERY
IMPORTANTLY, IT'LL HELP
CALIFORNIA DAIRIES TO ACCESS
FEDERAL INCENTIVE DOLLARS THAT
MAY BE AVAILABLE FOR THOSE
FUNDS. YEAH. WELL THAT'S USEFUL
TO UNDERSTAND THE ONGOING WORK,
BUT YOU KNOW, OVERALL, THERE IS
STILL THERE'S REALLY THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CALIFORNIA TO
LEAD HERE, AND I THINK WE WILL
HAVE TWO ADDITIONAL FUNDING AS
WELL. BUT I APPRECIATE YOU
TALKING ABOUT THE SCIENTIFIC
BASIS AND THE WORK THAT IS, UM,
IS ONGOING. THERE. UM LET'S SEE.
I'LL JUST HAVE PROBABLY ONE MORE
SET OF QUESTIONS. AND YOU MAY BE
INFLUENCED THIS AS WELL. THIS
CASINO THIS AROUND THE URBAN
GREENING PROGRAM OR.
WELCOME. THANK YOU. THIS PROGRAM
GOT BROUGHT UP EARLIER AND THE
BUDGET PROCESS SHIP 24 MILLION.
FROM THE CENTER STAND FROM
GENERAL FUND AT G R F. AND, UM.
DUE TO THE FUND SHIFT
ADMINISTRATION IS POSITIVE
VALUATION OF GRANT REQUEST FOR
THIS PROGRAM AS I UNDERSTAND IT,
SO CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT THE
URBAN GREENING PROGRAM AND WHAT
ARE SOME EXAMPLES OF THE
PROJECTS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
FUNDED? AND RIGHT NOW. SORRY
BRIAN CASH WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY. THE URBAN
GREEN PROGRAM PROJECTS THEY
REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS AND PROVIDE
MULTIPLE BENEFITS BY CREATING
MORE SUSTAINABLE, HEALTHY AND
VIBRANT COMMUNITIES. PROJECTS
ESTABLISH AND ENHANCE PARKS. AN
OPEN SPACE USING NATURAL
SOLUTIONS AND TO INCREASE TREE
CANOPIES, IMPROVE AIR AND WATER
QUALITY. REDUCE ENERGY COMES
CONSUMPTION. AND CONSTRUCT
NONMOTORIZED TRAILS. SOME
EXAMPLES OF SOME OF THESE
PROJECTS ARE CREATING A NEW
COMMUNITY CENTER, A NEW
COMMUNITY PARK WITH TREES AND
OTHER LANDSCAPING, A WALKING
PATH LIGHTING BENCHES,
TRANSFORMING A VACANT LOT INTO A
1.285 ACRE PUBLIC PARK WITH
DROUGHT TOLERANT LANDSCAPING,
BIO RETENTION BASIN. PLANTING
TREES IN THE TENDERLOIN AND
SOUTH OF MARKET COMMUNITIES IN
SAN FRANCISCO. UM GREENING
SCHOOL CAMPUSES, AND THAT'S ONE
OF THE ONES THAT WE ARE MOST
PROUD OF IS ACTUALLY GETTING
MORE GREEN SPACE IN THE IN THE
TREE IN THE SCHOOLS, ESPECIALLY
IN THE LOS ANGELES AREA, AND
THEN ACQUISITION OF VACANT LAND
FOR FUTURE DEVELOPMENT OF PUBLIC
PARKS. WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE
THE DEMAND. FOR GRANTS I
MENTIONED. I THINK THAT WE'VE
POSITIVELY ELATION NOW, WITH THE
UM WITH WITH THESE SHIPS WERE
WHAT DO YOU WHAT WOULD YOU
ESTIMATE IN THE DEMAND FOR
GRANTS FOR THIS CURRENT ROUND?
WE RECEIVED 89 APPLICATIONS
REQUESTING $132 MILLION AND WE
HAVE 23.72 AWARD. AFTER THE
SHIP'S 23 MILLION, OKAY? IT'S
ABOUT 1/5 OR SO UM, YEAH, IT'S A
VERY, VERY POPULAR PROGRAM. YEAH
AND THEY'RE THESE ARE REALLY WIN
. IT'S SORT OF LIKE THE SCENE
AND THESE ARE REAL WIN WIN.
PROGRAMS. AND HAVE THAT HAVE
MULTIPLE BENEFITS. UM. SO I
THINK WE'LL COME BACK TO DISCUSS
THIS AS WELL. THANK YOU, MR
CASH. I'D LIKE TO TURN IT,
CENTER ALLEN. DO YOU WANT TO YOU
HAVE SOME FROM MOLINA CAR
RECYCLE. RECYCLE YEAH. OKAY UM,
RECYCLE, FOLKS. SURE. HEY,
EVERYBODY. SORRY THIS JUST I
MEAN, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT TO
SOME EXTENT BEEN HAPPENING FOR A
LITTLE WHILE, BUT, UM YOU KNOW,
I JUST TALKING ABOUT THE BOTTLE
BILL LOAN FUND. SORRY THE BOTTOM
BUILT FUND THAT'S BECOME ALONE
OF SORTS. TO THE GENERAL FUND.
SO YOU KNOW THE CURRENT PROPOSAL
I THINK IN THE BUDGET IS LIKE
125 MILLION LOAN ALONG WITH THE
ONE YEAR REPAYMENT DIFFER ALL
FROM THE. THE BOTTLE BILL FUND
TO THE GENERAL FUND, AND I KNOW
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF THIS GOING
ON ACROSS THE BOARD WITHIN THE
BUDGET. UM BUT I GUESS I WANTED
TO ASK. YOU KNOW WHETHER WHETHER
AND MAYBE WE CAN ASK D O F OR
POWER CYCLE BUT THE EXTENT TO
WHICH CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED
THAT 100 $25 MILLION LOAN IN
ADDITION TO THE DEFERRAL OF THE
EXISTING $25 MILLION LOAN FROM
FROM LAST YEAR. COULD YOU KNOW
COULD POSSIBLY TRIGGER
PROPORTIONAL REDUCTIONS AND
INTERFERE WITH OUR CYCLES. PLAN
SCHEDULE FOR USING THE MONEY
THAT FUNDED IMPROVE RECYCLING
PROGRAMS. AND, YOU KNOW, OF
COURSE, THIS WAS MONEY THAT WAS
COLLECTED FROM CONSUMERS FOR THE
PURPOSES OF IMPROVING OUR
RECYCLING RATES AND SO I WANTED
TO, UM, TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THAT QUESTION. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ALLEN FOR THE QUESTION
THAT CHRISTIAN BELL TRAIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AGAIN,
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO KIND OF JUST CLARIFY SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE THAT'S INCLUDED IN
THE BUDGET ACT AND WHAT WAS ALSO
INCLUDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
ACT PERTAINING TO THE LOANS THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO, UM THESE
LOANS ARE WERE NEVER AND CAN
NEVER, UH, INTEND TO MAKE
PROGRAMMATIC IMPACTS TO THE
POINT OF PROPORTIONAL
REDUCTIONS. SO IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT IN THE LANGUAGE ITSELF
, THE ADMINISTRATION IS REQUIRED
TO MAKE PAYMENTS BACK FROM THE
GENERAL FUND BACK TO B C R F IN
THE CASE THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT PROGRAM IMPACTS THAT
ARE PROJECTED AS A RESULT OF THE
LOAN SO OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS
, FINANCE AND THE POWER CYCLE
TEAM HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY ON RECONCILING THE FUND
AND THEIR OVERALL REVENUES AND
PROJECTIONS THAT WE ASSUME IN
OUR FUND CONDITION. STATEMENT OF
THE FUND. AND THROUGH THAT KIND
OF RECONCILIATION PROCESS.
THERE'S BEEN SOME PRELIMINARY
DATA. THAT KIND OF SUGGESTS THAT
MAYBE THE CURRENT YEAR LOAN IS
NOT NECESSARILY STILL VIABLE AT
THIS POINT IN TIME, AND SO,
SINCE THAT HAS OCCURRED, WE HAVE
ACTUALLY PAID BACK THE CURRENT
YEAR $100 MILLION LOAN AND IN
THE BUDGET YEAR, SPECIFICALLY,
THEIR PRELIMINARY DATA SUGGESTS
THAT IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THAT
LOAN IS ALSO NOT VIABLE. BUT WE
ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY AND
STILL RECONCILING THE FUND
CONDITIONS STATEMENT TO SEE IF
IT IS STILL VIABLE BUT JUST
WANTED AGAIN. PINPOINT THAT
THESE LOANS COULD NEVER LEAD TO
THE PROPORTIONAL REDUCTIONS OR
LEAD TO AN INSOLVENCY OF THE B C
R FUND, AND IT'S CRITICAL TO
KIND OF NOTE THAT PART AND DO
YOU DO YOU DON'T DO YOU SEE ANY
SENATE MEANS THERE. FUTURE
SCENARIO WHERE THE GENERAL FUND
CAN'T PAY IT BACK. I MEAN, IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT NOT NOT THAT
WE'RE AWARE OF. WE'RE PRETTY
CONFIDENT IN TERMS OF REPAYMENT.
I MEAN, WE WERE JUST ABLE TO
REPAY THE CURRENT YEAR LOAN BACK
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO WITHOUT ANY
REAL MAJOR CONCERNS IN TERMS OF
THE CASH BALANCE OF THE GENERAL
FUND, VERSUS WHAT'S IN THE CRF.
SO IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET YEAR
LOAN AGAIN, THIS IS A PROPOSAL
AT THIS TIME AT THE MAYOR
VISION, THE ADMINISTRATION WILL
COME BACK AND JUST GET TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ON THE SAME
PAGE IN TERMS OF WHERE THE FUND
CONDITION IS AT THAT POINT AND
BE ABLE TO SEE IF THAT LOAN IS
STILL VIABLE AT THAT POINT.
WAIT. YEAH, I THINK WE NEED TO
BE REALLY, UM IF WE'RE GOING TO
DO THIS, WE HAVE TO BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT ABOUT THE INTEGRITY.
ABSOLUTELY THIS FIND AND. YOU
KNOW IT WAS IT WAS ESTABLISHED
FOR A PARTICULAR REASON. IT'S
NOT MONEY THAT I MEAN, THIS WAS
MONEY THAT WAS EXPLICITLY YOU
KNOW I COLLECTED FROM CONSUMERS,
YOU KNOW, FOR THE PURPOSE OF
IMPROVING OUR RECYCLING RATES
AND SO I GUESS. LET ME LET ME
I'D LOVE TO TURN IT OVER TO
CALVIN CYCLE. UM, YOU KNOW, I
MEAN, YOU KNOW, FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE. HOW DO WE MAKE SURE
THIS DOESN'T UM, INTERFERE WITH
ALL THE PLAN RECYCLING PROGRAMS?
THERE'S A LOT OF AMBITIOUS
THINGS THAT AFFECTED OUR CYCLE,
YOU KNOW, AND I MEAN, THERE'S
GOT TO BE AT SOME POINT WHERE
FURTHER BORROWING FROM THE FUND
OR DELAYED REPAYMENT IS GOING TO
INTERFERE WITH YOUR SCHEDULE FOR
USE OF THE FUNDS AND YOU KNOW
WHAT'S THAT LOOK LIKE TO YOU?
YOU KNOW, HOW CAN WE ALL BE IN
TOUCH ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THIS
SEVEN AND EQ BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
WE CARE A LOT ABOUT THE WORK
THAT'S UNDERWAY THERE. WELL
FIRST AND FOREMOST, I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
AS A WHOLE IS COMMITTED TO
IMPLEMENTING THE REFORMS THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS TO
IMPROVE OUR RECYCLING SYSTEMS,
UM, INCLUDING THE APPROPRIATIONS
THAT WERE MADE LAST YEAR FOR
GLASS RECYCLING THE
APPROPRIATIONS THAT WERE MADE TO
IMPLEMENT SENATOR ATKINS DEALER
CO OPERATIVES AND THE INFLUX OF
NEW MATERIALS COMING INTO THE
SYSTEM THROUGH WINE AND
DISTILLED SPIRITS. UM AND SO WE
ARE WORKING RIGHT NOW, AND WE
WON'T UNLESS YOU REALLY WANT US
TO GO INTO GREAT DETAIL ABOUT
THIS. THE SCHEDULE ON, UM,
GETTING OUT THOSE APPROPRIATIONS
FOR THE VARIOUS PROGRAMS, BUT WE
ARE WORKING ON GETTING THOSE
DOLLARS OUT THE DOOR. RIGHT NOW,
AND SO WANT TO ASSURE THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THE DEPARTMENT
IS FULLY IMPLEMENTING THOSE
REFORMS AND ENSURING THAT WE ARE
UTILIZING THE FUNDS AS INTENDED
IN THIS PROGRAM, UM, TO ACHIEVE
BETTER AND MORE ACCESSIBLE AND
MORE CONVENIENT RECYCLING
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. I WILL
SAY THAT. UH UM NOT UNLIKE, UM,
2008 WHEN THE FUN WAS UNDER
STRESS BEFORE ARE SEEING
HIGHER LEVELS OF REDEMPTION OVER
THE TWO YEARS THAT ARE
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
COMING OUT OF THE FUND. UM ON
ABOUT AVERAGE. I 1% INCREASE IN
REDEMPTION IS THE EQUIVALENT. UH
IN A MONTH IS THE EQUIVALENT TO
$13 MILLION. SO AS WE START TO
SEE THOSE NUMBERS INCH UP, THE
MONEY COMING OUT OF THE FUND
WILL BE GOING OUT AS IT WAS
INTENDED TO IN THIS PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY OBVIOUSLY, UM, THE
APPROPRIATIONS THAT WE MADE TO
REFORM THE SYSTEM. AS THOSE
DOLLARS ARE GOING OUT THE DOOR.
THOSE DOLLARS WILL BE COMING OUT
OF THE ACCOUNT. UM AND, UH AND
SO WE DO FEEL THAT THE FUND IS,
UM BEING DEPLETED AT A FASTER
RATE THAN IT PREVIOUSLY WAS IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS, AND I
THINK IT IS WORTH A CONVERSATION
AND ONGOING DISCUSSION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATE USE OF THAT MONEY.
UM OKAY, I'D LOVE TO. OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS AN AREA MEANS A LOT TO
ME AND I WOULD LOVE TO BE PART
OF THE CONVERSATION. UM CAN I
ALSO JUST ASK YOU, RACHEL? UM UH
, THE GRANTS FOR AUTOMATION
UNDER THE FUND. UH YOU KNOW, I
THINK I SAW SOMETHING ABOUT, UM,
BASICALLY GRANTS FOR REVERSE
VENDING MACHINES BACKDROP. ALL
THAT SORT OF WORK. I SAW
SOMETHING ABOUT HOW ONLY
EXCITING 40 MILLION WAS PUT OUT
OF 100 40 MILLION AVAILABLE LOVE
TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE
TIMELINE. ABSOLUTELY. SO ONE OF
THE TRICKS HERE WAS THAT, UM,
THE. I THINK ROUGHLY 100 AND 40
MILLION THAT IS MEANT TO GO TO
AUTOMATION. UM WAS ALSO INTENDED
TO HELP FIND SOME OF THE REFORMS
AND UTILIZE THAT INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGY FOR THE REFORMS. FOR
INSTANCE, THE DEALER COOPERATIVE
LANGUAGE, SO WE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING ON THOSE REGULATIONS.
HOPING TO HAVE THEM OUT. BUT
WORKING ON THOSE REGULATIONS FOR
HOW THE DEALER CO OPERATIVES
WILL, UM, WILL BE IMPLEMENTED
AND PART OF THE FUNDS WERE
INTENDED TO GO TO THE DEALERS TO
HELP THEM UTILIZE THAT, UM, THAT
TECHNOLOGY AND IMPLEMENTING THE
DEALER COOPERATIVE, SO WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE DEALERS
KNOW WHAT THE RULES OF THE GAME
ARE AND CAN BUILD OUT A PLAN
MUCH LIKE AN EPI. OUR PLAN. UM
FOR HOW THEY WILL UTILIZE THAT
TECHNOLOGY BEFORE THEY HAD TO
COME AND APPLY FOR THE FOR THE
MONEY, SO WE WERE VERY
INTENTIONALLY. UM, HOLDING A
PORTION OF THAT TO THE SUMMER
WITH DID A WORKSHOP IN FEBRUARY,
UM, TO ENGAGE WITH THE RETAILERS
AND DEALERS AND ASKED THEM, YOU
KNOW, HOW DO YOU ENVISION THIS
WORKING? AND THEN WE PLAN ON
OPENING THAT GRANT CYCLE THIS
SUMMER, OKAY? THANK YOU. SO IT
WAS THE REFORMS AND THE MONEY
CAME AT THE SAME TIME, BUT WE
HAD TO BUILD THE PLAN FOR THE
REFORMS SO THAT THE MONEY COULD
BE UTILIZED IN THE MOST
EFFICACIOUS WAY. THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS,
OTHERWISE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU. WE
SHOULD THANK RACHEL FOR HER
SERVICE. ABSOLUTELY YES. BEST
WHEN THEY'RE NEW ENDEAVORS. YEAH
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY. YEAH. YES
THANK YOU. GOOD GOING AWAY FROM?
YEAH YOU KNOW THAT WE'RE FOCUSED
AND INTERESTED IN THE PROGRAM
GOING FORWARD, SO THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF YOUR SERVICE. THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY, UM, EXCELLENT. WE
WILL NOW TURN TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
I SEE FOLKS ALREADY LINING UP.
WE WILL ASK PEOPLE TO UM KEEP
YOUR COMMENTS TO 1 TO 2 MINUTES
SINCE WE DO HAVE A LOT OF, UM, A
LOT OF FOLKS AGAIN. THANK YOU TO
ADMINISTRATION. AND TO L A. L
FOR ALL OF THEIR, UH, TESTIMONY
TO DATE, GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR. BECKER SENATOR ALLEN AND
STAFF RICO MASTER DONATO WITH
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND. I
HAVE A LOT OF SYMPATHY FOR THE
CUTS AND DECISIONS YOU HAVE TO
MAKE THIS YEAR AND BEYOND. BUT
WHAT I WANT TO IMPLORE IS THAT
IN OUR VIEW, WE ARE WAY BEHIND
ON ADAPTING TO THINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING TO US RIGHT NOW,
WHETHER YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
COASTLINE AS WE HEARD TODAY,
COST OF CONSERVANCY HAS NO MONEY
TO DO NEW PROJECTS. URBAN
GREENING HAS NO MONEY. THE GREEN
SCHOOLYARD HAS NO MONEY. THESE
ARE EXTREME HEAT INTERVENTION
PROGRAMS. AND YOU JUST HEARD
FROM RACHEL EARLIER THAT THERE
IS NO BIGGER DANGER TO CLIMATE
CHANGE IN CONTEMPORANEOUS
CALIFORNIA, THEN EXTREME HEAT,
SO WE NEED TO LOOK AT THESE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS. THESE
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS AS
ESSENTIAL SERVICES, NOT
SOMETHING ELSE AND SHOULD BE
AMONG THE LAST THINGS THAT WE
CUT. AND A YEAR WHERE WE HAVE TO
MAKE DIFFICULT DECISIONS, SO
THANK YOU VERY, VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. SARAH
BECKER MEMBER ALAN PAUL MASON
WITH PACIFIC FOREST TRUST, AND I
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT FOR A
MINUTE SOME OF THE REDUCTIONS IN
THE WATER AND DROUGHT PACKAGE IN
PARTICULAR. A LITTLE BIT
STRIKING THAT WE TALK ABOUT
THESE EIGHT AND $9 BILLION
PACKAGE IS AN AWFUL LOT OF THAT
OUR INVESTMENTS AND THINGS THAT
I ALMOST FEEL LIKE BASELINE
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE AND
WATER TREATMENT PLANTS AND WATER
SERVICES AND THINGS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT. I DON'T WANT TO
MINISTER. THEY'RE IMPORTANT, BUT
THEY DON'T REALLY STRIKE ME AS
THE CLIMATE INVESTMENTS THAT WE
NEED TO BE MAKING TO PREPARE FOR
THE WORLD THAT IS COMING AT US
REALLY QUICKLY. SO WHEN I LOOK
AT THE REDUCTIONS AND SEE THAT
THEY'RE OVERWHELMINGLY LIKE $440
MILLION IN CUTS TO WATERSHED
RESILIENCE PROGRAMS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE THE THINGS THAT WE
NEED TO BE DOING TO PREPARE FOR
THE EXTREME STORMS THAT ARE
COMING IN, LITERALLY OUTSIDE, OR
THAT HAMMERED SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EARLIER THIS YEAR,
AND THAT'S MONEY THAT WOULD GO
BOTH THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
THE SIERRA CASCADE REGION. THOSE
ARE THE THINGS WE NEED TO BE
INVESTING IN NOW, SO THAT 30
YEARS FROM NOW WE ACTUALLY HAVE
WATERSHEDS THAT ARE GOING TO
BUFFER THESE EXTREME STORMS AND
PROTECT OUR WATER SUPPLIES. SO
I'M NOT SO OPTIMISTIC TO THINK
THAT WE'RE GOING TO RESTORE ALL
OF THESE CUTS IN THIS
CONVERSATION, BUT AS WE ARE
LOOKING AT CLIMATE, BOND AND
OTHER WAYS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ACTUALLY ARE DOING THESE THINGS,
LET'S MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE YOU
KNOW, RESTORING THE CUTS THAT
WE'RE SEEING HERE AND REALLY
INVESTING IN THE THINGS THAT
WILL PREPARE US FOR THE CLIMATE
THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
REGARDLESS OF ANY OF THE OTHER
REDUCTIONS IN PHDS THAT WE MAKE.
THANKS THANK YOU. I HAD A WHOLE
PAGE OF QUESTIONS ON THE
WATERSHED CLIMATE RESILIENCE, SO
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT UP.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MICROBES IN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE GLASS PACKAGING IS TO JUST
REALLY ON THE LAST ITEM THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP ON THE ON THE LOANS
FROM, UH FROM THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING FUND TO THE
GENERAL FUND AND I REALLY JUST
APPRECIATE THE COMMUNITY GETTING
THIS ON THE AGENDA AND BRING
SOME LIGHT ON IT AND FOR SITTING
AROUND BRINGING IT UP IN
COMMITTEE. I TRULY APPRECIATE
IT. I THINK IF I UNDERSTOOD THE
TESTIMONY FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE CORRECTLY, SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS MIGHT BE ALLEVIATED. I
NEED TO GO BACK AND WATCH AND
SEE IF I UNDERSTOOD IT ALL
CORRECTLY. BUT AGAIN, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING IT UP AND
BRINGING THIS AS PART OF THE
AGENDA. THANKS. THANK YOU. JERRY
BECKER, SENATOR ALLEN BILL
MCGOVERN, WITH THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR FOR MOST CALIFORNIANS
ARE AREAS SO DIRTY THAT IT'S
ILLEGAL UNDER THE CLEAN AIR ACT,
AND THAT'S ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR
RESIDENTS OF DISADVANTAGE OF LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. FOR THAT
REASON WE HAVE STANDARDS TO MAKE
A TRANSITION TO ZERO MISSION
TRANSPORTATION, AND THAT'S WHY
WE NEED TO PRESERVE THE ZEV
FUNDING, PARTICULARLY FOR EQUITY
PROJECTS LIKE YOU TALKED ABOUT
WITH QUEEN CARS FOR ALL AND
CLEANING UP THE HEAVY DUTY
FLEETS THAT ARE SPEWING DIESEL
EXHAUST INTO OUR COMMUNITIES,
AND LET'S BE CLEAR A THREE YEAR
DELAY IS TANTAMOUNT TO A CUT.
YOU'RE NOT SETTING ASIDE MONEY
FOR 2027. WE DON'T KNOW WHO WILL
BE THE GOVERNOR IN 2027. BUT I'M
NOT HERE JUST TO COMPLAIN. I
HAVE A SOLUTION. CALIFORNIA IS
RECEIVING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL TRANSPORTATION FUNDS
CONGRESS ALLOWS FOR UP TO 50% OF
THOSE FUNDS TO BE SHIFTED FROM
ONE PROGRAM TO ANOTHER. SO, FOR
EXAMPLE, WE COULD SHIFT FUNDS
FROM NATIONAL HIGHWAY
PERFORMANCE TO CONGESTION,
MITIGATION AND AIR QUALITY AND
SOLVE SOME OF THESE CLEAN AIR
PROBLEMS, SO I KNOW THAT A LOT
OF THAT IS IN A DIFFERENT
SUBCOMMITTEE. BUT I URGE YOU TO
WORK WITH THEM AND YOUR STAFF TO
TAKE A HARD LOOK AT HOW WE COULD
BE SHIFTING THESE FUNDS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
KENDRA HARRIS AT THE CLIMATE
CENTER. UM I KNOW IT'S A TOUGH
BUDGET YEAR. WE'RE LOOKING AT
CUTS ACROSS THE BOARD FOR A
NUMBER OF PROGRAMS, BUT I URGE
YOU TO CONSIDER BEFORE WE TAKE
THESE CUTS, EQUITABLE, CLEAN AIR
PROGRAMS, WE MUST SIGNIFICANTLY
EXPAND THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
CUTS TO OIL AND GAS SUBSIDIES BY
ELIMINATING FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY
SUBSIDIES AND CUTTING OUT OTHER
DEAD AND INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS. AND ALSO PEOPLE
LIVING WITH POLLUTED AIR, WHICH
HAS ONLY MADE WORSE FOR THE
CLIMATE CRISIS CONTINUE TO
SUFFER FROM SYSTEMATIC
MARGINALIZATION THAT MAKES THEM
SICK AND CAN LEAD TO EARLY DEATH
. IT'S ESTIMATED THAT 7500
DEATHS CAN BE ATTRIBUTED TO AIR
POLLUTION EACH YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA, THE STATE'S CLEAN
AIR SATAN IS MODERATE, ALREADY
CHRONICALLY UNDERFUNDED IN THIS
BUDGET THREATENS TO COMPLETE
ZERO PROMISED INVESTMENTS IN
PROGRAMS THAT ARE WORKING TO
SAVE LIVES AND IMPROVE QUALITY
OF LIFE IN THESE MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR.
BECKER AND SENATOR ALLEN. THANK
YOU SO MUCH TODAY FOR ALL THE
CONVERSATIONS AND FOR YOUR
COMMENTS RACHEL MUELLER HERE ON
BEHALF OF NEXT GEN. CALIFORNIA
WE STRONGLY URGE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE REJECTS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED $35 MILLION BUDGET CUT
TO THE CALIFORNIA NUTRITION
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS SEEN IT. AND
WE SEEK TO WHEN WE HOPE YOU WILL
SEEK TO MAINTAIN THIS PROGRAM AT
CURRENT LEVELS SEEN IT IS A
POWERFUL TOOL TO FIGHT FOOD
INSECURITY THAT PROVIDES
INCENTIVES TO CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE, LOW INCOME FAMILIES.
THESE FAMILIES RELY ON SCENE EPP
TO PURCHASE LOCAL FRESH AND
AFFORDABLE FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
, OFTENTIMES WHEN THEY WOULD
OTHERWISE BE UNABLE TO DO SO. WE
ALSO FULLY SUPPORT PROTECTING
THE FARM TO SCHOOL PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY IN TIGHT BUDGET
YEARS, IT'S MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER THAT CALIFORNIA'S
STRENGTHEN THE PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT RESILIENCE AND CONTINUE
TO DEMONSTRATE CREATIVE
LEADERSHIP ON CRITICAL ISSUES
SUCH AS CLIMATE. THEREFORE WE
ALSO URGE YOU TO FUND AND
DUMPLING IMPLEMENTATION OF SB
253 AND SB 261. THE TWO CLIMATE
ACCOUNT ACCOUNTABILITY PACKAGE
BILLS. TO BRING THE RESOURCES OF
THE PRIVATE SECTOR TO BEAR ON
CLIMATE EFFORTS AT NEAR
NEGLIGIBLE COST TO TAXPAYERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU. THANKS FOR BRINGING
UP THE BILLS THAT WE'VE PASSED
LAST YEAR. WE'RE HOPING THAT
THESE ALL GET FUN TO THANK YOU,
MR CHAIR MEMBERS, BRENDAN TO
WORK ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION, AS THE STATE
CONTENDS, WITH SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET DEFICIT THIS YEAR, WE
ASKED FOR YOUR CONTINUING
PRIORITIZATION OF FUNDING STATE
BUDGET PROGRAMS THAT COST
EFFECTIVELY REDUCE, UM CRITERIA,
AIR POLLUTANTS, SO PUBLIC HEALTH
BENEFITS AND ALSO GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTIONS. WE ALSO THINK THAT
THE G R F SHOULD BE RESERVED FOR
PROGRAMS THAT MEET THIS CRITERIA
RATHER THAN FOR BACKFILLING,
MORE EXPENSIVE PROGRAMS WITH
LESS BENEFITS IN THE IN THESE
AREAS TO AIR DISTRICT ADMINISTER
PROGRAMS, AS YOU KNOW, THE A B
617 COMMUNITY AIR PROTECTION
PROGRAM AND THE FARMER PROGRAM
COST EFFECTIVELY REDUCE BOTH G H
G S AND CRITERIA POLLUTANTS, AND
BOTH ARE PROVIDING SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS. FOR DISPROPORTIONATELY
EFFECTIVE AFFECTED COMMUNITIES.
SO JUST SINCE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT REDUCTIONS, THE AIR
PROTECTION PROGRAM IS PROPOSED
TO RE REDUCED FROM 300 TO 250
MILLION. WE ASKED FOR
RESTORATION BACK TO 300 MILLION,
AND THEN THE FARMER PROGRAM IS
ACTUALLY ZEROED OUT, AND THAT'S
ALREADY AFTER A $75 MILLION CUT
OF 50% CUT LAST YEAR, SO WE'RE
ASKING YOU GO BACK TO TWO YEARS
WHERE IT'S 150 MILLION AGAIN,
KEEPING IN MIND HOW COST
EFFECTIVE. THESE PROGRAMS ARE
AND WE HAVE SCARCE RESOURCES. SO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS
NICOLE HUTCHINSON ON BEHALF OF
CAL START FIRST. I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOU AND THE
GOVERNOR ARE FACING DIFFICULT
CHOICES. GIVEN THE BUDGET
DEFICIT, HOWEVER, ADDRESSING AIR
QUALITY AND CLIMATE CRISIS IS
ONE OF THE MOST MEANINGFUL WAYS
TO PRESERVE PUBLIC HEALTH IN THE
LONG TERM AND AVOID HARMING
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. WE APPRECIATE THAT
THE ELECTRIC SCHOOL BUS FUNDING
HAS BEEN PRESERVED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET IS
THIS FUNDING WILL REDUCE
EXPOSURE TO HARMFUL EMISSIONS
FOR SCHOOLCHILDREN. HOWEVER WE
ARE CONCERNED BY THE DELAYS IN
FUNDING FOR OTHERS OF CATEGORIES
, INCLUDING INVESTMENTS IN
INFRASTRUCTURE. MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY DESERVES AND CLEAN MOBILITY
OPTIONS. GIVEN THE
DISPROPORTIONATE NEGATIVE IMPACT
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES HAVE IN
TERMS OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND GIVEN
REGULATORY TIMING WITH A CF.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
PRIORITIZE INVESTMENTS IN MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTIES EBS THIS YEAR.
SIMILARLY ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS SUFFICIENT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO
SUPPORT BOTH THE LIGHT AND HEAVY
DUTIES OF MARKET IS ESSENTIAL TO
MEETING OUR CLIMATE AND AIR
QUALITY GOALS. AND FINALLY, THE
SCOPING PLAN HIGHLIGHTS THE
IMPORTANCE OF REDUCING BMT IN
ORDER FOR THE STATE TO MEET ITS
CLIMATE GOALS. HOWEVER THIS WILL
BE THE THIRD YEAR IN A ROW THAT
COMMUNITY BASED PROJECTS WHICH
PRODUCED THE MTR BEING DELAYED
OR SCALED BACK. THESE INNOVATIVE
PROJECTS IN POWER UNDER
RESOURCED COMMUNITIES TO
OVERCOME MOBILITY, OBSTACLES AND
TRANSFORM THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
THE WAY THEY TRAVEL. WE URGE YOU
TO RECONSIDER THESE DELAYS FOR
THESE IMPORTANT PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR. BECKER AND
SENATOR ELLEN THIS IS MAKING
CLEAN WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. DESPITE RECORD
BREAKING STATE BUDGETS,
CALIFORNIA'S INVESTMENTS IN
NATURE, NATURAL RESOURCES AND H
BASED CLIMATE SOLUTIONS HAS NOT
MATCHED THE PACE AND SCALE OF
THE NEED. THE GOVERNOR IS 2024
25 BUDGET PROPOSAL WOULD REDUCE
STATE SPENDING FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES TO LESS THAN 3% OF THE
STATE BUDGET AS A SENATE CRAFTS
ITS BUDGET PROPOSAL. WE URGE YOU
TO PROTECT THESE INVESTMENTS AND
RESTORE CRITICAL INVESTMENTS TO
NATURE BASED CLIMATE SOLUTIONS
AND BIODIVERSITY CONSERVATION.
WE PARTICULARLY ADVOCATE FOR THE
RESTORATION OF THE FUNDING TO
THE COASTAL PROTECTION PACKAGE,
WHICH IS SLATED TO BE CUT BY
NEARLY 50% SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCING FUNDING TO THE STATE
COASTAL CONSERVANCY AND THE
OCEAN PROTECTION COUNCIL TO
ADDRESS SEA LEVEL RISE, INCREASE
OCEAN PROTECTION AND OCEAN
RESILIENCE. FINALLY AS
CALIFORNIA FACES A SIZABLE
BUDGET DEFICIT FOR THE SECOND
YEAR IN A ROW, WE ARE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROVIDE STRONG
LEADERSHIP, WHICH SENATOR ALLEN
HAS BEEN DOING. TO ADVANCE A
ROBUST CLIMATE BOND THAT WILL
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED FUNDING FOR
NATURE BASED CLIMATE SOLUTIONS.
THE CRITICAL INVESTMENTS
PROVIDED BY A BOND WILL NOT ONLY
HELP TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S
ICONIC HABITATS AND RICH
BIODIVERSITY, BUT ALSO HELP
CALIFORNIANS ADAPT TO INCREASING
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. WE'RE STILL
WORKING ON THAT. THANK YOU.
EXCEPT. OH GOOD AFTERNOON. SURE.
BECCA SENATOR ALLEN. MY NAME IS
MICHELLE CANNOLIS WITH UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS. I WANTED
TO TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THE SUB
PACKAGE. MUCH OF THE STATE
CONTINUES TO BE OUT OF
ATTAINMENT WITH FEDERAL AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS, EXPOSING
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS TO
HARMFUL AIR POLLUTION. TAILPIPE
POLLUTION FROM TRANSPORTATION IS
A HUGE REASON WHY SO WE URGE
LEGISLATURE TO AVOID CUTS AND
DELAYS TO VITAL ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INCENTIVES AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. FURTHER WE ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO TARGET THE
FUNDING THAT IT DOES HAVE FOR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE INCENTIVES
TO REPLACE THE OLDEST CARS ON
THE ROAD, WHERE THE STATE CAN
GET THE LARGEST EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS PER DOLLAR SPENT.
REPORT WE RELEASED WITH THE
GREENLINING INSTITUTE LAST YEAR
SHOWED THAT PRE 2004 VEHICLES
MAKE UP 19% OF CARS ON THE ROAD,
BUT I'M AT 73% OF THE SMOG
FORMING NOX EMISSIONS. THESE
CARS AND POLLUTION ARE ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY CONCENTRATED
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND SHOULD BE REPLACED AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE. LASTLY THE STATE
NEEDS TO GET SERIOUS ABOUT LAND
TRANSITION IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
TO MOVE TOWARDS MORE SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE FOR THE COMMUNITIES THAT
LIVE THERE. A GOOD START WOULD
BE FUNDING PROGRAMS LIKE THE
MULTI BENEFIT LAND REPURPOSING
PROGRAM AND MAKING SURE THAT
THIS FUNDING AS MAXIMIZING
PUBLIC BENEFITS. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I GUESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON, KIM DELFINO AND
REPRESENTING DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE. CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PLANT SOCIETY, CINEMA, LAND
TRUST, MOJAVE DESERT LAND TRUSTS
AND SIERRA FOREST LEGACY. SARAH
FUNDS, SYRIA INSTITUTE, AUDUBON,
CALIFORNIA AND THE MORE THAN 100
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE POWER OF
NATURE COALITION. I WOULD ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MAKING CLEVELAND WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF INVESTING IN
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS AND
CLIMATE RESILIENCY. THANK YOU
ALREADY HEARD HOW IMPORTANT THIS
FUNDING IS. IT'S A RELATIVELY
SMALL AMOUNT OF MONEY IN THE
BUDGET, BUT IT HAS SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT AND IT HAS IMPACTS AT
LAST WELL BEYOND INTO FUTURE
YEARS. THESE ARE ALSO PROGRAMS
AT THE STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY
, WCBB DEPARTMENT OF
CONSERVATION DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE COUNT FIRE THAT ARE
ALREADY OVERSUBSCRIBED. EVEN
EVEN IF FUNDED THIS YEAR. WE'RE
GOING TO RUN OUT OF MONEY IN THE
NEXT YEAR OR TWO. SOME SOME
PROGRAMS AREN'T EVEN ACCEPTING
NEW APPLICATIONS AT THIS POINT.
SO WE WOULD URGE THAT YOU
PROTECT THIS RELATIVELY SMALL
AMOUNT OF MONEY IN THE BUDGET
AND ALSO LOOK AT CREATIVE
FUNDING SOLUTIONS SUCH AS YES,
ALREADY POINTED OUT BY SENATOR
ALLEN A BOND THE CLIMATE BOND
BECAUSE WE REALLY DON'T HAVE A
WAY OF PAYING FOR MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS PASSED NEXT YEAR, AND
YET WE HAVE GOALS SUCH AS 30 BY
30, WHICH WERE SUPPOSED TO BE
MEETING OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
YEARS, BUT NO MONEY TO ACTUALLY
ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS. FINALLY I
WOULD JUST SAY ON THE FIRE
PACKAGE, WHICH WE DIDN'T REALLY
HEAR MUCH ABOUT, UM, THERE IS A
PROPOSAL TO CUT ABOUT $5 MILLION
OUT OF THE SCIENCE AND
MONITORING FUNDING, WHICH WE
WOULD STRONGLY URGE REJECTING,
AS POINTED OUT, FIGURING OUT THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF TREATMENT IS
IMPORTANT. WE SHOULD NOT BE
CUTTING THAT FUNDING. AND
THERE'S ALSO BEEN SOME
SUGGESTIONS ABOUT PERHAPS
CUTTING BACK ON PRESCRIBED FIRE
AND TRIBAL ENGAGEMENT AND
CULTURAL BURNING. THOSE ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT PROGRAMS. THEY
HAVE A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT. WE'VE
MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS IN THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS IN THE STATE,
AND WE WOULD HATE TO SEE US, UH,
BACK AWAY FROM THAT PROGRESS. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. CHAIR BECKER AND
SENATOR ALLEN ALEX CLEAR ON
BEHALF THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND, CAL TROUT AND TROUT
UNLIMITED, ECHOING PREVIOUS
THREE COMMENTS BEFORE ME ABOUT
THE CUTS TO NATURAL RESOURCES,
WATERSHED HEALTH, THE MULTI
BENEFIT LAND REPURPOSING PROGRAM
AND REALLY APPRECIATE SENATOR
ALLEN FLAGGING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE CLIMATE BOND. GIVEN THE CUTS
WE HAVE IN FRONT OF US, IT'S ALL
THAT MUCH MORE IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE AN EQUITABLE AND ROBUST
CLIMATE BOND ON THE BALLOT THIS
NOVEMBER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THIS CHAIR, SENATOR ALLEN BART
BROOM WITH THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT, ALSO
CALLED VALLEY WATER. UM, I WANT
TO SPEAK FIRST ABOUT THE COASTAL
RESILIENCE PACKAGE, THE SOUTH
SAN FRANCISCO BAY SHORELINE
PROJECT WAS MENTIONED AS ONE OF
THE PROJECTS THAT WAS FUNDED BY
THE PROGRAM. UM, THAT PROJECT IS
JUST VERY PARTIALLY FUNDED
PHASE, ONE OF A THREE PHASE
PROJECT IS STRUGGLING TO MEET
FUNDING SHORTFALLS. NOW UM AND
JUST TO UNDERSCORE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE COASTAL
RESILIENCE PROGRAM. THESE ARE
OUR BASICALLY LIFE SAFETY
PROJECTS BECAUSE THEY'RE THERE
PROTECTING THE REGIONAL
WASTEWATER TREATMENT PLANT FOR
1.5 MILLION PEOPLE. THERE'S A
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY OF
ALVISO AND THEN THE PHASES TWO
AND THREE PROTECT PALO ALTO
MOUNTAIN VIEW HUGE AMOUNTS OF
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE, BOTH
JOB CREATING BUSINESSES. NASA
AMES LABORATORY MAJOR HIGHWAYS,
AND SO I JUST WANT TO UNDERSCORE
THE COASTAL RESILIENCE. FUNDING
IS IT'S LIFE SAFETY. IT'S NOT
JUST, YOU KNOW, PROTECTING
COASTAL HOMES. THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S MUCH MORE IMPORTANT THAN
THAT. AND THEN REGARDING THE DAM
SAFETY PROGRAM. THE ANALYSIS
SUGGESTED THAT PERHAPS THE DAM
SAFETY PROGRAM COULD BE, UH,
ELIMINATED BY REMOVING THE LAST
$50 MILLION. THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSED TO TAKE 50 MILLION. IT
SUGGESTED YOU COULD TAKE ANOTHER
50 MILLION. I JUST WANT TO
UNDERSCORE THAT, YOU KNOW
PROJECTS LIKE THE ANDERSON
SEISMIC RETROFIT PROJECT ARE
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO LIFE
SAFETY TO THE WATER SUPPLY FOR
THE ENTIRE REGION AND THE
STATE'S CONTRIBUTION TO THE
ANDERSON PROJECT, WHICH IS $2.3
BILLION SO FAR IS NEGLIGIBLE. UM
IT'S OF NATIONAL IMPORTANCE. IT
IS, ACCORDING TO FEDERAL
REGULATORS, THE HIGHEST DAM
SAFETY PRIORITY IN THE NATION.
UM, AND THE ONLY PROGRAM THAT
THE STATE HAS THAT CAN ACTUALLY
SUBSTANTIALLY CONTRIBUTE TO THAT
PROJECT IS THE DAM SAFETY
PROGRAM, SO I URGE YOU TO EITHER
REJECT OR OR REDUCE THOSE CODES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU PROTECT
THAT DAM SAFETY PROGRAM. YOU
KNOW? NO, THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE IT. APPRECIATE IT.
THAT'S TRUE. HI MY NAME IS
ANGELA GEORGIANS. I'M AN
UNDERGRAD STUDENT AT UC DAVIS AS
WELL AS AN INTERN WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA, THE
STATEWIDE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
THAT WORKS FOR CLEAN AIR AND A
HEALTHY FUTURE FOR ALL. WE'RE
ASKING THAT YOU PLEASE RESTORE
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR SAFETY
NET PROPOSED FUNDING DELAY IN
REALITY IS A $600 MILLION CUT
FROM OUR CLEAN AIR PROGRAMS,
INCLUDING THOSE PROMOTING CLEAN
CARS, TRUCKS AND BUSSES.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE WORST AIR
POLLUTION IN THE COUNTRY AND
TAILPIPE POLLUTION IS A TOP
CONTRIBUTOR TO THIS PRESSING
ISSUE. WE SUPPORT ENDING OIL AND
GAS SUBSIDIES IN TOUGH BUDGET
TIMES. THE LAST THING WE SHOULD
BE DOING IS SUBSIDIZING OIL
COMPANIES WHEN THEY ARE MAKING
RECORD PROFITS AND POLLUTING OUR
ENVIRONMENT. AND FINALLY, AS A
YOUNG PERSON BORN AND RAISED IN
CALIFORNIA, I URGE YOU TO FIND
MORE WAYS TO PROTECT OUR HEALTH,
THE ENVIRONMENT AND THE FUTURE.
CLEAN ENERGY AND CLIMATE
PROGRAMS ARE INVESTMENTS WE MAKE
FOR OUR KIDS AND GET GRANDKIDS.
IF YOU CUT NOW, YOUNG PEOPLE
LIKE MYSELF, AS WELL AS
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE GENERATIONS
PAY MORE LATER, NOT JUST IN
TERMS OF MONEY, BUT ALSO IN COST
TO OUR HEALTH AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS MARIELA
RETRO FROM THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION. WE URGED THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN AIR
SAFETY. NET COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE HAVE SUFFERED FOR
GENERATIONS FROM TAILPIPE
POLLUTION. I WANT TO ECHO
COMMENTS MADE BY COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR ON THE NEED TO MEET
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR STANDARDS. AND
INVEST IN, UH, EQUITABLE'S OR
OMISSION PROGRAMS ARE OUR STATE
OF THE AIRPORT. OUR STATE OF THE
AIR REPORT FOUND THAT 98% OF
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN AN AREA
WITH UNHEALTHY AIR AND POOR AIR
QUALITY AFFECTS THE HEALTH OF
EVERYONE, ESPECIALLY ESPECIALLY
CHILDREN, SENIORS AND THOSE WITH
PREEXISTING CONDITIONS. THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR CLEAN AIR
AND EQUITABLE PROGRAMS ARE ZERO
DOUBT. BEFORE CUTTING FUNDING.
UH FOR THESE PROGRAMS, WE NEED
TO LOOK AT ELIMINATING FOSSIL
FUEL INDUSTRY SUBSIDIES AND CUT
OUT OTHER HIGHWAY EXPANSION
INVESTMENTS THAT INCREASE ERROR
IN CLIMATE POLLUTION. SO AGAIN,
WE URGE TO CONTINUE TO FULLY
FUND CLEANER PROGRAMS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MR CHAIR,
SENATOR ALLEN BETH OLA. SO ON
BEHALF OF WATER REUSE CALIFORNIA
WE KNOW YOU'RE BOTH VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF WATER RECYCLING.
WANT TO ADDRESS THE CUTS IN THIS
BUDGET TO WATER RECYCLING
FUNDING THE MULTIYEAR CUTS TO
THIS PROGRAM TOTAL OVER 60% OF
WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY ALLOCATED.
THE THIS YEAR'S CUTS ARE
REQUIRING THE STATE BOARD TOO.
TAKE FUNDS AWAY FROM PROJECTS
THAT WERE ALREADY COMMITTED,
INCLUDING ONE IN YOUR DISTRICT,
SENATOR BECKER THERE'S A
RESOLUTION AT THE STATE BOARD AT
THE END OF THE MONTH TO GIVE THE
DIRECT DEPUTY DIRECTOR THE
AUTHORITY TO TAKE AWAY OR
ELIMINATE THE FUNDING BECAUSE
THEY'RE JUST THEY JUST DON'T
HAVE THE PROMISED FUNDS ANYMORE,
SO REALLY PROBLEMATIC FOR
PROJECTS THAT HAVE MOVED DOWN
THE ROAD. UM AND NOW THEY'RE
FUNDING IS GETTING TAKEN AWAY.
SO UM I REALLY HOPE WE CAN
RESTORE. UM WE'RE NOT EVEN
ASKING TO RESTORE ALL OF IT JUST
TO COVER THOSE PROJECTS THAT
WERE WERE IN THE FUNDING PLAN
THAT HAD MONEY COMMITTED, SO WE
NEED ABOUT $115 MILLION TO COVER
THOSE PROJECTS BECAUSE WE DO
UNDERSTAND IT'S A TOUGH BUDGET
YEAR. WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR MORE
JUST TO COVER THOSE PROJECTS
THAT WERE ONCE ALLOCATED
FUNDING. SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
SENATOR ALLEN. MY NAME IS TASHA
NEWMAN AND I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL
OF LAND TRUSTS, REPRESENTING
MORE THAN 70 LAND TRUSTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
REPRESENTING 76 RESOURCE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WE
DEFINITELY WANT TO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. AND OTHER GROUPS
WHO HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN OVER
CUTS TO NATURAL RESOURCE CLIMATE
RESILIENCE, DOLLARS, AND IN
PARTICULAR, WE WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR GREAT CONCERN FOR
THE PROPOSED CUTS TO THE COASTAL
, UH, RESILIENCE FUNDING THROUGH
THE COASTAL CONSERVANCY, AND,
UM, WE WOULD JUST LIKE TO, UM
FINALLY MENTIONED THAT WE, UH
SUPPORT A FUTURE NATURAL
RESOURCES BOND. HOPEFULLY ONE
FOR THIS NOVEMBER, UM AS WE
SPEAK, LAND TRUSTS AND RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND
OTHERS ARE WORKING TO IMPLEMENT
THE GOALS OF 30 BY 30, THE
CLIMATE, SMART LAND MANAGEMENT
STRATEGIES AND THEY HAVE RAMPED
UP BASED ON YOU KNOW THE FUNDING
THAT WAS AVAILABLE THAT WE WERE
HOPING WOULD CONTINUE TO BE
AVAILABLE AND SO WITH POSSIBLE
BUDGET CUTS, WE THINK THAT A
BOND IS DEFINITELY NECESSARY AND
WE WOULD SUPPORT THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MR CHAIR, SENATOR ALLEN. MY NAME
IS EDSON PEREZ AND I'M THE I'M
WITH ADVANCED ENERGY UNITED WERE
REPRESENT ADVANCED ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGIES THAT
HAVE ALREADY CREATED OVER
500,000 JOBS IN CALIFORNIA, AND
WE WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
OF PROGRAMS THAT WILL HELP US
MAINTAIN OUR GRID, PREVENT
BLACKOUTS AND PREVENT THE WORST
HEALTH EFFECTS OF EXTREME HEAT
EVENTS LIKE THE L. A. YOU
MENTIONED THEY'RE JUST GONNA
KEEP GETTING WORSE. SO THE FIRST
ONE IS THAT DISTRIBUTED
ELECTRICITY BACK UP ASSETS OR
DEEP A PROGRAM. I WANT TO UPLIFT
IT BECAUSE IT'S BEEN FLAGGED AS
A POTENTIAL TARGET FOR FUNDING
CLAWBACKS FROM ITS FUNDING FROM
PRIOR YEARS. THIS PROGRAM IS
GOING TO BE A CRITICAL WAY FOR
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY ASSETS LIKE
ENERGY STORAGE. THE MAN
INFLEXIBILITY, SOFTWARES
MULTIPLY, INCE'S MICROGRIDS AND
OTHERS. TO SHOW THEIR TRUE
POTENTIAL IN MAKING THE GREAT
MORE RESILIENT. RIGHT NOW. THE
ENERGY COMMISSION IS VETTING
APPLICATIONS, AND IT'S GOING TO
DECIDE ITS FIRST ROUND OF
GRANTEES. SOON SO THAT THEY
THESE THIS PROGRAM CAN HELP US
WHETHER THIS UPCOMING SUMMER
MONTHS SO WE SHOULD NOT CUT OFF
HIS LEGS AS IT'S JUST TAKEN OFF
IF WE WANT TO CONTINUE LEADING
AND DEVELOPING INNOVATIVE
TECHNOLOGIES OR THE SAME TIME
MAKING THE GREAT MORE RELIABLE.
AND SECOND IS THE DEMAND SIDE
GREAT SUPPORT PROGRAM. THIS WAS
ALSO FLAGGED BY THE EARLIER AS
AN OPTION FOR FUNDING CLAWBACKS.
BUT THIS PROGRAM HAS ALREADY
PROVED ITSELF OVER THE SUMMERS
OF 2022 AND 2023. HELPING US
WHETHER THE HOTTEST DAYS SO, UM
JUST THIS BOTH PROGRAMS FOR THEM
. PROVIDERS NEED PREDICTABILITY
ABOUT FUNDING LEVELS AND PROGRAM
LENGTH. FOR IT TO BE
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE FOR THEM
TO PARTICIPATE. SO WITHOUT THAT,
WE WERE KIND OF SETTING UP THESE
PROGRAMS TO FAIL, SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT.
I FINALLY JUST ALSO WANT TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS FROM THOSE WHO HAVE
MENTIONED THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
SYRIAN MISSION VEHICLE PACKAGE
FUNDING. CALIFORNIA IS RIGHT NOW
AT A PIVOTAL MOMENT IN
DETERMINING WHETHER WE'LL MEET
OUR TRANSPORTATION
ELECTRIFICATION GOALS. WE HEAR
FROM FLEET FLEET OWNERS THAT
THEY WANT TO COMPLY WITH NEW
REGULATIONS, BUT THEY HAVE A
HARD TIME PLANNING OUT THEIR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE PURCHASES
AND HOW THEY'RE GOING TO CHARGE
EVERYTHING SO TO HIGHLIGHT THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS PACKAGE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND SENATOR WILL
BRING HER WITH CLIMATE ACTION.
CALIFORNIA WE SUBMITTED A LETTER
ALONG WITH 70, PLUS GROUPS
AROUND THE STATE AND THE NATION.
ASKING FOR FUNDING FOR SP 253
AND SP 261 FROM LAST YEAR. I
KNOW IT'S TOUGH YEAR, THE
MINISTRATIONS DECIDED TO PROPOSE
NOTHING FOR THAT IMPLEMENTATION.
UM BUT HERE'S THE GOOD NEWS. ONE
IS IT'S A BARGAIN. THE MOST OF
THE WORK IS ON THE REPORTING
ENTITIES, UM, TO REPORT THEIR
EMISSIONS. SECONDLY, THERE IS A
FEE. WHICH THE INITIAL FISCAL
ANALYSIS. PREDATED THE FEE BEING
ADJUSTED SO THAT IT CAN BE
RATCHETED UP TO COVER THE COSTS.
UM THE OTHER PIECE OF GOOD NEWS
IS THEY MAY NOT BE AS EXPENSIVE
AS PROPOSED. I WHEN I WORKED A
CAR BY NO, WE IMPLEMENTED. KIND
OF THE BEST IN CLASS ROLLS ROYCE
OF REPORTING PROGRAMS IN THE
MANDATORY REPORTING OF
GREENHOUSE GASSES. THE MOST
EXACTING PROGRAM KNOWN UM, IT
MIGHT BE POSSIBLE TO DO THESE ON
A LESS STRINGENT BASIS, LESS
EXPENSIVE BASIS THAT DOESN'T
REQUIRE AS MANY PEOPLE AS THAT.
MANDATORY REPORTING PROGRAM
REQUIRES AH! IN ANY EVENT,
WHATEVER MAKE OR MODEL CAN GET.
FUNDED FOR THIS, UM THIS IS NOT
A CAN. I DON'T NEED TO TELL THIS
GROUP THE CLIMATE IS NOT A CAN.
WE CAN KICK DOWN THE ROAD LIKE
TO SEE THAT FUNDED. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE IT. MR
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
LOUIS BROWN HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA GROCERIES
ASSOCIATION. I WANT TO
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
REGARDING THE LOAN FROM THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER REDEMPTION
FUND. WE ARE OPPOSED TO THAT
LOAN. WE'VE SEEN SOME OF THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE
BOTTLE BILL IN HIS 30 YEAR
HISTORY OVER JUST THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND AS WE MOVE
TO A TRANSITION, WHICH INCLUDES
A DEALER COOPERATIVE AND THE
EXPANSION OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO REDEEM. WE BELIEVE
THOSE FUNDS IN THAT FUN ARE
NECESSARY TO STAY THERE TO
SUPPORT IT. WITHOUT THOSE FUNDS.
THE ENTIRE INFRASTRUCTURE HAS
BEEN ALLIES. DO WE'VE SEEN IT
HAPPEN BEFORE? IT'S
UNPREDICTABLE TO LOOK AT WHAT
MAY HAPPEN IN THAT SYSTEM, AND
THEREFORE WE THINK THAT THOSE
FUNDS SHOULD REMAIN WHERE
THEY'RE INTENDED TO BE, WHICH IS
FOR THE CONSUMERS AND
REDEMPTION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR CHAIR
MEMBERS, ROSS BUCKLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT. WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE FUNDING BEING
PROVIDED FOR THE 617 PROGRAMS
LIKE GOVERNORS PROPOSED BUDGET
FOR AIR DISTRICTS AND
LAMENTATION INCENTIVES,
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE BUDGET
SHORTFALL REQUESTS THAT
CONTINUED PARTICIPATION OF THE A
B 617 FUNDING, WHICH THE HAS
PREVIOUSLY CONFIRMED AS HIGHLY
COST EFFECTIVE, ADDRESSING AIR
QUALITY PUBLIC HEALTH IN CLIMATE
CHALLENGES. CURRENTLY THE 617
PROGRAM IS SEVERELY UNDERFUNDED.
THE NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES
STATEWIDE HAS CONTINUED TO GROW,
BUT THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THOSE
EXISTING COMMUNITIES. TO FURTHER
THIS POINT. THE SOUTH COAST
REGION CONTAINS ALMOST TWO
THIRDS OF THE EJ COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE. WE CANNOT, HOWEVER,
ADD ADDITIONAL 617 COMMUNITY DUE
TO THE LACK OF RESOURCES TO HELP
ADDRESS THIS DIRECTLY ASKED THE
SIX AND SEVEN PROGRAM FUNDING
ABUSE TOWARD TO LAST YEAR'S
LEVEL. THIS WILL ONE HELP COVER
ACTUAL PROGRAM COSTS AND TO COST
EFFECTIVELY REDUCED EMISSIONS
THAT HELP MEET FEDERAL AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS AND PROTECT
THE HEALTH OF THIS MANAGED
COMMUNITY STATEWIDE. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR CHAIR AND MR
ALLEN AND STAFF ABRAHAM MENDOZA,
ON BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER WERE AN ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS
DIRECTLY WITH IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES ALONG THE CENTRAL
COAST AND IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY TO FILL THE HUMAN RIGHTS
OF WATER IN CALIFORNIA. IN THE
2023 BUDGET CYCLE, THE
LEGISLATURE DELAYED
APPROXIMATELY 200 MILLION IN
FUNDING FROM DRINKING WATER AND
WASTEWATER PROJECTS. NOW THAT
FUNDING WAS RESTORED UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S JANUARY 10TH BUDGET
PROPOSAL, AND WE'RE URGING
YOURSELVES IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
PRESERVE THAT FUNDING. AS WE
RECEIVED SEVERAL REPORTS THAT A
NUMBER OF THESE SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS AND OTHERS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE WERE
IMMEDIATELY HALTED WHEN THOSE
CUTS WERE PROPOSED. SECONDLY
SEVERAL OF OUR ADVOCACY PARTNERS
REGIONALLY JOINED US IN
AUTHORING A LETTER EXPRESSING
CONCERN OVER THE LEOS
ALTERNATIVE RECOMMENDATION THAT
THE STATE UTILIZE SAFER FUNDING
AND FEDERAL SRF DOLLARS TO
BACKFILL STATE RESOURCES AND
BUDGET FUNDING. S¼ FOR FUNDING
PROVIDES MORE THAN JUST
INFRASTRUCTURE. IT PROVIDES
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR MORE
THAN 350 WATER SYSTEMS THAT ARE
GOING THROUGH CONSOLIDATION, AND
IT ALSO PROVIDES PROVISIONS OF
DIRECT EMERGENCY AID TO
COMMUNITIES LIKE BOTTLED WATER
DELIVERY. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROTECT SAFER SO
THAT A PIPELINE OF PROJECTS
PROVIDING ACCESS TO SAFE WATER
FOR UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES CAN
CONTINUE TO BE DEVELOPED. AND
LASTLY, UNDER THE CURRENT
PROPOSED HOUSE BUDGET AGREEMENT,
CONGRESS REDUCES SRF FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS TO THE STATE WATER
BOARD FROM 91 MILLION TO 4
MILLION AND 113 MILLION TO 4.5
MILLION, RESPECTIVELY. OUR STATE
CAN DEPEND ON CONGRESS TO ALIGN
THEIR SPENDING PRIORITIES WITH
OURS, AND WE NEED TO PRESERVE
THESE INVESTMENTS AND ENSURE
THAT PROGRESS IS NOT LOST ON
DELIVERING SAFE, CLEAN AND
AFFORDABLE WATER TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MARISA WOO WITH THE GREENLINING
INSTITUTE FOR THE SECOND YEAR IN
A ROW, THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET DEBILITATES EQUITY
FOCUSED CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS THAT CRITICALLY
MITIGATE THE IMPACTS OF
POLLUTION AND INCREASE ACCESS TO
CLEAN MOBILITY OPTIONS FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR,
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS ARE NOT OPTIONAL. NICE
TO HAVE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES DISPROPORTIONATELY
CARRY THE BURDEN OF POLLUTION
ACROSS THE STATE, WHICH I
APPRECIATED THAT YOU UPLIFTED.
EARLIER, SENATOR THESE PROGRAMS
ARE TOO OFTEN FIRST UP ON THE
CHOPPING BLOCK AS FUNDING HAS
INCREASINGLY AND UNSUSTAINABLY
DEPENDENT ON GDR F IN RECENT
YEARS, THESE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS WHICH
WERE ALREADY UNDERFUNDED SINCE
THEIR INCEPTION, HAVING FORCED
INTO DISRUPTIVE, STOP AND GO
CYCLE, CREATING UNCERTAINTY FOR
COMMUNITIES. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE NO FURTHER
CUTS OR DELAYS TO INVESTMENTS
FOR CLEAN TRANSPORTATION AND
MOBILITY PROGRAMS LIKE CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL CLAIM ABILITY,
PROGRAMS AND MEDIUM HEAVY DUTY
PROGRAMS. IT IS ALSO CRITICAL
THAT WE CREATE A STABLE AND
DEDICATED FUNDING SOURCE FOR
THESE PROGRAMS TO ENSURE THAT WE
GET BACK ON TRACK FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE GOALS AND
ARE FIGHTING EMISSIONS AND
IMPROVING PUBLIC HEALTH FOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO
CHAIR. BECKER CAN YOU HEAR ME
AND SENATOR ALLEN STAFF? NICE TO
MEET YOU. ALL MY NAME IS DYLAN
FINLEY. AND I AM HERE ON BEHALF
OF US, YOUR BUSINESS COUNCIL AND
THE SIERRA CONSORTIUM. WE WANTED
TO LET THE COMMITTEE KNOW THAT
WE ARE HAPPY WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FUNDING TO VARIOUS
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCE
PROGRAMS. THIS INCLUDES THE
REGIONAL FOREST AND FIRE
CAPACITY PROGRAM, WHICH IS
UTILIZED FOR A WIDE RANGE OF
ACTIVITIES. WE APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THIS COMMITTEE AND STAFF
AND HOPE TO SEE CONTINUED
INVESTMENTS IN WILDFIRE FOREST
RESILIENCE PROGRAMS IN THIS
BUDGET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR. BECKER AND
SENATOR ALLEN. MY NAME IS KIRK
WILBUR. I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION WANTED
TO BRIEFLY SPEAK TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
BUDGET SPECIFICALLY URGE YOU TO
RENEW FUNDING THIS YEAR FOR THE
DEPARTMENT'S WOLF LIVESTOCK
COMPENSATION FUND. IN ADDITION
TO HELPING MAKE WHOLE RANCHERS
WHO MAY BE IMPACTED BY WOLVES RE
EMERGING ON THE LANDSCAPE.
THERE'S TWO VITAL FUNCTIONS OF
THAT PROGRAM. ONE IS IT REDUCES
WOLF LIVESTOCK AND WOLF HUMAN
CONFLICTS BY ALLOWING FOR NON
LETHAL DETERRENCE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THAT FURTHERS THE
DEPARTMENT'S GOALS OF WOLF
CONSERVATION IN THE STATE. IT'S
ALSO GOOD FOR WOLVES THEMSELVES
AND GOOD FOR THE SAFETY OF
LIVESTOCK HERDS. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY, THAT PROGRAM
INCREASES TOLERANCE OF WOLVES IN
THE RURAL LANDSCAPE, WHICH HAS
ALLOWED THAT SPECIES TO THRIVE
IN CALIFORNIA. A PRIORITY. I
THINK FOR MOST FOLKS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO WE WOULD
ASK YOU TO RENEW FUNDING FOR
THAT PROGRAM THIS YEAR THAT
INITIAL OUTLAY OF $3 MILLION
CARRIED THAT PROGRAM FOR 29
MONTHS ARE MUCH MORE MODEST
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THIS YEAR
WOULD STILL ALLOW THE MOST VITAL
PORTIONS OF THAT PROGRAM TO
CONTINUE ON FOR THE NEXT YEAR,
AT LEAST, SO JUST URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER SOME AMOUNT OF FUNDING
FOR THAT PROGRAM, WHICH HAS NOW
BEEN FULLY ENCUMBERED BASED ON
ITS PRIOR FUNDING ALLOCATIONS.
THANK YOU. GOD. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MELANIE ROLLS WITH
THE GREENLINING INSTITUTE. WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF FUNDING
SP 253 FOR CARB IN ORDER TO
PREVENT ANY DELAYS TO THE
STATUTE WITH THE DEADLINE
STATUTE THAT ARE ALREADY IN LINE
. UM WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE SCC
RULING IS LIKELY COME OUT NEXT
WEEK AND SCOPE THREE EMISSIONS
DISCLOSURES IS LIKELY NOT TO BE
PLACED THE NEW ROLLING SO IT'S
VERY IMPERATIVE THAT WE GET IT
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I ALSO
WANT TO MENTION THAT WE'RE VERY
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE REGIONAL
CLIMATE COLLABORATIVE PROGRAM
WAS CUT BY $10 MILLION. THERE'S
OVER 270 ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN SPENDING A LOT OF TIME
APPLYING FOR THIS PROGRAM,
INCLUDING SGC. THAT WAS JUST
ABOUT TO ROLL OUT THOSE AWARDS
THIS MONTH, BUT SINCE IT WAS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE JAN BUDGET, IT
MAKES IT REALLY HARD TO GET OUT
THAT MONEY THAT WAS ALREADY
READY TO GO. UM AND I LAST THING
I'LL MENTION ABOUT THE RCC
PROGRAM IS THAT IT'S UM,
DIRECTED TOWARDS VERY CRITICAL,
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
IN DESPERATE NEED OF STATE AND
FEDERAL CLIMATE INVESTMENTS. THE
LAST THING I'LL SAY IS WE REALLY
URGE THE SENATE BUDGET AND THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET TO RESTORE AS
MUCH MONEY AS POSSIBLE FOR THE
TRANSFORMATIVE CLIMATE
COMMUNITIES PROGRAM THAT YOU'RE
VERY FAMILIAR WITH MR BECKER AS
MUCH AS THE 200 MILLION THAT WAS
CUT IN PREVIOUS BUDGET
NEGOTIATIONS. THIS IS A
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED HERE IN CALIFORNIA,
SERVING RURAL UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES AND TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON. SENATORS
TAYLOR, RUSSIAN ON BEHALF OF A
COALITION OF AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATIONS, WE WERE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE FARMER
PROGRAM AT CARB WASN'T PROPOSED
TO BE FUNDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET, STATE INVESTMENTS AND
FARMERS AND FARMERS HAVE
LEVERAGED BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL ASSETS AND MATCHING
FUNDS FROM FARMERS ACROSS THE
STATE TO INVEST IN DIESEL
TRACTOR EMISSION UPGRADES,
INCLUDING THE TRANSITION TO ZERO
AND NEAR ZERO ACADEMICIAN
EQUIPMENT. THE PROGRAM PROVIDES
IMMEDIATE AND DURABLE EMISSION
REDUCTION BENEFITS AND AIR
QUALITY BENEFITS TO THE STATE'S
MOST DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
AND I KNOW THE ELIO SPOKE TODAY
ABOUT HOW DO WE SHOW THE VALUE
FOR OUR INVESTMENT? SINCE 2018.
THE PROGRAM HAS TURNED OVER
12,000 PIECES OF AGRICULTURAL
EQUIPMENT, UM, REDUCED 368,000
METRIC TONS OF CO 2 16,000 TONS
OF PARTICULAR MATTER. AND 26,000
TONS OF NOX, SO CONSIDERING THIS
YEAR'S INVESTMENT SHOULD BE
REALLY FOCUSED ON DEMONSTRATED
SUCCESS AND FINANCIAL
EFFICIENCY. WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO FUND FARMER. WE'D
ALSO LIKE TO ECHO SUPPORT FOR
SUPPLANTING FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAM FOR FOOD PROCESSORS AND,
UM REFUNDING ENTERIC METHANE
REDUCTION PROGRAMS. THANKS SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. AFTERNOON MR
TERROR CENTER ALLINGER SHE
GEHRINGER WITH AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA. THANKS
FOR STICKING IT OUT WITH SOME OF
US HERE AT THE END. UM
DEFINITELY WANT TO ECHO THE
PRIOR SPEAKER, MS ROSHAN HER
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF THE
FARMER PROGRAM, BUT I'M ALSO
HERE AND SUPPORT. SHE MENTIONED
THE FOOD PRODUCTION INVESTMENT
PROGRAM, OTHERWISE KNOWN AS F
PIP AT THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. REALLY IMPORTANTLY,
THIS PROGRAM IS OVER. 80% OF THE
FUNDS FROM THIS PROGRAM IS GOING
INTO PROJECTS AND DISADVANTAGED
AND LOW AND UM, COMMUNITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY THERE IS NO NEW
DOLLARS IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
. AND AS THE ALEJO'S ANALYSIS
HAD NOTED, THERE IS A REVERSION
OF 19 MILLION FROM EXISTING
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND DOLLARS SO
AS UNDERSTANDING THE CHALLENGING
BUDGET YEAR AND AS YOU CONSIDER
AND WEIGH OUR OPTIONS, WE WOULD
ASK THAT FUNDING BE SUPPLANTED
FROM G R F FOR ANY LOSSES TO
THAT PROGRAM, GIVEN THIS IS A
SMALL BUT MIGHTY GRANT PROGRAM
FOR LOCAL GO FOOD PRODUCERS TO
LOWER THEIR EMISSIONS, IMPROVED
ENERGY EFFICIENCIES WHILE THEY
PROCESS FOOD GROWN RIGHT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA, IMPORTANTLY, I'VE
PEP IS IN THE TOP 10. IT'S
RANKED IN THE TOP 10 OUT OF ALL
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF
TOTAL GHG REDUCTIONS AND COST
PER TON OF GHD, SO WE HOPE
YOU'LL CONSIDER THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE PROGRAM.
THE FACT THAT THERE ISN'T A
FEDERAL ALTERNATIVE AND ALSO
THAT IT'S BENEFITING PRIORITY
POPULATION. SO THANKS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, SENATOR BECKER. SENATOR
ALAN MICHAEL BROKE A DOOR ON
BEHALF OF OUR EGG AND DAIRY
CLIENTS VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS
REGARDING THE ENTERIC EARLY
ADOPTER PROGRAM, WHICH, OF
COURSE YOU CREATED LAST YEAR. WE
SHARE YOUR CONCERNS WITH THE
LOSS OF FUNDING. WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH YOU ON RESTORING
FUNDING TO THAT PROGRAM, WHETHER
THROUGH G, R F OR SOME OTHER
CREATIVE SOLUTION. THE TIMING
FOR THAT IS CRITICAL. AS YOU
HEARD FROM CDFA. WE ARE FINALLY
GOING TO HAVE A PRODUCT
AVAILABLE FOR USE TO BEGIN
REDUCING ENTERIC METHANE AND THE
DAIRY AND LIVESTOCK INDUSTRIES
IN THE STATE. CRITICAL THAT WE
DO THAT AS WE PRIORITIZE FUNDING
FOR CLIMATE IMPORTANT TO KEEP IN
MIND THE IMPORTANCE OF
CONTINUING TO REDUCE NOTHING. WE
KNOW THAT'S OUR ONLY HOPE OF
ACHIEVING THE, UH, PARIS CLIMATE
ACCORD BY 2030 IS BEING ABLE TO
OFFSET SOME OF THE CONTINUING TO
ACCUMULATES CARBON DIOXIDE
EMISSIONS IN THE ATMOSPHERE
BASED SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCING
METHANE IN THE SHORT TERM. AND
SO THESE PROGRAMS BECOME EVEN
MORE CRITICAL. AND SO I HOPE WE
MAINTAIN FOCUS ON REDUCING
METHANE, BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO GET THAT
FUNDING RESTORED. THANK YOU.
GREAT. THANK YOU. MR CHAIR
SENATOR AROUND CHRIS REARDON,
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU. UM TWO
ISSUES REALLY WANT TO CHAT WITH,
UH, WITH ABOUT VERSUS THE WOLF
COMPENSATION FUND THAT WE TALKED
GENTLEMEN TALKED ABOUT EARLIER.
LOOK WE'RE SEEING WOLF
POPULATIONS GROW IN THIS STATE,
AND THEY HAVE OVER THE LAST 3 TO
5 YEARS. NOW WE FIND WOLF PACKS
IN TILLERY COUNTY. SO WHEN YOU
LOOK BETWEEN THE R AND THE
NORTHEAST PART OF THE STATE
UNTIL EVERY COUNTY FROM FROM
ARRANGING PERSPECTIVE, WE KNOW
THEY'RE GOING TO FILL IN THOSE
DIFFERENT PARTS OF STATE AS
WELL. IF WE LOSE THIS RESOURCE
OF THESE FUNDS, THERE IS NO WAY
WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
COMPASS. FOR SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGES, MANY OF OUR WRENCH
IS GOING TO FACE WITH AN
INCREASED POPULATION. OF WALLS
IN THE COMING YEAR, SO I WANTED
TO MAKE SURE YOU PUT THAT ON
YOUR REAR. IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US. WE KNOW LIKE EVERYONE ELSE
HAS INDICATED TOUGH BUDGET YEAR
BUT AT LEAST SOME ABILITY TO
SORT OF KEEP THIS PROGRAM GOING
TILL THINGS GET ROSIER, SO TO
SPEAK. SECONDLY, THE FARMER
PROGRAM REALLY IMPORTANT PROGRAM
FOR MANY OF US IN AGRICULTURAL,
UH WE THINK IT'S A RELATIVELY
MINOR INVESTMENT. YES,
150,000,002 YEARS AGO, 75 LAST
YEAR, BUT WE LOOK AT THE
IMPLICATIONS OF WHAT IT MEANS
FOR MANY OF THESE COMMUNITIES
AND THEIR INVESTMENTS IN TECHNO
NEW TECHNOLOGIES TO TRANSITION,
SO I THINK WE'RE FOLKS WANT TO
BE RELATED TO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES. IT'S REALLY, REALLY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM CENTERS AND
PROGRAMS WE FOUND IN
AGRICULTURAL, UM, ARE
OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORTED IT HAD
BEEN CONSISTENT WITH WHAT WE'VE
DONE HISTORICALLY IN THE STATES.
I WANTED TO MAKE BRINGING THESE
TWO ISSUES UP, AND THEY'RE JUST
LASTLY WHAT MR BUCKLEY GIL
TALKED ABOUT THE ENTERIC METHANE
REDUCTIONS IMPORTANT AS WELL,
PARTICULARLY IN AREAS AND I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN A LEADER ON THIS
ISSUE, TOO. SO LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AS WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR BECKER AND THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL CLAIBORNE.
I'M A DIRECTING ATTORNEY WITH
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN ADDRESSING
THE BUDGET DEFICIT. THE STATE
CANNOT BE PRIORITIZED
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE OR
UNDERMINE ONGOING WORK TO MEET
BASIC NEEDS IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. AS SUCH, WE REQUEST
FUNDING FOR THREE PRIORITIES OF
COMMUNITIES. I WORK ALONGSIDE.
FIRST WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO RESTORE
200 MILLION FOR DRINKING WATER
AND WASTEWATER INFRASTRUCTURE
AND DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES,
WHICH WAS DELAYED IN THE 2023
BUDGET. CONTRARY TO THE L. A S
ANALYSIS, THIS FUNDING WILL
POTENTIAL PRIMARILY GO TO FUND
SEWER EXTENSION PROJECTS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE SERVED BY FAILING SEPTIC
TANKS AND SEWAGE LAGOONS.
THERE'S NOTHING MORE BASIC AND
ESSENTIAL THAN ADEQUATE
SANITATION AND ACCESS TO THAT
SAFE DRINKING WATER, AND EVEN
THE 2023 DELAY, SLOWDOWN
PROJECTS AND COMMUNITIES I WORK
WITH, LIKE MATHENY TRACKED. WE
HAVE POST CUTS TO SECOND. WE
OPPOSE CUTS TO EQUITABLE BOOK
EQUITABLE BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION PROGRAM THAT IS
ESSENTIAL TO MEETING OUR
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE TARGETS AND TO
ENSURING THAT LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS CAN ACCESS CRITICAL
INVESTMENTS. WE FURTHER OPPOSED
CUTS, UH, TO FUNDING FOR THE
SALTON SEA. UH PROJECTS TO
ADDRESS THE AIR QUALITY CRISIS
IN THE EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY.
THAT IS QUITE LITERALLY
SHORTENING THE LIVES OF FOLKS I
WORK WITH. AS A FINAL POINT. WE
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH THE 150,
PLUS ORGANIZATIONS,
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS CALLING
FOR AN EQUITABLE CLIMATE
RESILIENT SPAWNED THAT COMPORTS
WITH JUSTICE 40 PRINCIPLES BY
ENSURING THAT 40% OF THE BOND
GOES DIRECTLY TO PRIORITIES OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. AND
WE THANK SENATOR ALLEN FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS SAM GREENLEE. I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF ALCHEMIST.
CDC OF FOOD SYSTEMS NONPROFIT
SERVING THE SACRAMENTO REGION.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF
THE STATEWIDE SAVE MARKET MATCH
COALITION TO ASK FOR THE FULL
RESTORATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
NUTRITION INCENTIVE PROGRAM,
ALSO KNOWN AS SEEN IT IN THE
BUDGET. LAST YEAR, ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE ORGANIZED THREE
NEW FUNDING FOR SENATE AND
SECURED $35 MILLION IN THIS
BUDGET. THIS NUMBER REPRESENTS
YEARS OF GRASSROOTS NONPROFIT
WORK LOCALLY AND ACROSS
CALIFORNIA, BUILDING AN
EFFECTIVE SAFETY NET. FOR
CALIFORNIA SMALL FARMS AND LOW
INCOME FAMILIES. IT'S NOT SIMPLY
A ONE TIME ALLOCATION, BUT THE
RENEWAL OF A LONG RUNNING
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM. THE PROPOSED
$33 MILLION IN CUTS TO SINOP.
WOULD UNDERCUT THIS WORK, KILL
THE PROGRAM AND LEAVE NO
POSSIBILITY OF A FUTURE RETURN.
IT WOULD LEAVE THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES WITHOUT FRESH FRUIT AND
VEGETABLES AND ACCELERATE THE
LOSS OF CALIFORNIA'S SMALL AND
MIDSIZE FARMS. IT WILL ALSO
LEAVE TENS OF MILLIONS AND
MATCHING FEDERAL FUNDS ON THE
TABLE. IN FACT, AT THIS VERY
MOMENT, CDF IS MISSING OUT ON
ABOUT $12 MILLION FROM AN OPEN
FEDERAL NUTRITION INCENTIVE
APPLICATION BECAUSE IT'S SIMPLY
LACKS AUTHORIZATION FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO MAKE
USE OF BUDGETED FUNDS AS STATE
MATCH. I ASKED YOU TO REJECT THE
PROPOSAL TO CUT SEEN IT. AND
RECENTLY ALL 35 MILLION THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY APPROVED IN THE 2023
24 BUDGET ACT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
BACKERS SENATOR ALLEN EDDIE
KARAMIRA ON BEHALF OF VALLEY
CLEANER NOW IMPLEMENTING THE
CLEAN CURSE FOR ALL PROGRAM IN
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY. AS YOU
ALL KNOW, THAT'S THE REGION WITH
THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE
ENTIRE UNITED STATES. JUST ALIGN
MY COMMENTS WITH YOU, SENATOR
BECKER AS WELL AS UM BILL
MCGOVERN FROM COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR, AND, UM, MEMBERS OF
GREENLINING OF JUST HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO MAINTAIN.
PARTICULARLY THOSE EQUITY
INVESTMENTS IN THE PACKAGE AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
ENGAGE WITH YOU ALL AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE AND UP IN THE FINAL BUDGET
VEHICLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR CHAIR AND
SENATOR ALLEN JAMIE MORRIGAN ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION AND ALSO
REPRESENTING IN CHILD POVERTY BY
TO THE LINE. MY COMMENTS WITH MR
GREENLAND. WE ARE A MEMBER OF
THE SAVED MARKET MATCH COALITION
AND JUST WANT TO URGE YOU TO
PRESERVE FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM
. WE KNOW THAT A HEALTHY DIET IS
KEY TO PREVENTING CHRONIC
DISEASES SUCH AS HEART DISEASE.
AND THIS IS TRULY A CRITICAL
FOOD SAFETY NET PROGRAM AND
WHICH IS LIKE TERRITORY TO
PRESERVE THE FUNDING. THANK YOU.
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR CHAIR,
SENATOR DAHLE AND STUFF. MY NAME
IS DARRYLL LITTLE JUNIOR ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL FOR CALIFORNIA
TO CONTINUE REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS AND AIR POLLUTION. WE MUST
REMAIN STEADFAST AND ADDRESSING
TRANSPORTATION BY INVESTING IN
PUBLIC TRANSIT AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION. DOING SO OR
REDUCE POLLUTION FROM BOTH CARS
AND TRUCKS WHILE CREATING SAFER
AND MORE ACCESSIBLE COMMUNITIES
FOR CALIFORNIA. WE CALL ON THE
LEGISLATURE TO REVERSE THE
PROPOSED $200 MILLION CUT TOO
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION. BY
ALLOCATING 200 MILLION FUNDING
FROM THE STATE HIGHWAY ACCOUNT
OR BY LEVERAGING THE STATUTORY
FLEXIBILITY OF FORMULA FEDERAL
SURFACE TRANSPORTATION FUNDING.
WE WOULD ALSO LIKE TO SEE THE
REVERSAL OF THE PROPOSED $283
MILLION CUT TO BUILDING THE CAR
PROJECTS PROGRAMS. THE BUILDING
D CARD PROGRAMS AT THE CC MAKE
TECHNOLOGIES ACCESSIBLE AND ARE
CRITICAL TO HELPING LOW INCOME
CONSUMERS WITH THE CARBONATE IN
THEIR HOMES IN OUR D C WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO SEE THE REVERSAL OF
THE PROPOSED CUTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL RESILIENCE
BUDGET. WE MUST REMAIN COMMITTED
TO MITIGATING THE IMPACTS OF SEA
LEVEL RISE STORMS AND COASTAL
FLOODING. ADDITIONALLY WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE LEGISLATURE
REINSTATES $33 MILLION FUND IS
IN FUNDS FOR THE RETENTION
INCENTIVES PROGRAM FOR $10
MILLION IN FUNDS FOR THE FARM
COMMUNITY FOOD HUBS PROGRAM AND
$13 MILLION INFORMS TO THE
UNDERSERVED AND SMALL PRODUCER
PROGRAM. WE ALSO REQUEST FOR
FUNDING FOR THE FARM TO SCHOOL
INCUBATOR PROGRAM, FOR WHICH CDF
IS CURRENTLY SOLICITING
APPLICATIONS. THESE PROGRAMS
SERVE LOW INCOME FAMILIES, AS
WELL AS SMALLER AND UNDERSERVED
FARMERS. WE ALSO REQUEST THAT
FUNDING FOR THE LIVESTOCK
METHANE REDUCTION PROGRAM BE
SHIFTED INSTEAD TO THE
ALTERNATIVE MANURE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM AT CDF, A WHICH IS
CURRENTLY WHICH IS CHRONICALLY
OVERSUBSCRIBED, UNDERFUNDED AND
HELPS FARMERS ADOPT PROVEN
METHANE REDUCTION STRATEGIES
FINANCIALLY. WE URGED THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN THE ENTIRE SUITE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING PROGRAMS
AT CDF, A HOPEFUL LIKE CLIMATE
CHANGE AND DROUGHT, WHILE ALSO
HELPING FARMERS PREPARE FOR
FLOODS AND WILDFIRES. CALIFORNIA
BECAME A NATIONAL LEADER ON ON
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING BY MAKING
IT EASIER AND AFFORDABLE FOR
FARMERS TO USE SUSTAINABLE
PRACTICES. CALIFORNIA MUST
CONTINUE FUNDING THESE PROGRAMS
THAT ALL FARMERS ARE ABLE TO
MAKE THAT TRANSITION. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON CHAIR BECKER, SENATOR
ALAN I'M MARK FENCE TO MAKE HER
HERE ON TWO ITEMS FIRST FOR
EARTH JUSTICE WANT TO ECHO THE
CALLS FOR PRESERVING OR ZERO
MISSION VEHICLE BUDGET AND WANT
TO PARTICULARLY RAISE OUR
CONCERN WITH THE LAOS
RECOMMENDATION ON ELIMINATING
THE ZERO EMISSION SCHOOL BUS
FUNDING? UM WE REALLY VALUE THAT
FUNDING GOING FORWARD IS THIS IS
GOING TO HELP US ACHIEVE OUR
CLIMATE GOALS ARE CLEAN AIR
GOALS WHILE REDUCING EXPOSURE
FOR OUR SCHOOLCHILDREN. UM
SECOND ON BEHALF OF THE
COACHELLA VALLEY CONSERVATION
COMMISSION. WE'D ASK THAT YOU
REJECT THE PROPOSED CUT TO THE
COACHELLA VALLEY MOUNTAIN
CONSERVANCIES. WILDFIRE BUDGET.
UM, WILDFIRE THREAT IN THE
DESERT IS REAL AND IS OFTEN
OVERLOOKED IN OUR WILDFIRE
FUNDING. UM AND DC BMC IS READY
TO GO WITH THIS FUNDING. THEY
WERE SET IN JANUARY. THEIR
PROPOSAL WITH THAT $9 MILLION TO
PUT IT OUT IN THREE DIFFERENT
CHUNKS ONE FOR PROJECTS FOR
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES, ONE
FOR PROJECTS IMPLEMENTED BY
TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS IN THE LAST
FOUR PROJECTS IMPLEMENTED
ALIGNED WITH THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION PLAN. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY. THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS KATHY MOSSBERG
ON BEHALF OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTITUTE, AND THEIR PROJECT
ROOTS OF CHANGE. WANT TO ALIGN
MYSELF WITH MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
ALREADY SPOKEN ABOUT THE NEEDS
OF THE SENATE PROGRAM. JUST
HIGHLIGHT IN DETAIL. JUST A
COUPLE OF PIECES ON THAT, UM,
OVER THE COURSE OF THE SENATE
PROGRAM WE HAVE BROUGHT IN OVER
WE HAVE BROUGHT IN $30,000,030
MILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDS WERE
SLATED, AS WAS NOTED BEFORE TO
BRING IN MORE IF WE CONTINUE
THIS PROGRAM, THIS PROGRAM IS A
TIME TESTED 15 YEAR OLD SAFETY
NET PROGRAMS SERVING OVER HALF A
MILLION CAL FRESH RECIPIENTS
WITH FRESH FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES. EVERY DAY AND WE
THINK IT'S WE KNOW IT'S A TRIPLE
WIN FOR BOTH FOOD SECURITY
FARMERS FARMER SUPPORT IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA AND HEALTH EQUITY AND
WE REALLY ENCOURAGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO MAINTAIN THE
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HELLO HAPPY LEAP DAY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY TO SENATOR BLAKE SPEAR
IF SHE'S LISTENING MELISSA WITH
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS,
I WANT TO SAY THAT WE REALLY
WANT TO URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
SEND A STRONG SIGNAL NOW THAT
FUNDING FOR THE TWO BIGGEST
CLIMATE LAWS THAT WERE PASSED
LAST YEAR IN THE COUNTRY WILL BE
FUNDED THIS YEAR AS P 253, THE
CLIMATE CORPORATE ACCOUNTABILITY
ACT IN SP 261 THE CLIMATE
FINANCIAL RISK DISCLOSURE ACT.
OUR NEW LAWS THAT ARE ALREADY
CREATING RIPPLE EFFECTS GLOBALLY
TO SET THE BAR FOR EMISSIONS
REPORTING AND TRANSPARENCY. NEXT
WEEK, THE SECURITY EXCHANGE
COMMISSION IS GOING TO BE
RELEASING THEIR CLIMATE
DISCLOSURE ROLE, AND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE CALIFORNIA
LAWS WILL BE MADE VERY, VERY
CLEAR, AND THE LEGISLATURE ALSO
NEEDS TO MAKE VERY CLEAR THAT IT
IS A HIGH PRIORITY TO FUND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE TWO LAWS
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET. I ALSO
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE
BY ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA TO
URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO END OIL
AND GAS SUBSIDIES. THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY HAS
IDENTIFIED ALMOST 9 BILLION WITH
A B DOLLARS THAT WE COULD
INSTEAD BE DIRECTING TO CLIMATE
INVESTMENTS THAT ARE RIGHT NOW
SUBSIDIZING THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY IN THE FORM OF TAX
CREDITS AND TAX EXPENDITURES.
FINALLY, CLIMATE BOND THIS YEAR
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL TO
ADDRESS THE VERY REAL THREAT TO
OUR LIVES AND OUR LIVELIHOODS IN
THE FACE OF WORSENING CLIMATE
CHANGE, AND FOR EVERY DOLLAR
THAT WE DON'T SPEND THIS YEAR ON
CLIMATE WILL BE SPENDING MANY,
MANY TIMES OVER IN THE FORM OF
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT AND PUBLIC
HEALTH COSTS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND WE DO LIKE WHEN OUR
BILLS THAT WE PASS GET FUNDED,
SO THANK YOU, UM, GOOD COMING
DOWN THE HOME STRETCH HERE TOO
MUCH LONGER. I PROMISE. MEGAN
MARKLE BERG HERE ON BEHALF OF
THEM IN MID PENINSULA REGIONAL
OPEN SPACE DISTRICT, EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARKS DISTRICT, THE
LAND TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY,
SAVE THE REDWOODS LEAGUE, THE
CENTER OF IRAN'S FUND AND
CALIFORNIA STATE PARK FOUNDATION
, ALL EXPRESSING STRONG CONCERN
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
CUTS TO FUNDING FOR THE W C B IN
COASTAL RESILIENCY. WE
ADDITIONALLY URGED THE
LEGISLATURE TO REFRAIN FROM
PULLING BACK ON FUNDING FOR
SEVERAS TRIBAL NATURE BASED
SOLUTIONS PROGRAM. BY PULLING
BACK THIS FUNDING. WE WILL BE
SENDING OURSELVES BACK YEARS AND
IMPLEMENTING PROJECTS ON THE
GROUND. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, JAMIE MINOR ON
BEHALF OF WEST BASIN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT. UM JUST WANT TO
ECHO WHAT BETHEL ALSO ON BEHALF
OF WATERY YOU SAID ABOUT THE
WATER RECYCLING FUNDS ALREADY
BEING ALLOCATED ALMOST OUT THE
DOOR FOR A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
PROJECTS AND, UNFORTUNATELY
HAVING TO BE PULLED BACK,
OBVIOUSLY, WATER RECYCLING IS
ESSENTIAL TO UPDATING OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE, MEETING OUR
WATER SUPPLY TARGETS BUT ALSO IN
AN AFFORDABLE WAY. UM SO
APPRECIATE GETTING THAT FUNDING
RESTORED JUST SINCE THOSE
PROJECTS ARE SO CLOSE TO THE
FINISH LINE. THANKS. THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS JOHN NORWOOD ON BEHALF
OF THE ALMOND ALLIANCE AND ARE
7600 MEMBERS AND OVER 100
PROCESSORS. WE TOO, ARE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THE FARMER
FUNDS WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET AND
WOULD ENCOURAGE THE SUBCOMMITTEE
AID REVIEW THIS SUCCESS OF THIS
PROGRAM TO DATE IN REDUCING
EMISSIONS AND PROVIDING
IMMEDIATE AIR QUALITY BENEFITS
TO THE MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. MANY OF OUR MEMBERS
USE THESE FUNDS TO RETIRE OLD
DIESEL BASED EQUIPMENT, AND I
WOULD JUST REITERATE THE
COMMENTS MADE EARLIER ABOUT THE
SUCCESS OF THIS PROGRAM IN THE
SAND. JOAQUIN VALLEY WHERE SOME
13,000 FARM VEHICLES HAVE BEEN
RETIRED AND SUBSTANTIAL
REDUCTION IN EMISSIONS, SO WE
UNDERSTAND THAT BUDGET PROBLEMS
IN CALIFORNIA, BUT WE THINK THAT
THE $150 MILLION REQUESTED BY
THE INDUSTRY IS APPROPRIATE,
GIVEN THE SIX SUCCESS OF THE
PROGRAM AND JUST REALLY QUICKLY
FOR ONE OTHER CLIENT ON BEHALF
OF THE INDEPENDENT INSURANCE
AGENTS AND BROKERS OF CALIFORNIA
. WE CERTAINLY SUPPORT ANY FUNDS
THAT HAVE GOING TOWARDS FIRE
RESILIENCY. IT'S REALLY ONE OF
THE KEY. AWAYS THAT CALIFORNIA
IS GOING TO WORK ITS WAY OUT OF
THE CRISIS IN PROPERTY INSURANCE
THAT WE'RE FACING RIGHT NOW. YOU
KNOW, DEALING WITH FIRE
RESILIENCY WILL HAVE A LARGE
EFFECT ON TRYING TO BRING THE
WORLDWIDE REINSURANCE COMMUNITY
BACK INTO SUPPORTING ADMITTED
INSURERS IN THIS STATE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. HERE TO WRAP IT UP. MR
CHAIR, SENATOR ALLEN. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY, CHI
COOPER ON BEHALF OF SERIES,
ECHOING THE OTHER COMMENTS MADE
REGARDING FULL FUNDING FOR
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 253 AND SB
261 COMPANIES ALREADY COMPLY
WITH REPORTING LAWS AND VALUE
THESE FRAMEWORKS LIKE THE GHD
PROTOCOL, AND ULTIMATELY, FILING
FEES WILL COVER THESE
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS. INVESTORS
AND COMPANIES DESERVE
STANDARDIZED DISCLOSURE RULES
AND CANNOT AFFORD A DELAY IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE LAWS. SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU. THAT WAS A GOOD WRAP
UP. I APPRECIATE IT, UM I WANT
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY. THE STAFF
RECOMMENDATION FOR ISSUE NUMBER
ONE IS TO HOLD OPEN. WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA FOR TODAY'S
HEARING. SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TWO IS
ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.